Also eigentlich sind wir ja noch gar nicht Bummsakritern. Noch heißen wir Mobile-Mix von so asexuellen, verschwitzten Nerds.
Wenn du kein Internet-Power-User bist, dann können wir dir hier leider auch nicht helfen.
Stimmt, wenn das Internet eins braucht, dann mehr Sex. Das turnt ihn an. Ich hab mal jemand IPv6.
Wie willst du das schlanke MacBook Air mit Zoll haben? Ich hab mal bei Beardose gearbeitet, da gewinnt man sich einen gewissen Stil an. Wollen wir wieder über Technik reden und Geräte und so? Tja, es wird uns nicht einfach gemacht, Leute. Das kann ich euch sagen.
Wie jetzt?
Wer, warum?
Uns nicht umzubenennen. Ja, also letztes Mal wollten wir noch ein Recently on... Previously on Lost. Sogar das kommt. Dieses Internet, das ist so ein... Das ist wie so eine Wunschdröte. Da kannst du einfach irgendwas reinrufen. Wunschdschungel. So wie du es da reinrufst.
Ich hab den Anfang gar nicht mitbekommen, sagen die dann dann Previously on...
Zuhören. Ganz wichtig.
Ich spiele immer total lustige Sachen.
Hab ich aber auch nicht gehört.
Du hast kein Zeichen gegeben.
Wie lange hatten wir eigentlich daran gesessen?
Wir haben 30 Sekunden lang schon unterm Kopfhörer gesessen und nichts gesagt. Dann denke ich doch mal, dass ihr zuhört. Vielleicht seid ihr nicht in eure überdimensionierten riesen Schlachtschiffen-Mac-Box hineinschauen.
Du hast gesagt, es wird gleich laut.
Ich dachte, wir machen Prinzessin Lea-Lukalai-Kontest.
Hier ist auf jeden Fall immer noch Movamex Ausgabe Nummer 60 in einem fortgesetzten Versuch, sich dagegen zu wehren, sich umzubenennen. Wobei, naja, wir sind so ein bisschen gespart. Du bist ja dafür, Max. Ich bin dafür.
Ich finde das super.
Was für mich noch ein kleines bisschen?
So ein Mühe?
Leiser?
Eins, zwei, drei, ich will lauter sein.
Du willst lauter sein?
Ja, stopp, reicht.
Ich will lauter sein.
Super, jetzt bin ich auch da.
Ich hoffe, dass wir das irgendwann hier bald auch so haben, dass das jeder so für sich selber einstellen kann. Aber dann ist es vorbei hier mit MacBooks. Dann gibt es iPads. Mobile Pads.
Mit vernünftigen Multitasking.
Ich hab ja schon einen Rechner. Mach doch einfach mal so eine App, die ich hab, wo ich hier so meine Regeln hab.
Mach doch mal so eine App, genau.
Das wäre eine echte Geilidee.
Also naja, ich hab, heißt das jetzt auf Mac auch, App. Ich hab eigentlich, wie soll ich sagen?
Ich hab App.
Also ich werde sicherlich selber keine entwickeln. Es ist aber jetzt durchaus vorstellbar, dass es entweder jemand eine entwickelt, oder es schon eine gibt.
Mit Mac Ruby.
Probier noch mal aus, ob diese Internet-Mundströte funktioniert.
Es ist eigentlich nicht so schwierig. Man bräuchte halt nur brauchbares GUI. Das Problem ist nur, das zu bedienen, weil man muss ja wieder diesen Umweg nehmen über die Maus. Wir finden ja irgendwie diese...
Das erste, was ich mit dem Arduino gebastelt habe, war einfach so ein stinknormales, doofes Poti. So einen Drehregler in den Arduino direkt reinstecken und dann mit Ruby, iTunes, Hardware, Volume Control. Gegen ratzfatz, halbe Stunde.
Ja gut, aber dann hast du einen Regler von vielleicht mehreren, die du brauchst. Außerdem musst du das ja digital rausgeschippt bekommen. Das ist schon richtig, ja. Ich sage nicht, dass es unmöglich ist. Ich sage nur, es ist naja.
Wie wird denn hier die Lautstärke geregelt? Also wie müsste man sie denn regeln?
Wahrscheinlich MIDI, oder?
Also wie es derzeit geschieht, ist, dass wir alle in diesen Mixer reingehen, alle dasselbe Signal haben und ich dann für jeden Kopfhörer einen eigenen Regler am Kopfhörerverstärker habe. Das ist sozusagen immer dann problematisch, wenn die Sendung losgeht und jeder hat so andere Vorstellungen davon, wie laut irgendwas sein soll. Abgesehen davon, dass es hier auch noch so ein paar Dinge zu exploren gibt, bezüglich Phasendrehungen und Pipapo, aber grundsätzlich ist es so. Und die Idealvorstellung ist, dass jeder seinen eigenen Mix kriegt. Und jeder seinen eigenen Mix steuert. Das ist theoretisch alles machbar, mit Augs wegen und so weiter. Bloß ist es nichts, was man mal so eben macht, weil das quasi komplexe Mini-Macros erfordert, die du an diesen Mixer schicken musst. Und dazu brauchst du wiederum ein mehr oder weniger generisches User-Interface mit einer Software dahinter, die das dann bündelt und so weiter. Das ist so der Pfad, so grundsätzlich. Ist alles nicht so einfach, wie man sich das so denkt.
Aber könnte nicht jeder einfach seinen eigenen Kopfhörerverstärker unter dem Tisch haben?
Ja, aber wenn du so weit bist, hast du natürlich auch noch diverse andere Vorteile, weil dann ist einerseits natürlich die Stummschaltung, die du derzeit über die V-Mode machst, könnte man dann auch über dasselbe Interface machen. Du könntest auch deine eigene Stimme in der Lautstärke relativ zu den anderen anpassen. Das geht eben jetzt nicht mit einem einfachen Kopfhörerverstärker und tendenziell setze ich eher auf digital, weil wo leben wir denn? Ich meine, das ist ja ja auch digital alles, der Podcast und so.
Sonst würde der Podcast auch eine halbe Stunde früher anfangen, das geht ja nicht. Aber aus dem Kopfhörerverstärker kommt dann analog raus oder auch schon immer noch digital?
Aus dem Kopfhörerverstärker kommt sehr analog raus. Das ist der Ort, wo es wirklich analog wird, wenn es auf dein Ohr trifft. Weil das Digital-Schnittstellchen für den Menschen ist ja so noch nicht erfunden.
Ja, aber ich meine ja auch, das Mikro war am Kopfhörer dran.
Das Mikro ist auch schwer analog. Hab ich dich wieder falsch verstanden?
Nee, ich hab mich falsch ausgedrückt. Also das Ding hängt das auch an diesem Verstärker? Nee, das ist nur für hier Verstärken, für die Ohren.
Welches Ding meinst du denn?
Das Mikro.
Das Mikrofon hängt auch an einem Verstärker, nämlich an einem Mikrofonverstärker.
Ah, dann könnte doch jeder sein Mikro- und Kopfhörerverstärker haben.
Ja, und dann...
Dann könnte man sich zu schmisch immer so mal laut drehen.
Ja, das ist aber...
Wir kennen noch nicht das Problem der mehreren Regler, aber wenn du nämlich hier voll wenig hast, dann musst du nämlich die Anlage voll verstärken. Dadurch wird es aber das Rauschen auch verstärken. Das ist voll für den Arsch.
Ich bin das auf jeden Fall alles schon mal durchgegangen und das ist alles schwierig. Und wie das alles so zusammenhängt, das gedenke ich demnächst ja auch in meinem neuen, anderen Podcast zu erklären.
Ach so, das ist jetzt also ein shameless Self-Plug. Oder wie das auch mal heißt.
Die ganze Sendung ist ein shameless Self-Plug.
In der 60. Folge kommt's endlich mal raus.
Also wer Lust hat, mag ja sicher schon mal den Lautsprecher bei iTunes raussuchen. Das ist so der Kanal.
Wir sind doch hier so eine Werbesendung, oder?
Wir sind eine Werbesendung, nicht nur um Geld.
Kann ich ja kurz Werbung machen, weil wir sind gerade bei Lautsprecher und Audio-Technik.
Ich hab ja letztens...
Passt total rein in unsere Max-Sendung. Letztens von meinen Boxen die Lautsprecher reparieren lassen, weil da waren die Sicken nämlich durch. Und da gibt es lange und partner in Berlin. Es gibt nicht mehr so viele Läden in Deutschland, die sowas machen. Da kann man seine Sicken reparieren lassen. Und die haben das voll super gemacht. Seine Sicken reparieren lassen. Das ist dieser Ring um die Lautsprecher drumrum, der sozusagen die Membranen hält.
Ach so, das, was man anschraubt.
Zwischen dem Ring, den man anschraubt, und dem beweglichen Teil dazwischen ist diese Sicken, die sozusagen...
Das, was die Membranen abfedert und festhält sozusagen.
Genau, genau, genau. Die ist ja aus irgendeinem Gummi oder Schaumstoff. Das wird schon immer porös. Und Boxen hat man immer schon ein paar Jahre länger. Es wird porös, oder die Katzen machen es kaputt. Das ist auch immer sehr beliebt. Und bei den kleinen Boxen kann man sie halt neu kaufen. Bei den teuren ist es halt ein bisschen schade. Und deswegen gibt es da so Reparaturservices. Und D Lange und Partner ist irgendwie in Berlin so ein Laden, der macht sowas. Ich hab auch deutschlandweit schicken die Leute oder ihre Lautsprecher hin und holen. Und hab ich machen lassen, ist voll super. Und meine Box nimmt jetzt wieder 1A.
D Lange und Partner. Ihr Partner in allen Fragen, wenn es um die Sicke geht.
Wie heißen die Dinge?
Sicken.
S-I-C-K-E-N. Das ist dann mehr oder weniger.
Er ist bestimmt nicht in der Sicker, sondern unter Lautsprecherabschnitt. Sicher? Ich hab immer wenig Hoffnung, wenn ich auf die Wikipedia gehe.
Vor allen Dingen auf die deutsche.
Ja, genau, also ich wiederhole mich. Ich hab immer wenig Hoffnung, wenn ich auf die deutsche Wikipedia gehe, wenn es um so, wie soll ich sagen, so separate Begriffe geht. Weil dann ich so in, naja, gefühlt 30 bis 50 Prozent der Fälle so einen Riederekt bekomme auf genereller Artikel, Abschnitt, tralala.
Na, hier steht im letzten Satz, im Lautsprecherbau wird der äußere bewegliche Rand der Membraneinspannung als Sicke bezeichnet, so als...
Correct.
Genau. Und wieso hat man da nicht einen Artikel, einen Artikel, Sicke...
Ist bei Lautsprecher nicht untergeordnet.
Ja, ist doch scheiße. Wenn du dich genau darauf jetzt beziehen willst, musst du erst so einen Scheißartikel durchlesen und am Ende, ach ja, übrigens...
Ich hab übrigens gesehen, dass ich jetzt in der Wikipedia stehe und dann ist auch dank dir... Unter deinem Artikel, also wir sind nicht verlinkt, ja, weil...
Ihr seid dann auch bei mir untergeordnet, oder was?
Nee, wir werden namentlich bei Mobile Max genannt.
Wir sind auch nicht besser als eine Sicke.
Na, du gehst auf Tim Prittlove und da steht dann unten, was du für Podcasts machst und dann steht da, wer da mit dir die Podcasts macht. Übrigens so, das ist auch mal so ein kleiner Tipp vielleicht zum Warmwerden heute. Nee, es gibt ja so Webseiten, wo man so Leute stalken kann, wo man nachgucken kann, was seine alten Schulfreunde heutzutage so machen. Da gibt es halt 123people.de oder comstayfriends und die Seite, die mir da eigentlich am ersten zusagt, das heißt jasini.de mit y am Anfang. Und da hab ich im Prinzip eine Suche, eine permanente Suche auf meinen Namen und lass mir mal E-Mail-Notifications schicken, wenn die mit ihren Robots in irgendwelchen Netzwerken irgendwas gefunden haben. Und da hab ich gestern nämlich eine Mail bekommen, wo in der VARpedia, das ist irgendwie eine Wikipedia-Frontend für Mobile Devices, unter Mobile Max und Tim Pridlove mein Name auftauchte. Da hab ich mich aufgeklickt, Wikipedia-Artikel geklickt, bumm, zack.
Toll, jetzt hast du jasini.de totgemacht.
Ja, also, ne, das ist aber eigentlich kein schlechter, also ich würd sogar empfehlen, mal den Leuten irgendwie ihre Klarnamen einzugeben mit E-Mail-Notifikationen an sich selbst, weil dann weiß man mal, wo man überall erwähnt wird. Weil ich hatte zum Beispiel schon mal das, einer aus meiner alten Grundschulklasse. Ne, sowohl als Klarnamen als auch Nickname. In deinem Artikel steh ich ja mit klaren Namen.
Ernsthaft? Ich dachte, ich kenn überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Skandal. Ich weiß auch nicht, wer das editiert hat, hab ich noch nicht nachgeguckt. Aber, genau, hier so ein Schulfreund von mir, oder ne, ein Schulkamerad aus der Grundschule, hat nämlich ein altes Schulfoto von mir hochgeladen und da so ein Rechteck um mein Gesicht gemalt und um alle anderen auch und die Namen dahingeschrieben. Und das hab ich halt auch über dieses Jasney gefunden und konnte denen dann mal sagen, dass ich das nicht will.
Chaos Radio Express ist zum Beispiel auch ein Abschnitt unter Chaos Radio.
Bist du also jetzt voll auf den Streisand-Effekt irgendwie aus?
Obermix-Flyper mit kleinem M. Ne, den, ich weiß nicht mehr, ich hab's zuletzt nicht mehr gefunden, vielleicht gibt's das noch irgendwann.
Aus dem heißt das Bumpzackreturn.
Hallo?
Die Lahm ist ja nicht so scheiß Wikipedia hier.
Ja, ich arbeite jetzt hier mal so eine 5-fach verschleifte Riederick-Kaskade da.
Aber dann dachte ich auch halt so, es ist so, okay, dann werden jetzt erwähnt und...
Kann ich mir eigentlich das Sofa hier rüberziehen?
Wir haben nämlich gerade, wir haben nämlich gerade sehr viel Pizza gegessen und Ringumfassungen sozusagen.
Nee, aber der Stuhl ist einfach hier...
Was denn denn den anderen?
Man kann übrigens auch einfach Google Abonnenten auf seinen Namen machen.
Das geht auch sehr gut. Ja, das mach ich.
Ich auch.
Na, ich hab's bei diesem Jasen nie da irgendwie gemacht, weil da irgendwie, weiß nicht, wusste ich nicht von dem Google Zeug. Und ich boykottiere eh Google. Na, ist ja ganz gut, dass ich da gar nicht erst...
Du boykottierst Google.
Na, also wo es geht. Ach so. Also, ich versuche es so wenig wie möglich zu nutzen, weil mir ist klar geworden, dass sie einfach... Die haben uns alle schon genug geownt. Also nicht nur, dass sie unsere Suchergebnisse tracken, wo wir Maps haben, unsere Mails, unseren Newsreader und was nicht alle. Nee. Ach so, und dann dieses Google Analytics Zeug. Sondern ich habe halt übrigens auf deine Empfehlung hin jetzt ja mal Hands Off probiert statt Little Snitch. Und habe das jetzt auch im permanenten Einsatz. Und da stelle ich dauernd fest, dass irgendwelche Applikationen halt mit Google Analytics telefonieren. Das heißt, nicht nur, dass jetzt irgendwie tracken, auf welche Webseiten du gehst, sondern tracken jetzt auch noch damit, welche Apps du wann, wie und wo benutzt. Ja, die machen Port 80, HTTP, irgendwelche Programme, die dann irgendwie mal Google Analytics Bescheid sagen, dass du jetzt hier gerade was weiß ich, Reader.app oder wen auch immer aufgemacht hast.
Sag mal, die machen das?
Ja, habe ich jetzt, ich müsste mal kurz in meine Hands-of-Rules-Stöbern gehen, aber ich habe ja eh alle Google Analytics Hosts nach Local Hosts zeigen lassen in meiner ETC-Host, von daher ist mir das der Latte. Aber ich gucke mal, ob ich das hier vielleicht, ob ich auch noch Rule konfiguriert habe, aber ja.
Derweil werde ich mir eine köstliche, gekühlte Club-Mate gönnen. Ein koffeinhaltiges Erfrischungsgetränk auf Mate-Basis.
Kriegen wir dafür Geld, oder hast du das jetzt kostenlos gemacht?
Nee, ich mache nur wieder ein shameless Self-Plug. Da habe ich gerade einen schönen Podcast gemacht, nur Hacker-Brausen.
Gingst du auch an Lead-Mate?
Ja.
Super.
Die finde ich nämlich...
Hacker sind die Fernfahrer des Internets, ja. Das nehme ich dem ja übel.
Das wird da alles erklärt.
Wir haben jetzt ja im Club Flora-Power-Mate.
Flora-Power?
Das ist das, worauf Lead-Mate basiert.
Die schmeckt so ein bisschen mehr nach Mate und hat ein bisschen weniger Kohlensohn. Ist auch nicht ganz so süß, aber mehr Koffein.
Aber das müssen wir jetzt gar nicht in Detail machen. Ja, aber ich wollte ja nur darauf hinweisen, dass wir das an anderer Stelle alles schon...
Du hast uns da nicht eingeladen. Wir haben auch noch was dazu zu sagen.
Ja, ihr hättet vielleicht was dazu sagen, aber ihr seid nicht Experten.
Ja, das stimmt.
Du auch nicht.
Obwohl ich trinke das auch schon größer als 10 Jahre.
Ich trinke schon, solange ich leben kann.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht so eine Massenveranstaltung machen, sondern eher mit den Leuten reden, die sich da intensiv mit beschäftigt haben.
Mein täglich beruhigt E-Mail-Klient namens Postbox, der telefoniert mit Google Analytics.
Und ist er dann auch gleich wieder abgewählt?
Nein, ich hab das ja alles nach Local Host zeigen lassen.
Hier ist er ja immer noch zu unmeckig.
Ja, aber ich hab zwischendurch wieder Apple Mail probiert, und es ging halt auch nicht mehr. Ja, Mail-Klient muss auch jeder für sich ausmachen.
Ich hab mir am App-Store Sparrow gekauft.
Das geht ja nur mit Gmail, das hab ich gar nicht.
Aber mit Gmail, das ist gut. Vor allem schnell, ich will das nicht.
Und noch eine Applikation, die das benutzt, die ist aber auch so eine Nischen-Applikation, die hat bestimmt keiner unserer Hörer installiert oder jemals davon gehört, die heißt Kuppa. C-U-P-P-A. Das ist mein persönlicher Teatimer. Also nicht, dass das anders und viel effizienter vielleicht ginge, aber...
Und die telefonieren auch zu Google Analytics.
Die telefonieren auch mal kurz nach Google Analytics.
Aber geht's ihnen allen noch gut? Was haben die davon?
Wobei, ne, stopp! Ich nehm alles zurück und maube da das Gegenteil. Ich hab mir mehr Zeile vertan. Bar, alles Postbox. Aber dann hab ich jetzt auch mal auf diese kleine Nischen-Applikation hingewiesen. Für die Teetränker unter uns. Das macht sehr schöne Geräusche, wenn der T fertig ist.
Wenn der T fertig ist oder wenn es klingelt?
Du stellst die Zeit an und giechst da erstmal den T ein. Und wenn es dann fertig ist, dann macht es so Kling-Kling.
Ich hab ja jetzt so ein neues, hübsches Feature. Ich nutze ja dieses Alarms, wo man hier oben dann so eine Leiste einblenden kann, wo man sich Termine setzen kann. Und hier hab ich einen Timer drin. Ich brauch nur das Icon. Ich brauch es hier nur runterzuziehen, in der Mühleiste unterstellt. Da haben wir so einen Timer. Das ist ganz cool.
Bisschen visueller beschreiben, bitte.
Also ich hab so ein kleines Icon, so ein Glöckchen, genau, in der Menüleiste oben drinnen. Und da kann ich, wenn ich reinklicke und dann die Maus runterziehe, dann erscheint...
Zählt dann ein Counter hoch?
Genau, dann wird ein Counter hochgezählt und sobald ich loslasse, ist das der Timer, der dann runterzählt. Also sozusagen eigentlich der bequemste Timer überhaupt. Das ist so ein Feature, was ich überhaupt an dem Programm erst viel zu spät bemerkt hätte, vor kurzem, als ich... Egal, nicht so wichtig, aber... Ja.
Das ist schockig. Alarms. Nach längerer Zeit feststellt, dass ein Programm, das man seit Ewigkeiten benutzt, irgendwas ganz Tolles kann. Man hat es noch nie gecheckt.
Ein bisschen ist es schon so, eigentlich nutze ich es nur relativ selten, aber wenn, dann ist es ganz praktisch und naja.
Und?
Und? Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Bist du fertig? Von den drei Themen nehmen wir.
Wie bin ich fertig?
Ja, mit dem, was du jetzt erzählen willst.
Ich nehme mal noch so eine Mate.
Doch, ich habe nachgelegt.
Ach so, ach so, war eine kalt.
Ich nehme Ihnen die lebe warmen Mate.
Da ist, da ist Mate.
Du Warm-Mate-Trinker. Ja, die kleinen anderen Geschichten hebe ich mir für zwischendurch zur Auflockerung auf, wenn wir darüber gesprochen haben, wie wie Apple, einem seiner größten Konkurrenten, das meiste Geld in die Taschen steckt. Da war ja irgendwie so ein kurzer Artikel, dass Apple auch jetzt hier irgendwie Samsung so die Teile abkauft ohne Ende, ne? Displays und Flash, und hast du nicht gesehen, und der größte Customer von Samsung ist und ist ja eigentlich auch ein direkter Konkurrent jetzt so mit Galaxy Tab und sowieso, was nicht noch alles für Smartphones und Hustle nicht gesehen ist. Und jetzt sozusagen bei der Firma, die aber eigentlich auch hier Konkurrenz ist, soll die Teile für ihre coolen Geräte shoppen. Schon auch irgendwie interessant.
Na, das soll er ja machen. Die werden bestimmt auch Dinge bei Sony kaufen und bei... Weil Sony stellt nichts mehr her, was für Apple interessant ist, oder?
Das ist wirklich die traurige Wahrheit.
Der Sony ist auch, glaube ich, in dem ganzen Komponentenmarkt nicht wirklich vertreten.
Also langsam kann man auch Sony sagen und nicht mehr Sony.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht.
Sony?
Da ist Sony gesorgt.
Ich finde das immer mit so weichem S.
Aber die Süddeutschen, die machen das doch mit dem weichen S. Die sagen doch sowas wie Source Code und Open Source und Server.
Ich hab mir gerade erklären lassen, dass sie das ausgerechnet nicht machen.
Doch, aber du kennst Nibbler, Ro und die ganzen Konsorten, die machen das alle mit dem weichen S. Und die kommen alle aus Franken und so. Server. Das ist ein Desk, der nur Software.
Na gut, jeder wie er mag. Router, Router, Router, Router. Das haben wir alles mal gesagt. Also Apple und Samsung, wir klären mal ein bisschen auf. Also Apple bezieht einen Großteil seines SSDs und wahrscheinlich auch nicht unerheblich viele Displays von Samsung und steht damit lustigerweise auch mit Samsung selbst auf einmal in der Konkurrenz, die ja auch versuchen, aufzutrumpfen und Tablette zu erzeugen. Zu den Tabletten kommen wir noch. Ja, ich hab das Gefühl, in dem Markt nehmen gerade eine Menge Leute Tabletten.
Und ob Samsung mehr an Apple verdient als an den eigenen Geräten?
Na ja gut, ich meine, man muss unterscheiden, welches Samsung. Samsung ist ein Riesenkonzern und Samsung, ich bau dir was, ist halt was anderes als, ich verkaufe dir was.
Samsung bau du mir was?
Ja, so Samsung Fernseher, Samsunger Konsumergeräte, Samsung Computer, Samsung Tablette, das sind alles irgendwie unterschiedliche Bereiche. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt im Einzelnen da aufgefaltet ist, aber wir bauen elektronische Komponenten für alle möglichen. Das ist natürlich ein ganz eigenständiger Club und die lassen sich natürlich jetzt auch von ihrer eigenen Produkt Abteilung da wenig reinreden, weil wenn die irgendwie einen Customer haben, der gut zahlt, dann haben die einen Customer, der gut zahlt und das natürlich jetzt nicht... Das ist auch ganz klug, wo wir gerade über Sony geredet haben. Oder Sony.
Sony.
Sony machen. Was hat denn Sony seinerzeit mal getan, als sie ganz erfolgreich war? Da haben sie gedacht, sie müssten irgendwie Player und Content kaufen. Und dann sind sie irgendwie in Hollywood losgezogen und haben sich irgendwie den Content eingekauft.
Sony Entertainment.
Also in Form von Columbia Pictures?
Ja genau, also Movies.
Die haben eine komplette Filmbude gekauft, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Was war das, Columbia?
Ich glaube ja.
Wir schauen nach parallel. Erzählt mal weiter.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall haben sie sich sozusagen gleichzeitig zum Hüter des DRM und zu demjenigen, der unter DRM leidet, nämlich Player-Hersteller, da gebacken. Und haben sich sozusagen selbst in Zugzwang gebracht.
Das waren die mit dem Virus auf der CD, wo sich was installiert, was sich auf deinem Rechner installiert?
Ja, die hatten noch irgendwie so ein...
Ja, Sony kennt man schon fast gar nicht mehr. Die bauen auch irgendwie nichts mehr, was man hat. Oder? Ich meine, gibt es ein Sony-Gerät, das man kaufen müsste derzeit?
Ich hab neulich großmäßig zum Balkott gegen Sony aufgerufen, wegen GeoBot.
Das hat ja Wellen geschlagen.
Ja, das hat gigantische Wellen geschlagen. Und drei Tage später kam ich auf die Idee, dass ich mir eigentlich eine Sony PlayStation kaufen wollte für LittleBigPlanet.
Da war doch noch was.
Genau, also PlayStation ist schon noch was, was sich verkauft. Und was ja hier, als wir mal über Blu-Ray und so geredet hatten, meint ja dann auch einer, der in so einem Produktionsstudio da arbeitet, dass er der beste Blu-Ray-Player sei. Und naja.
War eine Zeitlang unterbilligste Blu-Ray-Player.
Das kam dann vielleicht noch hinzu, aber es soll wohl halt aufgrund der schier unendlich scheinenden Rechenpower auch einfach zum Dekodieren extrem gut geeignet zu sein.
Na und dadurch, dass es Software-Updates einspielen kann, problemlos. Was ist eigentlich aus Aiva geworden? Gab's die nicht auch mal?
Aiva? Oh, nie wieder was von gehört.
Ich dachte mal, das wäre so eine Sony-Billig-Marke.
Aber wir kaufen heute alles bei Apple.
Aiva?
Ja, aber das stimmt gar nicht, ne?
Also alles, was man nicht so richtig gut kennt, das gehört wahrscheinlich eh zu Panasonic. Weil es sind alles immer irgendwelche Panasonic-Marken.
Panasonic ist auch krass. Ah, sowieso diese ganzen...
Technics und so.
Sowieso diese ganzen Firmen da, also auch Yamaha ist ja auch so ein total krasser Konzert, das hat man auch schon mal erwähnt.
Also ein halber Mischkonzern, oder?
Ich meine, die bauen vom Außenborder fürs Motorboot bis irgendwie zum Edelflügel.
Na, ist sowas wie Siemens halt.
Von der EU?
Siemens mittlerweile keine Mobiltelefone mehr hinbekommt und auch sonst eigentlich keine Consumer-Devices.
Und Yamaha auch ein bisschen mehr Style hat.
Also sollte man mal zu denken gehen, jemand, der keine Telefone bauen kann, kann aber keine Kraftwerke bauen.
Na, wenn sie in dem Handy-Markt dieselbe politische Protektion hätten, dann könnten sie wahrscheinlich auch Geräte auf den Markt schmeißen. Aber ich denke, wenn sie den freien Kräften ausgesetzt sind, dann ist Deutschland irgendwie immer so ein bisschen gescheitert. Und ich meine, das ist, jetzt kommen wir auch langsam zum Thema. Es ist ja auch nicht nur Deutschland. Es ist ja Europa.
Oh Gott, was für eine Überleitung.
Europa hatte mal eine Computerindustrie. Da kann man sich schon fast gar nicht mehr dran erinnern. Hier wurden mal Computer gebaut, in Deutschland.
Schneider CPC.
Das ist nur ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil das war nun Englisch. Ja gut, das ist auch England. Das ist auch Europa.
Commodore Amiga 2000, der wurde in Braunschweig gebaut.
Ja, es gibt Fertigungsstätten. Aber es wurden auch welche erfunden. Es gab so einen Minicomputer. Es gab so Hersteller von...
Der Computer überhaupt wurde hier erfunden?
Good point. Ja, hier wurde, genau. Hier um die Ecke, ja, aber direkt neben der Metaebene wurde der Computer erfunden.
Ich hatte mal mein Büro...
Und was ist davon übrig geblieben?
Mein Büro war mal da, wo der erfunden wurde. Der Z1, wo er den gebaut hat.
Und schau, was aus dir geworden ist.
Dein Büro war mal da, wo der gebaut wurde. Du hattest mal ein Büro...
Ich saß mit... In dem Gebäude. Ich glaube, das war... Wir hatten ein Büro und da gab es irgendwann mal einen Prospekt dazu zu diesem Büro, weil da so Büroräume drin waren, und sie die vermieten wollten. Und da stand dann drin, hier hat Conrad Zuse in diesem Gebäude seine Z1 gebaut. Und dann hat ihm einfach mal geglaubt.
Dönekens gemacht hat er.
War das nicht so ein General? Das Zweite Weltkrieg? Achso.
Umstieber in Geld.
Nee, das war Döring.
Das Hitlermedien ist reserviert für Nutzerlfamilie.
Wie hieß denn der Nachbar von Hitler, der drei Tage noch gemacht hat?
Ich hab damit nichts zu tun.
Lassen wir das mit den Nazis mal raus.
Ist doch klar, warum Bumm zack return.
Wir haben ja kurz vorher überlegt, beim Pizzaholen, wir könnten uns ja auch rechts unten nennen, aber da haben wir gleich wieder freigelassen.
Es hat so zweifacher Hinsicht keine gute Konnotation.
Die NPD unter den Podcasts?
Nee, aber ich meine jetzt, die letzte halbwegs marktbeeinflussende Firma, die so verblieben ist derzeit, ist Nokia. Schonmal gehört?
Also es dient nicht mit dem 63 CI?
Wenn wir jetzt nicht drauf eingehen, dann können wir das Thema an uns vorbeigehen lassen.
Ja, ich sehe das ja ganz entspannt. Du bist ja dann immer gleich energized.
Einfach ganz ruhig. Das ist überhaupt kein großes Ding. Aber die Tatsache ist, die Nokia ist der letzte Hersteller, der eigene Plattform vorangetrieben hat, auch wenn sie scheiße waren. Sie waren auch mal nicht scheiße, aber in letzter Zeit waren sie nicht mehr so toll, wie auch immer. Tatsache, sie haben es getan. Es gibt einfach keinen anderen Hersteller. Oder habe ich irgendwas gerade gesehen?
Vor allen Dingen, muss ich mal sagen, war es ein prader Telefon.
Vor allen Dingen waren sie die Ersten, die nicht mehr scheiße waren. Die ersten Mobiltelefone waren alle grottig. Mein erstes Nokia-Phone konnte man super bedienen.
Ja, im Vergleich zum Motorola. Ich fand, dieser Knochen hatte irgendwie einen geilen Appeal. Was ist denn auch dieser Motorola-Knochen? Dieser Star-Tech? Nee. Das waren diese Ausklappteile. Nee, der Knochen. Ich weiß nicht, wie hieß denn das Teil? Das sah halt aus wie so ein Knochen. So ein fettes Teil, wie ein schlecht designtes E.
Na ja, weiß nicht, irgendwie... Ich kenne nur dieses erste E-Plus-Telefon.
Da taucht bestimmt gleich ein schöner Link.
Motorola International 3200?
Und alle anderen Hersteller sind halt in den USA. Oder in Asien. Und da zieht es jetzt irgendwie hin.
Aber ist da nicht der Ericsson-Teil noch in Europa?
Gibt es eigentlich so eine Ericsson noch?
Ericsson gibt es doch noch.
Ja, Ericsson gibt es noch. Aber ich meine, dass Sony Ericsson eine eigene Plattform hätte, könnte ich mich jetzt nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern. Die sind Symbian-Licency.
Keine Smartphone-Plattform, aber hier diese ganzen Feature-Phones, die haben noch ein eigenes Betriebssystem.
Ja, aber doch keins von... Also Sony Ericsson stellt seit längerer Zeit mit wechselnden OSen her. Also mal haben sie Symbian genommen, dann haben sie Windows Mobile probiert.
Ja, aber die haben so Feature-Phones. Die haben so Feature-Phones und die haben irgendwas eigenes drauf. Keine Ahnung, wie das heißt, aber das ist halt so der übliche. Ich mochte die immer sehr gerne, früher.
Ja, ich hatte auch mal so einen Teil. Aber ich meine, das sind einfach keine nennenswerten Plattformen. Sony Ericsson ist kein Player bei Plattformen. Die bauen keine Systeme, die bauen keine Betriebssysteme, sondern sie kaufen sich jetzt irgendwas zusammen. Vielleicht haben sie da so ein Gehacke, was auf zwei, drei Telefonen läuft, aber so irgendwas in der Dimension von Nokia findet einfach nicht mehr statt. So, und jetzt gab es diese schöne Mail von Herrn Elop, der seines Zeichens der hauptamtliche Spion von Microsoft. Zufälligerweise...
Ach, wie viele größte Shareholder?
Acht größte, glaube ich, war das er.
Er konnte sich zumindest noch rausreden, damit er auf Basis der Gesetze gar keine Chance hatte, diese Anteile bisher zu verkaufen.
Und jetzt wollte er sie so wertlos nicht weggeben?
Na, er darf sie halt nicht so en bloc verkaufen, nachdem er die Firma verlässt. Das ist halt einfach Antitrust, tralala, Gesetzgebung. Also du darfst nicht einfach raus aus einer Firma und dann verkaufst du deinen ganzen Shares.
Ja, aber das ändert nichts daran, dass er trotzdem involviert ist.
Klar, das ändert nichts daran, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass er mir das vorwerfen könnte, dass er das nicht schon getan hat, weil er es gar nicht hätte tun können. Trotzdem hat er natürlich einen ganz anderen Stake in Microsoft, als er in Nokia hat. Aber ich glaube, das spielt gar nicht so eine große Rolle. Das ist jetzt gar nicht das Ding. Aber dann hat er halt dieses Memo rausgebracht, in dem er irgendwie beschrieben hat, was ich ja jetzt auch hier schon seit Jahren eigentlich repiziere, dass halt bei Nokia eigentlich alles in Flammen steht. Und dass es da irgendwie auch ein extremes Denial innerhalb der Firma gibt, die das einfach ablehnt.
Wenn man einst bestätigen kann schon mal, dass du tatsächlich schon... Also letztens hatten wir im Chat irgendwie, kam die Frage und rante Tim eigentlich auch immer noch gegen Nokia. Das hatte er schon vor... Also irgendwie kam so der Spruch, dass Tim ja schon vor zwei Jahren Recht gehabt hätte. Und er meinte, Dennis ja, das proklamiert er auch immer noch. Also wenn man was feststellen kann, dann, dass du deinen Feldzug sozusagen zu gewinnen scheinst. Oder deine Prognose... Was heißt mein Feldzug?
Das ist kein Feldzug.
Ich versuche auch nur auf diesen Markt zu schauen. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt, als das iPhone rauskam, war mir irgendwie klar, dass sie einfach diese Kurve nicht kriegen werden. Ich hätte mich ja auch gerne eines Besseren belehren lassen, aber dafür haben sie leider nichts getan. Es ist einfach ein fortgesetztes Elend. Und alle ihre Alternativen, die sie haben, sind schlecht. Und jetzt ist ihre Situation so schlecht, dass man sogar fast sagen kann, dass dieses Mit-Microsoft-Gehen vielleicht sogar noch ihre beste Option ist. Aber so oder so verlieren sie einfach den Status eines Plattformherstellers.
Ich hab das Gefühl, er hat alles nur noch schlimmer gemacht. Also ich meine, sich da hinzusetzen, ich fand das echt deprimierend. Da ist doch irgendwie ein Traditionsunternehmen, das mal ganz gute Hardware hergestellt hat. Und dann kommt das da plötzlich raus, und die sind ja von Microsoft so vorgeführt worden, wie sonst nichts. Das ist, ich hätt's für nicht vorstellbar gehalten. Also der Termin für die Pressekonferenz war ja auf 11 angesetzt. Microsoft hat mal eben zwei Stunden vorher schon alle Videos raus und so hoppla, da ist uns rausgerutscht. Und dann hast du da dieses Foto von diesem, wie Steve Baumer und dieser Elob da stehen. Und das sieht wirklich so aus, als ob so Elob da so gewartet hat in Finnland auf ihnen. Und Steve Baumer kommt so rein, so von der Seite. Ich mach das hier mal vor, das können dann im Podcast alle sehen. So, hallo, da bin ich. Und ich bin mal kurz vorbei geschneit, um hier den Laden zu übernehmen. Dann drei Tage nachdem es vorbei ist, machen sie erstmal einen Microsoft-Mitarbeiter zum Nokia Amerika-Chef. Das ist doch das römische Reich mit seinen eroberten Gebieten besser umgegangen. Ja. Und dann vor allen Dingen keine Geräte. Also nicht irgendwie eine Ankündigung, nicht mal einen Prototypen zeigen, gar nichts, nicht mal irgendwie so ein Nokia...
Prototypen von was denn?
Naja, ich meine, die hätten noch irgendein Nokia-Telefon nehmen können und hätten da mal ein Windows Phone 7 drauf installieren können. Das kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
Und dann?
Naja, hätten sie wenigstens was zum Zeigen gehabt, wenigstens irgendwas. Naja, also ich meine, 2012 wären wir irgendwann mal...
Also du willst sagen, der Laden wurde eigentlich gekauft?
Der Laden wurde eigentlich verschenkt. Und dann eben diese Nummer mit... Wenn sie wenigstens konsequent gesagt haben, wir schmeißen Symbian weg und wir schmeißen MeeGo weg und wir lassen das alles sein und machen nur noch Windows Phone 7. Weil bisher haben wir zwei schlechte Betriebssysteme und jetzt haben sie drei schlechte Betriebssysteme. Weil sie lassen Symbian noch ein bisschen auslaufen, MeeGo lassen sie auch noch ein bisschen weiterlaufen. Jetzt haben sie noch Windows Phone 7.
Sie haben da Verträge und sie haben da eine riesige Produktpalette, die sie überhaupt nicht umstellen können.
Also es geht gar nicht.
Du kannst diesen ganzen Symbian trosten. Ich meine, das sind immerhin noch dreistellige Millionenzahlen von Geräten, die da draußen sind, die weiter supportet werden müssen und wo sie jetzt auch Nachfolger noch verkauft bekommen.
Ist ja kaum gibt's zu dem Tim immer ein bisschen Gegenwind, wird da gleich pro Nokia jetzt. Der Tim ist nämlich ein Oppositionstyp.
Ich aber. Nein, ach Quatsch. Das auch. Aber ich finde ja bei der Geschichte eigentlich, also weißt du so, ich gucke ja immer mit großer Freude in die Retrospective, also in die Retrospective auf die Rückkehr von Steve, als der zurück zu Apple kam. Der kam da an, ging auf die Bühne, hat gesagt, hey Jungs, ist ja alles gut und schön, wir haben hier so und so ein paar Core-Kompetenzen. Hat sich da drauf fokussiert, hat den Schrott weggeschmissen, hat es durchgezogen, ein, zwei Jahre später.
Du meinst jetzt berühmte Quadrat mit den vier Abteilungen? Und wir machen jetzt nur noch hier Laptop.
Also damals hat mich das jetzt nicht so fasziniert, aber wenn ich jetzt so sehe, wie dieser Elop da so performt und dann einfach so Panik.
A Revolutionary Mobile Internet Device!
Jetzt bringe ich es durcheinander. Ich meine, worauf wollt ihr jetzt hinaus?
Sind wir noch bei Nokia? Das ist doch erstmal festhalten, was eigentlich passiert ist.
Also Nokia hat jetzt bekannt gegeben, dass sie Windows Phone-Geräte rausbringen sollen. Was heißt denn das eigentlich? Ich meine, schau dir mal an, was Windows Phone-Geräte derzeit sind. Windows Phone-Geräte sind alle gleich.
Gibt es überhaupt mehr als eins?
Microsoft hat ja dahingehend gelernt von Apples Erfolg, dass ein Teil des Erfolgs auch der Tatsache zuzuschreiben ist, dass es nur eine klare Hardware-Plattform gibt. Der Bildschirm ist so und so groß, hat so und so viele Pixel. Okay, jetzt hat er mal doppelt so viele, aber das wissen wir ja, ist alles kein Problem. Und diese und jene Dinge sind einfach vorausgesetzt. Und ähnlich ist Microsoft da auch rausgegangen. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie jetzt diese Verträge da aussehen, aber wenn man sich alle Windows-Mobile-Devices anschaut, das ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger dasselbe. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass jetzt Nokia irgendwie viel Spielraum hätte, da groß irgendwas anders zu machen. Geschweige denn jetzt deutlich billiger, besser oder sonst irgendwie. Also das ist mir schon mal so das erste, was mir dabei hochkommt, wo ich mir denke, wie wollen die sich jetzt eigentlich positionieren? Wie wollen die da sich differenzieren? Die weiß es, da steht auch überall Microsoft drauf.
Nächstes Jahr, wenn die ersten Geräte von Nokia kommen irgendwann, dann haben die anderen schon alle aufgehört, Windows-Geräte zu produzieren.
Ja, und das dauert auch jetzt erstmal noch eine Weile. Ja, das finde ich ein Jahr, das weiß ich nicht.
Also sie haben ja gesagt, bis 2012 wollen sie es machen. Andere schreiben derzeit ein Betriebssystem. Also das verstehe ich tatsächlich nicht. Wenn ihr MeeGo hier, da wollten sie Ende letzten Jahres...
Die können nicht mehr zwei Jahre warten. Also für Nokia wird es wirklich ein bisschen eng gerade.
Ja, aber sie werden auch kein Windows Phone. Sie haben gesagt, so im großen Stil kommen die Windows Phones auch erst nächstes Jahr raus.
Aber wie gesagt...
Ja, es ist vielleicht auch schon zu spät. Aber was sollen sie machen?
Aber guck dir an, ich meine, also jetzt nur noch mal diese komische Apple Analogie. Aber die standen nun echt noch viel mehr mit dem Rücken an der Wand. Also die waren wirklich kurz vorm Crash so.
Was ist jetzt mit dieser Analogie?
Na die haben sich halt auch mal ein Jahr lang auf den Arsch gesetzt und dann irgendwie das Ding gerade gezogen und aus eigener Kraft geschafft.
Ja, aber genau das haben wir ja nun alle live mitverfolgen dürfen. Nokia kann das nicht. Die haben keinen Plan. Und ich finde, es ist halt auch ein Versagen Europas. Dass einfach die Vision fehlt, ein Produkt zu designen, was Leuten gefällt, was irgendwie an den Benutzer sich orientiert und in irgendeiner Form, in irgendeine Richtung weist, wo man sagt, da will ich hin. Und das ist auch, glaube ich, so ein bisschen so dieses, wie nennt man das, so dieses Syndrom, wenn du so aus deinem eigenen Kasten nicht rausgucken kannst. Das ist alles auch so engineer driven. Für die sind so Sachen wie Touchscreen, das sind für die so technische Details. Und die verstehen überhaupt nicht das Modell dahinter. Und was halt auch ein Problem ist, ist, dass für Nokia, wie auch für einige andere Hersteller, die Kunden sind nicht die Leute, die die Telefone kaufen. Sondern die Kunden sind die Telekom Firmen gewesen. Das ist das, wo sie hingehen und mit denen sie die Deals machen. Mit dem ganzen Branding. Sie haben sich auch die Features diktieren lassen, im Prinzip von den Telecoms. Und dass die Features natürlich auch nicht für die Kunden sind, sondern für die Ausnahme der Kunden, liegt ja auch auf der Hand. Also ich... Es ist ein totales Trauerspiel und es ist irgendwie auch traurig, dass sie nicht ein bisschen die Werbe gehabt haben, aber im Prinzip... Also ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass sie auf irgendetwas anderes aus waren, als auf diese Heirat mit Microsoft, als sie sich diesen Typen geholt haben. Ich meine, man holt sich doch nicht irgendeinen Vogel, der seit Ewigkeiten bei Microsoft in der Office-Abteilung sitzt.
Ja, und es wurde ja dann noch bekannt gegeben, dass es jetzt ja auch noch Google oder als Mitbewerber und so weiter da gab.
Naja, aber da gab es jetzt diverse Gerüchte, dass es ein Beat-Festbiblium gegeben hätte, dass jetzt Microsoft angeblich total viel Geld zahlen würde. Das haben sie alles dementiert.
Wer hat was dementiert?
Das hat hier Elop dementiert.
Ich dachte, Elop hat gesagt, dass irgendwie Billions...
Nee, nee, das hat er nie gesagt und hat es auch explizit dementiert.
Das heißt, sie kriegen noch nicht mal Geld?
Sie kriegen noch nicht mal Geld.
Was kriegen sie denn überhaupt?
Die Sicherheit, dass sie da erstmal weiter werkeln dürfen.
Nee, nicht mal das kriegen sie. Eigentlich kriegen sie wirklich exakt gar nichts.
Aber sie haben auch wirklich nichts gehabt. Ich hab irgendwie jetzt... Intel hat ja auf irgendeiner Messe gerade so einen MeeGo Prototypen vorgestellt.
Da fasst man sich ja auch an den Kopf.
Also das ist auch alles so von Dreck.
Das ist alles so furchtbar und schlimm.
Es geht...
Also ich hab nur das User Interface gesehen, da läuft ja einfach ein kalter Schauer in den Rücken. Das ist alles vorne und hinten nicht zu Ende gedacht. Und man merkt einfach, wenn diesen Firmen irgendwas wirklich fehlt, dann fehlt ihnen einfach Betriebssysteme. Und es gibt offensichtlich derzeit nur drei Firmen auf diesem Planeten, die die Power haben, ein eigenes Betriebssystem zu entwickeln. Was so halbwegs General Purpose ist. Und das ist zu wenig eigentlich. Auch wenn es irgendwie schon mal eins mehr ist, als vor ein paar Jahren.
Wen meinst du jetzt? Also iOS, klar, Microsoft? Na, HP gibt es jetzt auch noch so ein bisschen?
Da können wir gleich nochmal zukommen. Ob das trägt, das wird sich zeigen.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall so ein Betriebssystem.
Naja, ich meine, wenn du es jetzt technisch machst, dann könnte ich dir auch noch 120 andere betriebst.
Natürlich, aber alleine ist ja auch nicht mehr das, was heutzutage reicht. Oder man braucht diese App-Store, Ökosystem drumrum. Und das, was denen überall irgendwie fehlt. Genau, darum geht es ja. So ein Artikel ist ja diese Mobile World in Barcelona, diese... Genau, und da ist wohl die ganze Zeit nur noch die Rede von Ecosystems, weil irgendwie US interessiert jetzt auch kein mehr. Sondern du brauchst halt die User, die Credit Card und so weiter dahinter, weil sonst kommst du ja nicht weit.
So, ich finde, je mehr solche News nur nach oben babbeln, ich finde es immer beeindruckender, dass diese Apple-Jungs da einfach auf die Bühne kommen und alle in die Hosen ausgezogen haben und alle hinterherrennen nach wie vor. Das ist wirklich echt beeindruckend.
Ja, und ich denke, wir sind auch erst am Anfang. Also jetzt geht die Apple Party erst richtig los. Alles war bisher, war echt alles nur Spaß. Und jetzt teilen sie aus.
Also ich bin halt gespannt jetzt auf die nächsten Sachen, die sie dann rausholen.
Was ich auch letztes Mal schon angesprochen habe, das hängt jetzt auch mit diesem ganzen Smartphone-Kram zusammen. Und insofern ist auch dieser Fall von Nokia besonders dramatisch. Im letzten Quartal sind das erste Mal mehr Smartphones verkauft worden als PCs. Und zwar deutlich. 80 Millionen PCs, 100 Millionen Smartphones. Und wir wissen alle, wohin der Trend geht. Der Smartphone-Markt wächst mit ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was die Zuwachsraten sind, aber sie sind enorm. 30 Prozent oder so. Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie so in der Größenordnung. Und wir können wohl schwer davon ausgehen, dass Ende 2011 sich diese Zahl locker verdoppelt hat. Andererseits, denke ich, kann man auch davon ausgehen, dass die Zahl dieser Desktop-Computer sich auch erheblich verkleinernd wird, die verkauft werden.
Also natürlich werden die ganze Zeit so.
Ja, erheblich.
Und zwar erheblich wegen des iPad. Und auch alle anderen Tablets, die jetzt noch auf den Markt kommen und sagen, ich will aber auch. Einfach, weil sich gezeigt hat, wie sich meiner Meinung nach jetzt schon nach einem Dreivierteljahr gezeigt hat, dass einfach dieses Interaktionsmodell angenommen wird. Dass einfach Leute sagen, super, für mein Facebook und für mein E-Mail lesen und für mein Webbrausen und für meinen Musik hören und für meinen Film gucken, was 95 Prozent der Tätigkeiten sind, die die Leute an so einem PC bisher gemacht haben, ist das viel einfacher, viel billiger, viel mobiler, hält länger, etc. Sieht schick aus, tolle Spiele. Und vor allem kein Stress mehr mit installieren. Keine Viren, kein Shit, kein Antivirus Installer, der mir alle 10 Sekunden vor die Nase gesprungen kommt und sagt, Error, Alarm, furchtbar, Warnung, Hilfe, bitte verkriechen Sie sich unter dem Sofa und zahlen Sie hier nochmal 50 Dollar. Da haben die Leute einfach die Schnauze voll von.
Ach, das wird schon schnell genug auch im iPad kommen.
Da bin ich mich nicht so sicher. Na, das wird ja schon seit vier Jahren für das iPhone auch vorhergesagt, aber...
Und für...
Findet nicht stand.
Für hier unsere Macs wird es ja auch vorhergesagt, dass da die Viren kommen und die Trojaner und...
Ja, aber ich würde schon sagen, also ich meine, es wird auf einer anderen Ebene kommen, dieses, dieses... Es wird ja nicht zwangsläufig die Software sein, sondern es wird halt irgendwo weiter oben ein Netz sein. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht drüber zu diskutieren, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen müde ich gerade.
Naja, also ich, ich gehe davon aus, wie viele iPads hat Apple verkauft? 15 Millionen? Im dreiviertel Jahr. Drei Quartale, 15 Millionen iPads. Das heißt, sie werden so in ihrem ersten Jahr vermutlich mal so 20 Millionen verkauft haben. Oder vielleicht haben sie auch schon mehr. Keine Ahnung, wie sie in diesem Quartal abschneiden. Ich wäre überhaupt nicht überrascht, Vince. Wenn es noch weiter ansteigt, vielleicht sogar auch über den Weihnachtsverkauf hinaus. Das waren glaube ich allein 7 Millionen, ne?
Ja, das Quartal nach dem Weihnachtsquartal bricht schon ordentlich ein wieder. Das Weihnachtsquartal ist schon immer das Größte. Wobei man sagen muss, beim iPhone 4, dann war das nächste Quartal auch nicht mehr so.
Das ist nicht gesagt.
Oder beim 3 GS, dann ging es auch weiterhin ab, weil irgendwie langsam das iPhone angenommen wurde.
Ich wäre mir da jetzt nicht so sicher.
Ich wäre mir da wirklich nicht so sicher.
Mich würde es nicht überraschen, wenn es mehr ist. Mich würde es auch nicht überraschen, wenn es ein bisschen abfällt. Ich würde sagen, 5 Millionen ist sicher. Dann sind es schon mal 20 Millionen verkauft. Im ersten Jahr. Das ist wahrscheinlich schon mal der Tod des Netbook-Markts. Jetzt wird es nämlich ganz interessant. Dann können wir auch gleich mal zu HP kommen. HP finde ich gerade wirklich spannend. Dieser PC-Markt bricht weg. Eins ist irgendwie tot. Microsoft kündigt an, dass sie Windows sogar auf Arm bringen wollen. Und Intel hat total Probleme, überhaupt noch ihre Prozesse zu verkaufen. Weil in dem Moment, wo die ganzen Desktop-Rechner weniger verkauft werden und mit Atom haben sie noch keinerlei nennenswerten Grip bekommen irgendwo. Also das ist zwar in irgendwelchen düsseligen Tablet-Prototypen steckt das immer drin, aber haben will es eigentlich keiner. Alles, was verkauft wird, ist arm. Und Intel steckt eigentlich nur in Servern und eben in Desktops. Das hat bisher wunderbar funktioniert.
Aber jetzt ist es nicht mehr so.
Ja, okay. Also ein Laptop ist für mich auch ein Desktop. Also ein Laptop ist für mich ein Desktop-Computer.
Ach so. Und die Desktops-Tower, die sind ja eigentlich andere Desktop.
Das sind Mainframes.
Was jetzt aber ganz lustig ist, ist, dass ja dieses Windows, was für ARM rauskommen soll, ist ja angeblich gar nicht mal unbedingt so sehr das Ziel, dass es nachher tatsächlich der Konsumer ist, dass du ein Tablet mit Windows drauf hast und einen ARM-Prozessor, sondern auch in erster Linie als Server-Betriebssystem, als Stromspanner, als ARM-Server-Betriebssystem.
Ich denke, ARM ist auch schwer im Kommen im Server. Genau, weil nämlich Intel es nicht schafft, Strom zu sparen und ARM schafft es wunderbar. Und mit der Performance holen sie halt kräftig auf. Wobei Windows, ARM und so halte ich auch erst mal nur für eine Pause.
Na ja, was heißt mit der Performance holen die auf? Also diese Core i7 und 5 und 3 und so, die gehen halt performancemäßig schon noch ganz schön weiter ab.
Aber nicht pro Watt.
Ja, das kann sein, aber die sind performancemäßig schon ganz schön viel weiter. Aber die Frage ist halt, wer braucht so viel Power noch? Die braucht halt nicht mehr jeder.
Am Server-Bereich brauchst du halt schon noch Power.
Ja, klar, aber das sind halt nicht so viele. Der normale Casual-User zum E-Mail lesen und Facebooken und was sie alle so machen, die brauchen halt kein 4-Quad-Overclocking auf 3,5 Gigahertz-Zeug. Deswegen reicht halt ein Atom oder halt ein kleiner Arm.
Genau.
Aber was passiert jetzt? Das heißt, dieser PC-Markt sinkt. Intels Bedeutung sinkt auch. Damit ist auch dieses Vintel-Monopol langsam weg. Es ist nicht weg, aber seine Bedeutung sinkt. Das ist das, was ich sagen will. Dieser Markt wird immer kleiner und es ist nicht absehbar, dass er größer wird. Ich glaube, dass der PC-Markt jetzt seinen Zenit überschritten hat. Das wird natürlich langfristig auch für den Mac interessante Auswirkungen haben. Der einzige, der jetzt wirklich noch nennenswert Marktanteil hinzugewinnen kann, abgesehen von den üblichen Tagesschwankungen, wer jetzt gerade mehr billig PCs verkauft hat, ob es heute Acer war oder morgen wieder HP. Die einzigen, die konstant über Jahre hinzunehmen, sind Apple in diesem Segment, weil der PC quasi mehr für Leute ist, die auch wissen, warum sie ihn brauchen und von daher sowieso mehr Geld hinein investieren, weil sie Qualität haben wollen. Aber der Junk-Konsumerbereich schwirrt halt ab in Richtung Tablet. Und wer kann da am billigsten verkaufen? Apple. Das ist völlig absurd. Die alte Situation ist komplett umgedreht, wo man immer gesagt hat, Apple ist ja viel zu teuer. Ich hab bisher noch kein einziges Tablet-Announcement gehört, wo Apples 500 Dollar Preis in irgendeiner Form unterboten werden konnte. Alles war 700, 900 Dollar.
Keine Ahnung, was das gekostet hat.
Das gab's nie.
Doch, doch, das kannst du kaufen. Ich hab's bei Mediamarkt gesehen.
Ich glaub, die haben auch eine Return-Quote von 80 Prozent. Wenn nicht sogar 100.
Das war gar nicht mal so schlecht. Ich hab darauf rumgetippt, das war echt okay.
Ich hab's an den Laden gesehen.
Na ja, gut. Dass das VTAP keinen nennenswerten Marktanteil hat, hat sicher erarbeiten können. Ich denke, das sind wir uns alle einig. Ich glaub auch nicht, dass das jemals stattfinden kann mit so einer kleinen Bude aus Deutschland.
Das VTAP kommt noch. Siehst du, es ist gleich wieder schlecht. Gerade haben wir es noch, dass es in Deutschland so wenig Computerbuden gibt. Dann gibts mal eine und dann machst du sie gleich wieder kaputt.
Das einzige, was du in Deutschland hast, ist irgendwelche Testosteronen-verseuchten Mittelstandsmanager, die möchte gerne Steve Jobs sind und einen dicken machen, aber keine Ahnung haben, wie sie wirklich Technologie in so einem Laden vorantreiben.
Na ja, da hast du aber auch in Amerika genug von.
Ja, natürlich, aber die kriegen am Ende des Tages auch noch irgendwo was gebacken.
Gibt nur eins, naja auch nicht alle.
Nicht alle, aber es gibt da schon mehr.
Ja, aber es gibt zumindest welche, die was gebacken bekommen. Und in Deutschland kriegt einfach keiner was gebacken. Das ist wirklich zum Kotzen. Und Europa ist auch an sich irgendwie in so einer Schockstarre. Also man traut sich ja auch irgendwie nichts zu. Das ist wirklich verflixt. Aber man hat sich schon so daran gewöhnt, dass alles aus den USA kommt.
Ja, aber die Sache ist halt, das ist auch irgendwie eine komplett andere Mentalität halt da. Ich meine, guck dir einfach schon alleine an, was die Start-ups da für Geld um die Ohren kriegen. Das Cheeseburger-Network hier mit den Lolcats, die haben 30 Millionen gekriegt für ein Blog-Netzwerk mit Quatschbildern. 30 Millionen! Oder hier diese Tumblr, eine Blogging-Webseite, 15 Millionen, oder was die gekriegt haben. Einfach mal so, puff, die haben kein Geschäftsmodell.
Genau, dann schau dir an, was wir hier für einen Quatsch reden. Und wo sind die Millionen?
Ja.
Nichts.
Also hier musst du halt auch echt so richtig battlen gehen bei der IBB oder sonst wo, wenn du mal ein bisschen Förderkohle haben. Das ist richtig so mit hier so Bücher, dicke Anträge schreiben und hast du nicht gesehen oder? Also das ist halt nicht so, dass hier mit Geld um sich beworben wird. Weiß nicht, Texte, wenn die vielleicht ein geileres Funding schneller gekriegt hätten, hätten die auch nicht so lange gebraucht. Weißt du, also ich kann mir das schon vorstellen, dass du dann einfach auch selbst wenn du eine coole Idee hast, bist du da mal hier in den Tritt gekommen bist.
Ja, man traut sich irgendwie nichts.
Ja, wenn man sich traut, dann schafft man es trotzdem nicht.
So, jetzt nochmal kurz zu dem PC-Markt. So, also meiner Meinung nach, dieser PC-Markt geht unter. Das heißt nicht, dass es morgen keine PCs mehr geben wird, aber der Aufstieg ist auf jeden Fall vorbei. Und ich denke, es geht schon jetzt bereits bergab. Und mit ihm alles, was bisher über den PC-Markt sich oben gehalten hat. Windows, Intel und natürlich auch die großen Hersteller. Und ein paar von denen scheinen Begriffen zu haben, allen voran offenbar HP. Womit wir beim Announcement von HP wären. Was sich in vielerlei Hinsicht echt bemerkenswert hat. Was denkst du, Max?
Ich überleg ernsthaft, mir eins zu holen. So ein Touchpad. Ich find das sehr geil.
Wenn es mal eins geben würde.
Na ja, das wird schon kommen.
Prinzip Hoffnung.
Was heißt Prinzip Hoffnung?
Sie haben ein Ankündigungsverdienung.
Das werden wir schon schaffen.
Ich meine, iPad 2 gibt es auch noch nicht. Es ist noch nicht mal angekündigt. Insofern ist das schon mal...
Es ist nicht angekündigt, weil es noch nicht zu kaufen ist.
Na ja, wenn es an der Ankündigung dauert. Ich meine, beim iPad hat es damals auch noch eine ganze Weile gedauert, bis es tatsächlich kam.
Aber nur beim ersten.
Beim iPhone hat es bisher auch mal ein bisschen gedauert.
Weil sie ja erstmal den Developern Bescheid sagen müssen, dass sie dafür auch Software bauen müssen.
Das Ding ist jetzt durch. Das muss doch Palme genauso machen.
Genau, deswegen haben sie es jetzt angekündigt. Aber einen Preis haben sie nicht genannt.
Doch, es gibt einen Preis. 699 Dollar?
Ja, das hat irgendjemand behauptet. Aber HP hat keinen genannt.
Die werden schon darauf achten, dass das Ding konkurrenzgünstig ist.
Aber sie haben auch kein konkretes Datum. Also sie haben ja auch nicht... Okay, das ist ja schon viel konkreter. Ich glaube schon, dass sie das schaffen werden. Ich finde es halt, da gab es halt so einen Artikel, dass HP angeblich auch der größte Windows-Lizenznehmer wäre. Und insofern, also unter dem Aspekt finde ich das eigentlich ganz interessant.
Schauen wir doch erstmal, was überhaupt angekündigt wurde. Also sie haben angekündigt das Touchpad, 9,7 Zoll Bildschirm, Sounds Familia.
Das ist im Wesentlichen ein iPad mit...
1024 x 768 Pixel, also voll iPad. Genau dieselben Maße. Und dazu kann ich nur sagen, super.
Mehr RAM, schnellerer Pixel.
Ihr habt es verstanden. Ihr denkt euch nicht irgendeinen 16 zu 9 Scheiß aus, wie diese ganzen merkwürdigen Android-Teile, die meiner Meinung nach einfach nicht in der Lage sind mit dem iPad zu konkurrieren, allein schon weil sie kein 4 zu 3 Seiten Format haben. HP macht das. Finde ich sehr mutig, weil es ist ja auch... Ich finde es gehört auch so ein bisschen Mut dazu, komplett zuzugestehen, dass vielleicht etwas anderes einfach mal Gold richtig liegt. Und ich denke, da liegen sie Gold richtig.
Sie hatten ja nie was anderes. HP? Na, hatten die ein Tablet?
Nein, aber ich meine, es gibt derzeit ein Produkt, das ist das iPad. Und dann gibt es diverse Ankündigungen von anderen Produkten. Und dann gibt es noch 7 Zoll Varianten. Und es gibt irgendwie dieses und jenes. Wobei jetzt das Samsung Galaxy 10 Zoll auch... 10.1 heißt es, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, dass es auch Breitbild ist. Es ist auch 16 zu 9. Ich glaube schon, ich muss noch mal gucken.
Okay, weiß ich nicht.
Ich finde übrigens das 16 zu 9 gar nicht so schlecht. Und zwar, es gibt eine Situation, in der es ist echt gut, wenn man so richtig schöne breite Webseiten, also wenn man Webseiten, die sind heute nicht mehr für 1024x768 gemacht, sondern die sind immer für ein Breitformat gemacht. Und darum ist das iPad immer rauszoomt. Du hast immer ein rausgezoomtes Bild eigentlich. Und da kannst du mit so einem breiteren Display, das mehr Pixel hat, einfach mehr weisen.
Und dann siehst du aber immer noch vertikal weniger. Ich meine, das ist doch als Scope viel gesprungen.
Dann scrollst du halt ein bisschen.
Und diese Webseiten, die so breit sind, die sollen, die gönne ich alle erschossen.
Also, kann ich nicht nachvollziehen, das Argument immer nicht zu sein. Die Ergonomie ist halt, wie benutzt es so rum und so rum. Und dadurch, dass der Unterschied einfach bei 4 zu 3 nicht so mega ins Gewicht fällt, ist es einfacher, da ein User-Interface zu bauen, was in beiden Varianten funktioniert. Und ich glaube nicht, dass du so ohne Weiteres eine Applikation machen kannst, die in voll breit und in voll schlank schmal hoch genauso funktioniert. Ich meine, gerade wenn sie so breit sind, dann macht das ja dann keinen Sinn, wenn du dein Tablett vertikal hältst. Dann ist das ja noch schlimmer.
Wenn nicht für Webseiten, sollte es das nicht vertikal machen.
Naja, eben. Das heißt, das ist so nicht zu gebrauchen. Beim iPad ist es wunderbar in beiden Varianten.
Naja, gerade bei anderen Applikationen.
Aber bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei HP. Also sie haben dieses Touchpad angekündigt mit WebOS. Ist das 2.0 irgendwie?
Ich glaube sogar 3.0.
3.0? Dann haben sie einen neuen Pri angekündigt.
Genau, den 3.0.
Wieder mit Tastatur. Was ich nicht verstehe, aber meinetwegen.
Es gibt Leute, die stehen darauf. Es gibt viele Leute, die sagen, ich mag mein iPhone, aber für eine Tastatur von einem Blackberry würde ich weiterhin, wenn sie das noch hätten, würde ich es super finden. Das ist nicht meine Meinung, aber ich kenne Leute, die sowas sagen.
Ja, gibt es auch schon Leute, die sowas sagen, aber ich sehe einfach die Zahlen nicht. Wie auch immer. Sie sind der Meinung, das wäre der richtige Weg. Und dann haben sie noch so einen Mini-Pri.
Irgendwie heißt der Vier.
Irgendwie sowas.
V-E-E-R. Also zwei Telefone und ein Pad. Was ich aber noch viel interessanter fand, ist die Ankündigung, dass sie erstens WebOS auch auf andere Plattformen bringen wollen. Einschließlich ihrer Drucker.
Ach, echt?
Was total sinnvoll ist. Ich meine, ich habe einen HP Drucker. Und ich kann nur sagen, da würde ich mir nach WebOS die Hände legen, um dieses Display zu benutzen. Das macht total Sinn. Also WebOS, denke ich mal, ist wunderbar, um dieses Problem von ihren kleinen Bedienerdisplays zu lösen. Weil da haben sie einfach furchtbare, grauenhafte User Interfaces. Und damit können sie das irgendwie machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Investment in WebOS sich an sich schon lohnt, nur wegen dieser Drucker. Das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu weit gegangen, aber es macht natürlich total Sinn.
Aber grundsätzlich ist es natürlich gut, weil die verkaufen ja wahrscheinlich eine Menge Drucker. Wenn die sagen können, der User, der Drucker, der kennt sich schon mit dem WebOS aus, der wird sofort, wenn er sich so ein Tablet oder was auch immer kauft, sofort gleich sich zu Hause fühlen. Das ist ja sehr wichtig. Das ist ja auch wieder Teil von diesem Ecosystem.
Ja gut, es ist ja nicht so, dass du den ganzen Tag vor deinem Drucker stehst und benutzt.
Die Leute mögen doch das, wenn sie irgendwas schon kennen. Wissen sie, funktioniert super, gefällt mir.
Ja, das funktioniert bei Windows-Telefonen auch. Die sagen auch alle, ich kenne das vom Desktop, darum will ich es auf dem Telefon auch haben.
Aber doch nicht bei Windows Phone 7. Das könnt ihr mir nicht erzählen.
Wenn das super ist, dann wäre das auch so.
Ich denke, das ist ökonomisch jetzt einfach für HP besser. Ich meine, sie können ihre ganzen merkwürdigen OS langfristig da wegschmeißen, wieviel sie auch immer haben. Dieses ganze merkwürdige Menü hoch, Menü hoch runter, links, rechts, User Interface. Können sie wegschmeißen, bauen einfach überall einen kleinen Touchscreen ein und haben...
Vielleicht könnte der Touchscreen hier abnehmbar sein an dem Drucker.
Das nimmt man dann Telefon.
Sollte einfach eins mit reinlegen.
In jedem siebten Ei ist ein Palmpre dabei.
Und finanziert natürlich das Ganze über Tintenpatronen.
Ja, genau.
Und dann haben sie noch gesagt, sie wollen das auch auf PCs bringen.
Und da bin ich ein bisschen nach hinten übergekippt.
Ja, das fand ich auch eigentlich so den spannendsten Teil.
Gab's aber nicht von Google auch schon mal diesen OS-Ansatz auf dem Rechner?
Wie hieß das?
Was ist eigentlich draus geworden? Von dem Google-OS auf dem Chrome OS.
Kommt irgendwann vielleicht.
Immer noch.
Sie haben doch zu Prototypen von diesen Laptops ausgeliefert.
Und HB will jetzt auch so was Ähnliches starten.
Ich glaub, sie haben gar nichts dazu gesagt. Ich glaube, das Erste, was sie gesagt haben, ist, dass man sah auf diesen Bildern, also es gab so einen Screenshot quasi, wo sie es überall draufbringen wollen und dann haben sie Tablets und Handys und eben da war auch ein PC irgendwo im Hintergrund zu sehen, was dann so der erste Aufhänger war und dann irgendwann haben sie gesagt, ja, ja, möglicherweise auch irgendwann mal auf PCs. Also richtig weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt haben sie sich da glaube ich noch nicht.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es in ein paar Feldern echt sinnvoll ist, weil es gibt eine Menge PCs, die heutzutage eigentlich fast nur noch als Webbrowser benutzt werden, wo aber trotzdem eine Tastatur nötig ist. Kassen, sowas. Überhaupt in Büro, Konzernen, Infrastrukturen hast du so The Network is the Computer, die alte Java-Idee. Im Prinzip ist es so Back to the Mainframe, wo du so deinen zentralen Rechner hast und da kommen dann so deine Programme auf dein Terminal. Das ist so das VT100 der Moderne. Und das würde dann wiederum, da würde WebOS insofern sinnvoll sein, als dass es eben das Minimum, ich habe einen Browser und ich kann sagen wir mal mit Internet generell umgehen, einfach schon mitbringt, für HP dann auch nichts kostet, also sie haben einfach keine Lizenzgebühren mehr und sie sind vielleicht auch in der Lage so ein halbwegs schickes Bedienerkonzept zu machen. Das heißt aber auch, dass sie das soweit umbauen müssen, dass es eben auch ohne Touch benutzbar sein müssen, es sei denn sie bauen Touch in alle ihre Netbooks ein und machen so eine Art, naja, weiß ich nicht, dann ist PC und Tablett irgendwie so ein flüssiger Übergang.
Was ich auf jeden Fall mal noch anmerken will, ist auf jeden Fall, dass es auch sehr, sehr schick aussieht, dieses WebOS, so wie du gerade meintest irgendwie, ne? Also es sieht wirklich extrem, also von allem, was ich bisher so neben Apple gesehen hab, ist das echt mit das Schickste.
Hast du es mal genutzt? So richtig?
Ich hatte leider noch nie so ein Gerät in der Hand, ja.
Das ist also, was die echt wirklich großartig gelöst haben, das hatten sie von Anfang an großartig gelöst, das haben sie jetzt auch nochmal gut herausgestellt, ist dieses Multitasking. Das haben sie, dieser kleine Palm Pre, der viel zu langsam war und ganz furchtbar, aber da konnte dieses echte Multitasking, hast dieses Kartenprinzip, was großartig ist und die haben in der Präsentation von dem Ding, jetzt von diesem Touchpad, hatten sie zum Beispiel sowas, du siehst deine Mails und dann drückst du auf Reply und dann geht das in einer neuen Karte. Sie haben so dieses Kartenprinzip, das alles eine neue Karte aufmacht. Und dann hat er so, ja und jetzt möchte ich einfach mal in einer alten Mail nachgucken, was da so eigentlich drinne steht. Weil ohne jetzt die neue gleich irgendwie abschicken zu müssen. Und dann ist er einfach auf die andere Karte gewechselt, hat die nach vorne geholt und dann konnte er da seine alten Mails lesen. Und das ist so was, das kannst du auf ein iPad komplett knicken. Das ist, wenn du eine Mail vorne hast, im Editiermodus, dann musst du abbrechen tippen, warum auch immer. Dann musst du sagen, ja, als Entwurf speichern, dann kannst du in deinen alten Mails dann wieder zurück in den Entwurfen nach dieser scheiß Mail suchen. Und das haben die wirklich grandios gelöst. Und insofern, also ich ich bin echt drauf und dran, mir so ein Ding zu... Also ich glaub, ich...
Du würdest dir vielleicht unter Umständen eins kaufen.
Ich würde mir unter Umständen vielleicht eins kaufen.
Ich schaue, dass das iPad 2 vorher rauskommt und wahrscheinlich noch viel toller ist.
Naja, ich glaube nicht, dass du das heute entdeckt hast.
Ja, als ich mal bei HP geklickt habe, also tatsächlich gibt es diese Geräte, von denen ich gerade mungelte gerade, tatsächlich schon, das heißt dann hier irgendwie All-in-One-Touch-Smart-PCs.
Habt ihr das jetzt in Podcasts alle gesehen?
Also so ein PC mit eben so einem Touchscreen und Tastatur davor, der so flach vor einem liegt.
Das haben sie so gemacht, dass man... Also die haben ja diese All-in-One-PCs, haben wir ja schon eine ganze Weile. Und so quasi iMacs für Windows. Und die hatten auch eine Touch-Oberfläche, was relativ wenig Sinn macht, weil du sitzt da die ganze Zeit davor und jetzt haben sie so diesen Fuß eingebaut, mit dem man das auch so ein bisschen hinlegen kann, wenn man mag.
Und das ist dann als Touch-Ziel eben auch... Weil das macht eben total Sinn, eben zum Beispiel für so Kassensysteme. Und da macht es natürlich auch durchaus Sinn, ein eigenes OS anbieten zu können. Und vor allem eins, was eben gut mit Web umgehen kann.
Ich glaube, das taugt mehr als für Kassensysteme.
Na, ich meine, wenn es für Kassensysteme funktioniert, dann ist es so ihre Zielgruppe vor allem. Also es könnte sein, dass HP gestärkt hervorgeht, aber Microsoft verliert irgendwie seine Dizenznehmer.
Ja, wird auch Zeit.
Naja, von verlieren ist jetzt glaube ich noch ein bisschen früh. Um jetzt mal dein Enthusiasmus hier ein bisschen zu bremsen, weil der PC-Markt mag nicht mehr, mag sogar ein bisschen schrumpfen, aber das ist, der Automarkt schrumpft wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen, aber das ist deswegen trotzdem noch lange keine sterbende Industrie. Also da kann man noch ein paar Jahrzehnte lang sehr gutes Geld verdienen.
Paar Jahrzehnte? Und vor allem gerade ein gutes Geld verdienen. Ich meine, wer verdient denn da gutes Geld?
Microsoft.
Ja und Apple. Nein, PC. Also im PC... Ja, also Microsoft, ok. Ja, Microsoft verdient auch gutes Geld, genau. Aber mit den Geräten, meine ich jetzt. Also die Margen sind im PC-Bereich extrem niedrig. Also da ist mit viel Geld verdienen...
Ja, aber irgendwo mit wird HP auch seine Manager bezahlen. Also die wären schon noch... das mag nicht... Meinst du, die kriegen jeden Abend so ein einmal Toner nach Hause?
Ja, hast du mal geguckt, was ein Drucker kostet?
Ja, kostet gar nichts.
Völlig krank. Also ich, ich mein, ich hab mir jetzt zwar gerade einen gekauft, weil ich halt einfach einen brauchte, aber eigentlich sind das so...
Bei dem Alten, der Toner leer war.
So in etwa, ne?
Ja, aber wie gesagt, PCs verkaufen die und damit verdienen sie wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Geld.
Also HP könnte da tatsächlich irgendwie noch was reißen. Trotz allem, sie sind natürlich allein auf weiter Flur und sie versuchen quasi das Apple-Modell ohne Apple zu sein. Sie versuchen, eine Plattform aufzubauen, ohne jemals... ne, nicht jemals. Also das letzte Mal, als sie eine Plattform waren, das ist schon echt lange her. Man hat... HP ist letztes Mal ein eigenes Betriebssystem hergestellt. Das war HPUX, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Hm, das gibt's immer noch. Weil ich auf diesen... auf diesen Etanium rechne, da war doch auch ein Hapox drauf.
Ja, in der Wikipedia steht, ist ein kommerzielles betriebssystem.
Die letzte Version kam im September 2010.
Ja.
HPUX 11IV3 update 7. Das sagt doch irgendwie alles, oder?
Ja, und auf den geilen Architekturen PRisk, Etanium und Etanium 2.
Und 68.000, ne? Ebenheits?
Tatsächlich, hat sogar noch eine eigene Webseite. Na gut, aber das ist nicht so ganz das, was ich meinte.
Na immerhin, wir haben ein eigenes Betriebssystem. Wer leistet sich diesen Luxus heutzutage noch? Na ja, zwei eigene Betriebssysteme.
Aber es ist halt schon auf jeden Fall interessant zu sehen, dass die jetzt einfach alle in Bewegung sind. Microsoft bundelt jetzt hier mit Nokia an. Die HP-Leute, die haben jetzt mal Palmen geschoppt und gehen da so ihren ganz anderen Weg. Der Markt ist im Umbruch. Alle sind da ganz schön am rotieren, auf jeden Fall. Und es ist noch nicht so ganz klar, wie es dann letztendlich ausgeht, außer dass man sagen kann, dass Apple schon jetzt echt tatsächlich erstmal wirklich gut dasteht.
Diese Bonbon-Firma, wie sie immer gerne beschimpft wurde, haben die halt nicht ernst genommen und gesagt, also iPhones, das wird doch nichts, das haben die noch nie drauf. Und wurden eines Besseren belehrt. Also sie sind sozusagen an ihrer Arroganz irgendwie und haben jetzt ganz schön zu knabbern. Also ich würde gerade sagen, Nokia hat sich auch gedacht, Telefone, da sind wir die Weltmeister, da können die uns gar nichts, die kauft doch keiner. Und wenn, dann vielleicht nur so ein paar Bekloppte, die zu viel Geld haben. Aber es ist irgendwie kein Massenmarkt und ja, es war mal voll eine Fehleinschätzung. Die haben das halt mit dem App-Markt nicht kommen sehen. Die haben, na die Smartphone-Welle sollten ja eigentlich schon vorhergesehen haben.
Na Smartphones gibt es schon ewig sozusagen.
Aber ich meine, also die waren vielleicht smart, aber das war auch vielleicht nur die Features. Also vom UI war da überhaupt gar nicht smart. Das war doch eine Katastrophe.
Ich glaube, gesehen haben die das auch schon lange. Sie wussten halt, sie konnten halt bloß nichts machen.
Wenn sie es gesehen haben, hätten sie es ja mal vorbereitet. Haben ja nichts vorbereitet. Dann hätten die nämlich zum Beispiel Präge gekauft und ich HP.
Ja, warum sind das nicht... Also ich meine, das wäre vielleicht der Untergang von Palm gewesen, wenn sie es gemacht hätten. Aber ich glaube so ein Unternehmen wie Nokia, das ist genauso, als ob du da siehst, als ob du Zugführer bist und siehst, da vorne ein Kilometer ist ein Gleisbruch. Da kannst du eigentlich nur noch die Bremse ziehen und warten, bis der Unfall passiert. Vielleicht, ich glaube, so ähnlich ging es Nokia auch. Weil so ein Riesenunternehmen, das dreht sich nicht mal einfach so.
Wie kann man das denn verkacken? Also ich meine, die haben sich ja probiert, von einem OS zum nächsten. Und irgendwie haben sich da aber auch voll verzettelt. Vielleicht sind die auch einfach ungünstig gewachsen und der Laden ist intern.
Ja, es gibt ja auch interne Probleme.
Ich glaube, das ist bei jeder Firma so. Wenn die größer werden, ich glaube, das ist so, das ist ja tatsächlich eines dieser großen Talente von Steve Jobs. Das muss man mal wirklich sagen, ist Steve Jobs, dass der diesen Laden so relativ kompakt hält und dass der nicht sagt, wir wuchern jetzt beliebig in alle Richtungen. Und in dem Moment, in dem man so viel Geld hat und so viele Ideen auch umsetzen kann. Und bei Nokia sind ja auch wahrscheinlich ein Haufen talentierter Leute. Und da sitzt halt wahrscheinlich niemand, der sagt, ok, und dein Projekt wird jetzt begraben, weil wir haben hier diese, wir konzentrieren uns auf die dreieinhalb Projekte. Sondern da wird dann gesagt, ja, du kannst da ein bisschen was machen und du kannst ein bisschen was machen. Und dann machen die da alle vor sich hin und du hast keine gemeinsame Strategie.
Die mussten halt wahrscheinlich noch nie bluten, so wie Apple mal.
Habt ihr das mit Nokia Plan b.com mitbekommen? Interessanterweise leitet diese Webseite jetzt auf einen Twitter-Account um.
Die haben ja heute gesagt, dass...
Das ist ein Hoax. There are no nine young investors, just one very bored engineer who really likes his iPhone. Ja, aber sehr schön fand ich dann auch Nokia Plan c.com.
Wieder den Reifen oder was?
Ja, und besonders, was ja mein besonderer Freund ist, was sie auch schon immer gesagt haben, Nokia Plan d.com. Back to the Boots. Das ist das, was irgendwie Nokia jetzt sozusagen angetreten hat. Ja, also eigentlich sind sie auf dem direkten Weg in den Gummistiefel-Markt. Und ich hab gehört, die Gummistiefel von ihnen waren echt gut.
Ey, ihre Telefone waren auch echt gut.
Kein gutes UI, aber ansonsten.
One Hit Wonder, nach dem 6310i ging es steil bergab.
Wobei, wie lange hatten sie denn? Ich meine, die hatten doch 20 Jahre.
Gutes Telefon, ich weiß nicht. Ich fand noch nie ein Nokia-Telefon möglich.
Ich fand früher die Typo, die da drauf waren. Ich hatte eins, da war ich kurz davor, mir die Pixelschrift dafür zu kaufen.
Aber es war halt auch wirklich nur ein Telefon. Smartphone, nichts mehr zu tun oder noch nichts. Und die, die danach kamen mit diesem Bund-Display, tut mir leid, aber das ging einfach gar nicht. Und genau deswegen war das 6310 so gut, weil er war das letzte mit einem ordentlichen Display. War halt ein Telefon, hat funktioniert und sonst nichts. Und das ist das, was man will, wenn man ein Telefon will. Nee, heutzutage will man mehr.
Heute will man einen Taschencomputer.
Ja, heute will man noch ein iPod und ein Revolutionary Internet Device haben.
Und diese ganzen Smartphones, was die da so hatten, ich weiss nicht. Was ich bei den Leuten so gesehen hab, das war einfach.
Na, ich hatte ja mal so ein Sony Ericsson P800, dass wenn er das jetzt mal, die Bilder euch anguckt, er denkt auch, oh Gott, langsam ohne Ende konnte nüscht. Ein Horror.
Also ich hatte, was hatte ich, ein Nokia 70, ein Nokia N70 und ein Nokia N95. Das war damals so das absolute Flagship, das hatte ich so für längere Zeit zum Testen. Und das war nicht das Problem, dass das Ding langsam und scheiße und weiß ja toll was war, sondern das war einfach, das hat niemand zu Ende gemacht.
Das war bei diesem P800 und diesem Symbian, es war das auch so.
Das hat sich nicht so wie so ein, wie jedes andere Gerät einfach in WLAN eingewählt und dann war gut, sondern obwohl es WLAN hatte, sondern man musste bei jedem Programm separat einstellen, dass es über WLAN jetzt reingeht.
P800, dieses Ding da ja.
Das fand ich eine Zeit lang ganz schick, das P800.
Das ist alles so ein Dreck. Ich hab mal mein Nokia, jetzt weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr, wie es heißt, wie geil. Ah ja, E71, glaube ich.
Ach, das war wirklich, also wirklich furchtbar.
Dieses riesen Klopperteil.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, dass du darauf total stolz warst.
Ja, aber nur für sehr kurze Zeit.
Du hast erzählt, du hast total damit angegeben, dass du es versehentlich draußen liegen lassen hast. Es hat geregnet, es war nicht kaputt danach.
Die Hardware war immer gut, das stimmt. Sie können sowas bauen.
Sie hatten den richtigen Tastendruck meistens.
Ja, da hab ich gar nichts dran auszusetzen. Aber schön ist anders und Software war einfach nur eine einzige Barrage. Gerade das mit dem W-Lan. Ich hab dann mal meinen Freund Hain, hallo Hain, wenn du zuhörst, hallo Hain. Dem hab ich mal irgendwie das Telefon gegeben. Der Typ ist blöd, der kann programmieren, der kennt sich aus, der ist schon seitdem nicht mehr dabei. Der ist kein Blöd? Nein, kein Stück. Hier hast du mein Telefon, du buchst dich jetzt in dein eigenes W-Lan ein, ich war bei ihm zu Hause, du buchst dich jetzt mal mit meinem Telefon in dein eigenes W-Lan ein und ich stoppe die Zeit. Er fragte mich irgendwie, wie schlimm es denn wäre. Oder irgendwie sowas war die Diskussion. Ich meine, hier nimm, buchst dich in dein eigenes W-Lan ein, versuch es selber rauszufinden. Also musst du sozusagen mit diesem Menü klarkommen. Was glaubt ihr, wie lange hat es gedauert?
Es hat nicht funktioniert.
Doch, er hat es irgendwann hinbekommen.
Das ist ja schon mal eine gute Vorgabe, okay halbe Stunde.
Viertelstunde.
Geht doch.
Viertelstunde?
Der Windows-Dauer ist lange, hab ich auch das Gefühl.
Ich hab mich gerufen bei dem Server und mir eine Festplatte schicken lassen.
Aber das kenne ich auch von anderen Telefonikern. Aber sag mal, dieses e-Logistik...
Ah, Hein, hör zu. Hallo, Hein.
Wie hieß das?
Ne Viertelstunde gebraucht.
Wie heißt dieses Motorola, was alle hatten, Razer? Das ist, das war, kenn ich jemanden, Sascha Lobos Lieblingstrick war das, wenn jemand das Razer hatte und gesagt hat, das ist ein gutes Telefon, dann...
Mach mal 16 Minuten, hat er gesagt.
Dann mach mal die Tastentöne aus. Das war so was, damit konnten sich die Leute auch einen ganzen Abend beschäftigen, dass sie probiert haben, auf ihrem Motorola Razer die Tastentöne auszukriegen. Das kann doch nicht so schwer sein, das mach ich.
Aber sag mal Tim, du hattest ja das erste iPhone gar nicht, oder? War das in der Zeit, wo du das E71 hattest? Du hast das erste iPhone, hast ja gerade ausgesessen, oder?
Habe ich ein E61, jetzt komm ich total ineinander.
Ich glaube, das war 71 oder so.
Aber war das erste iPhone, hattest du nicht, oder Timme?
Nein, hatte ich nicht.
Skandal.
Ja, da war er noch kein Believer damals.
Nee, ich hatte kein E71.
Ich hatte, glaube ich, doch ein E61.
Ich glaube, die bringen auch hin und wieder mal diese Handgeräte.
Ah, ich hatte einen. Entschuldigung, ich hatte ein E61.
Doch.
Ja, schön in der Wikipedia auf so einer Übersichtsseite. Natürlich wurden mehrere Telefone auf einer Seite drauf.
Nokia E-Series.
Mann, echt Wikipedia ist so eine Enttäuschung.
Das kann man sogar noch kaufen.
Was?
Für 189 Euro. So Nokia E-Series.
Gibt es aber Amazon.
Naja, jetzt 23 Software-Updates später.
Also man kriegt 198 Euro, wenn man das kauft.
Gebraucht.
Ich hab ja mein altes iPhone 3G verkauft und hab dafür, na, was hab ich für mein altes iPhone 3G bekommen?
300.
Ne, so viel nicht mehr. 250.
Für ein 3G?
16 GB Schwarz. Wann denn?
Jetzt gerade?
Mit einem Knackser am Dock-Connector. Also weißt du so, das Plastik da so einen kleinen Sprung drin. Ansonsten hinten verkratzt, vorne alles clean.
200?
279.
Ich hab dann noch 200 für mein erstes.
Weil wir ja letztens irgendwie von rechts unten kaufen oder Apple kaufen und dann hoher Wiederverkaufswert. Das hat sich für mich voll bestätigt, weil der Preis, den ich für das iPhone 4 bezahlen musste bei der Telekom für das nächste war ja 200 Euro oder so. Von daher war das ein guter Schnitt.
Aber 63 CNI gibt's auch noch. 128 Euro.
Einzige Feature, was mir an dem E61 gefallen hat und was mir beim iPhone noch heute fehlt, ist einfach, dass es mir mal meine upcoming Termine auf den Startscreen haut.
Aber Tim, das braucht auch niemand.
Ja, naja, doch. Das wär, glaub ich, echt mal schön. Das können Sie mal langsam einführen.
Ja, also dieses Notifications und so. Also die Apple-Jungs, die haben schon noch ein bisschen Raum zum Verbessern. Aber was ich echt geil fand, dass jetzt hier nicht nur die Microsofts, die es gesagt haben, dass jetzt wann kommt Multitasking und Copy-and-Paste in den iPhone 7? Wie die alle Apple ausgelacht haben, als sie ohne Multitasking und Copy-and-Paste an kamen. Und jetzt kommt hier das große Microsoft und...
Ja, wenn man es nämlich selber machen muss, dann stellt man fest, wie schwierig das ist. Und ich glaube, dass mit diesen Notifications ist genau das gleiche Ding.
Wie Notifications?
Naja, das ist ja das, was sozusagen bei iOS derzeit noch super akan ist.
Ja, aber Notifications ist bei allen anderen besser.
Also das haben die alle gut gelöst.
Das war das, was ich sagte.
Arkane, Voodoo-Magic, zaubermäßig.
Schlecht, altes Feuerstein rein.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, schon klar.
Das ist halt so, wie es derzeit ist. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie dieses Thema nicht auf dem Radar haben, sondern ich glaube fest daran, dass sie drüber nachdenken, wie sie es richtig machen.
Ja, ich hoffe es ist stark.
Ja, sollen sie langsam mal fertig werden mit überlegen. Ich meine, andere haben schon ganz okaye Ideen zumindest gehabt, die funktionieren.
Bei Palm soll das doch auch ganz gut sein, oder?
Bei Palm ist es ganz gut, bei Windows 4 und 7 ist es ganz gut, bei Android ist es noch am schlechtesten und bei iPhone ist es...
Gab es nicht irgendwo bei FSCKlog, dass der Typ, der bei Palm diese Notifications gemacht hat, der jetzt bei Apple ist?
Der ist schon ewig lange bei Apple. Den haben sie schon vor über einem Jahr, glaube ich, abgeworben.
Vor einem Jahr ist es ja dann noch nicht ins iOS 4 eingeflossen, also das heißt, es kommt dann jetzt vielleicht.
Mal reden.
Seit Generatoren.
Ich bin da mal sehr gespannt drauf.
Apropos alte iPhones, ich habe gerade mal wieder eine erfolgreiche Tauschaktion im Apple Store gemacht. Ich war nämlich kurz in Frankfurt und habe mich da gleich mal wieder eingeritten und habe erst mal so wieder meinen Bündel toter Headsets.
Der schon wieder.
Naja, ich hatte zwei und dann hatte ich noch beklagt, wenn ich seine iPhone Headsets umtauschen würde, könnte man sich dieses Subscription Modell sparen. Dann hatte ich noch, ich habe ja noch einen 3GS, was ich bisher noch nicht mich getraut habe zu verkaufen.
Warum nicht?
Weil ich einfach so ein Backup-Phone ist super und im Ausland ist es absolut sinnvoll, zwei zu haben. Weil dann ist man so ein lokales Modem mit Pay. Prepaid Karte, genau.
Danke.
Und das ist halt noch unter deinem eigenen Phone erreichbar. Aber irgendwie verlor es binnen eines Tages im ausgeschalteten Zustand seine Ladung. Das war mir dann doch ein bisschen zu schlecht. Und als ich es dann auf dem Apple Store auf diesen Genius Bar Tisch legte, hatte es auch schon ein bisschen an Umfang zugenommen. Der Akku blähte sich nämlich auf, was dann auch sofort festgestellt wurde. Also irgendwie hat sich das Ding irgendwie selbst zerfressen.
Sein iPhone hat probiert, ihn umzubringen.
Ja, es ist ihm aber nicht gelungen.
Danke Genius Bar.
Ein Niegelnagel Neues.
Und iPhone Kabel.
Alles super und alles mal wieder total unkompliziert.
iPhone Kabel oder nur Kopfhörer?
Kopfhörer. Ich weiß nicht, warum sie diese immer noch so verkaufen, aber die Teile gehen mir einfach schneller kaputt.
Na, weil mein iPhone Kopfhörer ist nämlich verschwunden, ich hab den irgendwo liegen lassen. Also der noch von euch an übrig hat, ne?
Xxxx, verschwunden mit Headset.
Die mit dem, wo man auch die Lautstärke klicken kann, und so on off und next track und so, die Dinger.
Ja.
Was beim iPhone halt dabei ist.
Du hast hier eins liegen lassen?
Nee, irgendwo hab ich halt verdingst.
Kann man kaufen.
Bei dieser Abtocker-Firma, bist du das Wahnsinns?
Genau, Apple fand ich im Falle.
Kostet nur 25 auch?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Doch, mindestens.
Und die sind so schlecht. Dieses komische Gummikabel, ich weiß nicht, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben. Das ist furchtbar. Das ist so die Einladung, sich überall zu verheddern in kürzester Zeit.
Nee, ich find das gar nicht so schlecht, weil die haben so ein Gummi gewählt, was nicht so leicht verknotet.
Ja, das behaupten sie, aber bei mir verknotet es schneller als alles andere.
Bei mir geht das auch ganz gut.
Ich muss dir wohl mal zeigen, wie man ein iPhone-Kabel aufwickelt, sodass es sich nicht verknotet.
Du kannst ja so ein YouTube-Video von machen.
Da gibt es schon ein YouTube-Video von......YouTube.
Ja, guck mal, da fiddel fiddel fiddel.
Ja, weil ich das mal von jedem Kabel...
Ja, aber durch dieses Gummi hat es noch mehr Reibungswiderstand.
Nee, finde ich gerade nicht. Ich finde, das hat so eine gewisse Steifheit, die daran hindert, sich zu sehr zu zerknoten. Also man kriegt es eigentlich doch immer irgendwie auseinander.
Da muss ich ausnahmsweise mal zustimmen.
Wenn man das irgendwie so ein bisschen oval zusammendreht...
Apple Earphones with Remote and Mic, 29 Dollar.
Ah, 29, ja, 25 Euro, das glaube ich. Du machst da halt einfach so ein... wickelst die zusammen so ein bisschen länglich und dann lässt du hinten das Ding raus und das wickelst du dann einmal in der Mitte drum herum und steckst es dann so da.
Genau so macht man das nämlich nicht, weil so eng, wie du das jetzt wickelst, ist der Biegeradius viel zu eng und dadurch hast du nur Knicke drin.
Ich stopf sie einfach mal in die Tasche.
Also das Problem ist nicht, dass ich hier Knicke drin habe, sondern das Problem ist, dass das Detail immer wieder anfängt zu scheppern.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch was ganz anderes.
Aber vielleicht liegt das an deiner wickelten Technik. Ich hab immer das Gefühl, dass ich schonmal drüber nachdenke.
Dass sich der Gummi hier oben, der im Ohrteil dran ist, dass der sich irgendwann immer auflöst und so, so, so.
Ich nutze hier einfach gar nicht aus dem Auto beim Fahren.
Das wär so meine Ohrensubstanz. Also die Flüssigkeit, die aus meinem Ohr rauskommt. Ich hab das aber auch schon bei sehr, sehr vielen anderen Kopfhörern gesehen.
Du hast Flüssigkeit, die aus dem Ohr rauskommt, sonst wird's im Arzt gehen.
Nein, ich hab keine Flüssigkeit, die aus dem Ohr rauskommt, aber das löst sich halt irgendwann so auf.
Also ich hab so ein Produkt von Sony, meine schönen EX-71, in ihr Kopfhörer, die es in der Bauform, glaube ich, gerade nicht mehr gibt.
Und 29 Euro kostet die Dinger.
Und die halten seit Jahren und die haben auch nicht dieses komische gummierte Kabel und die funktionieren super. Die lösen sich auch nicht auf, ja. Die sind bestimmt nicht ganz vorne mit dabei, in der Klangqualität, aber...
Diese kleinen scheißer Dinger, sie sind alle nicht vorne. Das kann mir einfach keiner erzählen, die können einfach nicht gut sein. Deswegen würde ich dir auch nie Geld ausgeben, weil die ersten, du verlierst die sowieso oder die gehen kaputt oder die Karte frisst die...
Doch. Täglich. Ich schlaf manchmal sogar damit. Im Ohr. Ja, wenn ich so irgendwo bin und das schnarcht die oder draußen ist ein Presslufthammer an, dann stopfe ich mir die rein, mach mir schöne Musik an und ich hab mich auch noch nicht stranguliert damit. Also die sind super.
Ich hatte mal so Sony in ihr Kopfhörer. Die waren total super, außer dass man brauchte so diese Gummiennöppel, die man sich halt so ins Ohr reinstopfen muss, die hab ich dann regelmäßig verloren. Und die haben so ein Schweinegeld gekostet, wenn man die nachgekauft hat. Das hat, ich glaube, einer, nicht ein Paar, sondern einer, so irgendwie 7, 8 Euro gekostet.
Ja, aber immerhin ist es immer noch besser als 25 Euro gleich für ein neues auszubehauen.
29 Euro.
Das sind ja 69.
Darf ich die wichtige Diskussion kurz ergänzen? Also wir haben ja zuletzt über diese Bluetooth-Headsets geredet, die ich jetzt häufiger noch im Einsatz hatte, diese MM550, beziehungsweise davon gibt es ja auch noch die billige Variante, die PX360, wo ich fast das Gefühl habe, die hätten mir auch gereicht. Und ich habe noch so ein paar mehr Erfahrungen damit gesammelt. Ich habe vor allem eine Menge Fragen dazu bekommen, die wollte ich mal kurz beantworten. Also was mich persönlich noch ein bisschen stört, und ich weiß nicht genau woran es liegt, ist aber die Gesamtlautstärke könnte für mich ein bisschen wummiger sein. Das ist schlimmer an diesem ganzen digitalen Kram, da hilft dir dann dein iPhone auch nicht, wenn es mehr Power hat, sondern wird halt einfach so übertragen. Und was das Teil nicht verstärkt bekommt, naja, das kommt dann halt auch nicht an. Sprich, du bist noch so ein bisschen anfälliger bei leisen Podcasts, die es nicht geben sollte, aber es dann doch immer wieder gibt. Und dann haben viele Leute gefragt, ob die Teile denn auch taugen für Internet-Telefonie. Und dann kann ich eigentlich nur sagen, nö. Denn die sind geschlossen, das heißt, du bist super isoliert. Und damit bist du auch super isoliert von deiner eigenen Stimme. Und wenn du deine eigene Stimme nicht hörst, dann ist so Telefonie eine schlechte Sache. Weil dann fängst du an zu schreien oder verstehst dich nicht. Und da die Software heutzutage keine Möglichkeit hat, in der Regel so einen Monitor-Modus dazu zu schalten, kenne ich zumindest nicht. Skype hat das nicht. Andere Programme wüsste ich jetzt eigentlich auch nicht. So dass du quasi in dein, dass du dein eigenes Signal noch in deinen Kopfhörer mit reingeschaltet bekommst. Warum es das nicht gibt, weiß ich nicht. Aber wäre wahrscheinlich bei Bluetooth dann auch nicht so schön, weil dann wieder die Latenz dazu kommt.
Du bist sicher, dass das keine Gewöhnungssache ist?
Och, weiß nicht, da kann man sich dran gewöhnen. Aber ich glaube, da will man sich nicht dran gewöhnen. Also so funktioniert einfach ein Telefon. Auch dein iPhone, alle machen das. Alle mischen deine Stimme. Du hörst in deinem Kopfhörer nicht immer nur das, was der andere sagt. Du hörst dich selbst dadurch. Das war schon beim alten, guten alten Analog-Telefon so. Und das ist einfach so funktioniert Telefonhörer. Und wenn du halt so...
Beim Analog-Telefon war es auch schon so. Obwohl du das andere Ohr sogar noch frei hattest.
Da war es gar nicht zu vermeiden, weil du hast ja eh nur zwei Draht und das ist irgendwie alles über eine Leitung. Also das ist so. Du willst einfach Feedback haben. Du willst dich selbst auch mit im Kopfhörer hören. Wenn die Software diese Möglichkeit nicht bietet, dann bist du mit geschlossenen Kopfhörern immer ein bisschen daneben. Also diese typischen PC, USB-Headsets, die man hat, das sind meistens immer nur so, das sind keine geschlossenen, sondern das sind halt so aufliegende. Das heißt, da hörst du dich einfach über die Luft noch mit. Und deswegen ist das okay. Aber mit den Dingern, wobei jetzt komme ich gerade ins Grübeln, weil ich ja auch, wie ist denn das, wenn ich das Ding als Headset benutze, da habe ich den Effekt ja nicht. Macht das dann das iPhone? Oder ist das ein Modus des Headsets, dass der das dann macht? Da muss ich leider nochmal drüber nachdenken. Das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, das nochmal genauer zu beleuchten. Ja, so viel zu meinem wunderbar durchrecherchierten Beitrag. Jetzt komme ich echt ins Grübeln gerade. Ich werde das nochmal testen. Nächstes Mal nochmal was zu sagen.
Die Dinger hier zu kriegen. AJ4 heißen die. Die scheinen es jetzt mittlerweile zu geben. Das sind so iPhone Kopfhörer auch, mit lauter Leiser und Play-Pause. Die sind auch so In-Ear Kopfhörer, sehen ganz gut aus. Haben so ein bisschen breites Kabel. A minus J's.
A minus J's?
J-A-Y-S. Vier Buchstaben. Ich schmeiß das mal kurz in den Chat den Link dazu.
AJ's.
In-Ear.
Genau, und ich finde die sehen richtig, richtig cool aus. Vor allen Dingen, die machen einen extrem durchdachten Eindruck. Die haben zum Beispiel so einen flachen Kopfhörerausgang, der so sofort gewinkelt ist, damit das auch am iPhone, wenn man es in die Tasche stopft, man sich nicht sofort den Kopfhörer kaputt macht.
Das ist bei meinen alten Sony Kopfhörern auch so. Aber die sind so ähnlich wie die, die Dr. Drake und Lady Gaga doch so promotet haben.
Keine Ahnung, was die so promotet haben.
Die mit dem B drauf, die auch die deutsche Nationalmannschaft großflächig tragen zur Schau.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Du warst ja mal wieder bei einer Allgemeinbildung.
Der Mesut Özil, der hat nämlich bei der WM, bei der letzten, war das die WM überhaupt? Da hat er nämlich immer und ein paar andere auch von den jungen Spielern, hatten diese Kopfhörer drin. Und Dr. Dre und Lady Gaga haben die promotet. Und die heißen Beats oder so. Und die sehen nämlich sehr ähnlich aus zu denen. Und jetzt frage ich mich, ob die vielleicht einfach nur relabelt sind. Aber nee, guck mal, die sehen ein bisschen anders aus. Aber die haben auch ein flaches Kabel.
Die sehen auch total anders aus.
Ja, die sollen auch. Also Dr. Dre persönlich hat die ja...
Setzt die auf, wenn er dafür bezahlt wird.
Krass.
Wie heißen diese, die du meinst, gerade?
Monster Beats Tour High Resolution.
Also die Marke heißt irgendwie Beats oder so. Die haben auch eine extra Seite dazu.
Ich hab mir gerade Schuhe empfohlen.
Warte mal, ich such mal gerade nach Dr. Dre.
Monster Beats...
Ja warte, ich such mal hier. beatsbydre.com Genau und die haben so normale Studio-Kopfhörer.
Die kosten auch nur 130 Euro.
Naja, die sind richtig... Definitiv über Kopfhörer. Ich hab dazu keine Reviews gelesen. Es hat mich halt, weil die in ihr Kopfhörer auch so eine Flachbandkabel haben, hab ich mich daran erinnert gefühlt gerade.
Achso, aber du hast sie nicht ausprobiert.
Nee, ich hab, wie gesagt, nur die deutschen Nationalspieler zum Beispiel damit herumlaufen sehen.
Wirklich?
Ja, da gibt es bestimmt Bildbeweismaterial im Internet. Na ja, kann man sich ja vielleicht, hat der irgendein Hörer oder so, dann später in den Kommentaren was zu diesen Beats zu sagen. Ansonsten seid ihr jetzt nur so am Rand vermerkt und keinerlei Produktempfehlungen. Und wenn du DJs hast, dann kannst du ja auch mal berichten.
Ja, ich überleg hier gerade, ob ich die hier bei PIXMANIA kaufe. Kann man das machen? Sieht irgendwie so ein bisschen so rosa aus.
Bei PIXMANIA hab ich glaube ich auch schon mal was bestellt.
Ja, und das hat geklappt. Gut, dann probier ich das jetzt auch mal aus.
So ein Web-Store.
Das sieht irgendwie so rosa aus, als ob da, ich bin Neukunde.
Jetzt wird ihr live in der Firma, in der Firma im Podcast.
Live im Podcast Hardware kaufen, genau.
Das ist ja auch der 60. Geburtstag immerhin.
Der 60.
Geburtstag, nein, der 60. Folge.
Das ist doch was zur Tat. Das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt. Aber was ist das schon?
Goldene Hochzeit mindestens.
Was ist das hier, Ihr Geburtsdatum? Was soll das sein? Welche Sprache ist das?
Hau ab du Sau heißt das. In etwas unfletigere Formuliere.
Ich habe noch einen kleinen Zwischenbeitrag, nachdem wir uns langsam wieder abgekühlt haben von dieser No-Care-Diskussion. Das fand ich extrem schön von euch.
Jetzt geht es langsam zum Mitleid über.
Wir haben ja noch nicht WebmRw.
Das Reizthema kommt noch. Ich habe ja in der Zwischenzeit mal Webstatistiktools ausprobiert. Ich bin ja...
Wie hieß das früher? Analog?
Nee, Webelizer und AV-Stats sind so die Klassiker. Diese Tools sind schon seit...
Die sind keine Klassiker. Analog hieß der früher. Klassiker ist schon noch ein bisschen länger her.
Okay, ich kann mir nämlich...
Webelizer ist schon richtig moderne Scheiße.
Ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können, dass Webelizer noch irgendwas davor hatte, was noch weniger...
Ja, da kam Analog davor und vor Analog kam das Log-File.
Na gut, also, jedenfalls die meisten werden schon mal AV-Stats oder Webelizer zumindest gesehen haben. Und dann gibt es halt natürlich Google Analytics, so, was im Prinzip ja jeder macht, der nicht groß drüber nachdenken will. Dann gibt es so ein Tool namens Mint. Da muss man allerdings, glaube ich, einmal 39 Euro oder so was bezahlen. Dann kann man es aber auch selber hosten. Und dann gibt es jetzt seit Kurzem so zwei, oder ich weiß nicht, wie lange es die schon gibt, aber noch nicht so lange, gibt es zwei Open Source-Statistiktools, die so ein bisschen versuchen, so wie Google Analytics, alles ein bisschen attraktiver aufzubereiten, mit Live-Views, die man eben selber hosten kann. Und da bin ich natürlich als Google-Boykotteur daran interessiert. Und das eine heißt Pivik, und das andere heißt Slim Stats. Und Pivik ist halt schon eher so, noch eher in Google Analytics Style. Da gibt es auch bei beiden eine Demo-Website. Pivik, W-I-K.
Das sitze ich auch so ein für meine ganzen Blogs.
Die sind auch auf Flatter.
Ja, die sind auf Flatter und die haben auch viele deutsche Supporter. Also Moviepilot, also ein paar Start-ups, oder sogar Konrad und irgendwie so benutzen das. Und ich bin ja jemand, der zum Beispiel, also in der Uni hoste ich ja auf einem Server mehrere Websites. Und ich hoste auch so hier und da ein paar Websites. Und mit Pivik kann man halt einmal das installieren auf einem Server und kann mehrere Sites damit tracken. Also man kann dann halt irgendwie schön Userverwaltung da drin machen, neue Sites eintragen und alles so schön im Blick haben. Du hast auf dem Dashboard so Live-Visitors, die dann so rechts vorbei scrollen. Also du siehst dann, wenn jetzt gerade jemand auf deine Seite klickt, siehst du es halt auch auf dem Dashboard sofort erscheinen. Und es hat, also es ist noch sicher lange nicht fertig, so dieses Pivik, aber es ist schon mal echt für selber hosten wirklich ganz cool. Es lässt sich auch relativ simpel installieren und gerade für Leute, die so mehrere Hosts haben auf einer Maschine oder in einem Netz und nur einen zentralen Statistik-Host haben wollen, ist das echt super. Und dieses Slim Studs, das habe ich noch nicht sehr viel ausprobiert, weil das ein bisschen zickig war. Das hat halt, wie der Name schon sagt, eher so den minimalistischeren Anspruch. Ich glaube, es ist sogar slimstuds.com oder irgendwie sowas. Da gibt es auch eine Demosite. Wo bist denn du abgebogen?
Ich finde seine Webseite ganz schön, vidone.com, dass der Programmierer von diesem Slim Studs unser Spruch ist. Steven Whittone ist ein Software-Engineer, der das Internet 1994 entdeckt und seitdem nicht geschlafen hat.
Also auf slimstud.net gibt es das zu sehen. Und das ist sozusagen, wie gesagt, eher so ein bisschen ein leichter Ansatz. Du kannst meines Wissens auch nicht mehrere Sites mit einer Instanz statistifizieren, sondern du müsstest dann halt pro Webseite, die du checkst, ein so ein Ding irgendwie hosten. Der Vorteil ist, dass es performt ein bisschen besser, ist ein bisschen knackiger, machst einfach weniger Load auf der Maschine und die Views. Pivik benutzt halt viel Flash-Grafiken. Ja, also man kann es auf dem iPhone auch immer noch sinnvoll betrachten. Also die Auswertungen für Keywords und den ganzen anderen Cramp, die sind auch auf dem iPhone gut zu betrachten, aber die Graphen sind da alle in Flash. Und bei SlimStats ist es halt, glaube ich, größtenteils gerendertes Bild. Und man sieht es ja auch auf der Seite dann, slimstat.net, da haben sie gleich so ein paar iPhone-Views. Und das ist einfach auf dem iPhone besser, sozusagen, zu betrachten. Das Pivik funktioniert da auch, aber SlimStats ist so einfach ein bisschen slicker.
Und das installiert man dann, das saugt sich einfach die Logfiles rein und fertig?
Nee, nee, nee, das macht nicht die Logfiles, sondern du machst ein JavaScript-Snippet an dir das Ende deiner Seite. Und dadurch können die halt auch Resolutions tracken und so richtig, also schon umfangreiches tracken, wo sie geklickt haben, ob sie wiedergekommen sind, wann sie wiedergekommen sind, der ganze Krempel. Und das, was du sonst eben dann Google Analytics abgibst, das gibst du dann einfach nur dem Webseitenbetreiber selbst ab. Das ist eigentlich, also ich finde das ganz sympathisch, ja. Wollte ich mal so erwähnt haben, wenn man schon mal sowas ausprobiert, nicht?
Ja, das ist gut. Ich hatte das auch neulich gesehen, aber noch keine Gelegenheit, das irgendwie mal auszuprobieren.
Bei Pivik kommt auch wahrscheinlich nicht dieses Jahr, wahrscheinlich sogar noch im Sommer, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, auch die Version 2.0, wo sie dann wahrscheinlich nochmal einen großen Schritt nach vorne machen werden. Ja.
Da ist doch gerade erst die Version 1.0 fertig geworden.
Ja, aber sie schrauben schon an der nächsten.
Also Pivik nutze ich jetzt schon seit einer ganzen Weile und finde es gar nicht schlecht. Also es ist...
Ja, die sind vor allen Dingen auch so...
Man kann mehrere Sites tracken und...
Du kannst halt auch so Kampagnen machen, also wenn du halt sehen willst, welches Medium dir jetzt am meisten Feedback bringt, dann kannst du halt einen Special-Link generieren. Und wenn du den rausgibst, dann wird dir gleich so eine Kampagne zugeordnet und dann kannst du halt irgendwie sehen, wie so dein Return-of-Click-Value ist für bestimmte Medien und so. Also die haben schon echt ein paar coole Features, so ein bisschen in der Auswertungsflexibilität könnten sie noch ein bisschen zulegen, aber... Ich habe mit denen jetzt auch schon mal so im Irk oder so gechattet und die waren auch recht responsiv. Also ich hatte mal ein Problem und das wurde auch innerhalb von 24 Stunden gleich gelöst. Die scheinen da auch auf jeden Fall ganz aktiv auch dabei zu sein.
Aber für click-responsive-Dingsbums, da finde ich ja hier gu.gl ganz gut, also so dieses Google, diesen Google URL-Shortner. Weil der zeigt einem auch an, wie viele Clicks man auf so einen Link drauf hat und so was.
Ja, man kann schon sehr viel machen in diesem Google-Universum.
Das war's.
Von der Statistik-Fraktion erstmal.
Ja, das ist bestimmt für viele Leute auch hilfreich. Jetzt können wir ja mal wieder ein bisschen über Apple reden. Zum Beispiel, lass uns mal über WebM reden.
Ich geh mal kurz auf Klo.
Na ist ja was interessantes passiert. Also ist nicht viel passiert. Aber was ich ganz interessant fand ist, dass bekannt wurde, ein Link herumging, darüber geschrieben wurde, dass es offensichtlich am 24. bis 28. Januar in Korea ein MPEG-Meeting gab. Und vom 28. Januar sind auch sozusagen die Notizen, die da ins Web gestellt wurden. Und das ist so eine Woche nachdem Google die Sache angekündigt hat, dass sie keinen H264 mehr in HTML5 machen wollen. Naja, und der Inhalt ist im Prinzip, also der Titel ist hier MPEG Envisage, das ist Royalty Free MPEG Video Coding Standard. Kurz gesagt, sie versuchen ihre Licencies zusammen zu trommeln, um auf, da steht hier nicht so, auf der Basis steht hier nicht, aber hier steht, Better compression performance than that offered by MPEG2 and possibly comparable to that offered by the AVC Baseline Profile, also bei dem H264, dem niedrigsten Profil, also das, was auch schon der iPod 5G unterstützt hat, bis auf eine Ausnahme. Das ist hier sozusagen das Ziel. Jetzt könnte man natürlich denken, dass diese Ankündigung von Google auch mit diesem Treffen im Zusammenhang steht.
Dass die Ankündigung von Google mit dem Treffen, ach so, dass die sozusagen...
Ja, das war eine Woche vorher. Die werden das nicht einberufen haben deswegen.
Nein, das werden sie nicht.
Keine Ahnung, was die für Vorlaufzeiten haben, aber bestimmt nicht eine Woche.
Aber ich nehme an, dass Google die schon mal vorgewarnt haben wird.
Dadurch?
Ich glaube, das hat sich ein bisschen abgezeichnet, dass Google jetzt H264 nicht mehr ganz doll liet hat. Darum werden die das dann schon so mit auf die Tagesordnung gepackt haben. Dass Google das dann strategisch günstig eine Woche vorher raus gehabt hat.
Man könnte jetzt argumentieren, dass das vielleicht alles durch Web-Apps schon mal ausgelöst wurde. Auf der anderen Seite ist es oft...
Konkurrenz belebt das Geschäft.
Ja, das mag sein.
Andererseits ist die Forderung, sowas zu machen, jetzt auch nicht neu.
Nö. Die Forderung, aber dass es denn noch mal gemacht wird, braucht du vielleicht einen Web-M?
Oder einfach Zeit.
Oder beides.
Die verzichten ja auch nicht freiwillig auf Kohle.
Also von Ergebnissen ist hier nicht so sehr viel zu... Wie ist die Formulierung hier?
Das heißt, das war jetzt schon das Ende der News?
Na ja, es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal von the News Standard zu reden. Also, keine Ahnung, wie man das lesen muss und welche Bedeutung das jetzt hier am Ende wirklich haben wird. Aber es macht auf mich so den Eindruck, als ob die Chancen nicht so schlecht stehen, als ob so eine Art Baseline-Profile H264 auch royalty-free kommen wird. Ich meine, wenn sie klug sind, dann nehmen sie einfach Baseline-Profile und dann ist es einfach frei.
Und dann nennt es halt um, damit sie ihr Gesicht wahren können.
Web H. Tja, keine Ahnung, irgendwie sowas. Also im schlechten Namen erfinden sind sie ja schon immer gut gewesen. Von daher denke ich mal, wird ihnen schon mal irgendwas einfallen. Wahrscheinlich ist es irgendwas, locker von der Zunge gehendes wie H264-X.
MPEG-5 wär doch mal super. So zu HTML5 kommt dann MPEG-5.
Web-Edition. Ich glaube, davon werden sie wohl schon Abstand nehmen.
www.h264. Webflash kommt hier gerade im Chat. Ja, aber ich habe ja auch noch mal ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, über die ganze Problematik. Weil du ja auch so gesagt hast, dass H264 so ein Web-Standard war. Oder ist. Aber ist es ja eigentlich ja nicht.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es ein Web-Standard ist. Ich habe gesagt, es ist ein Standard.
Naja, beim Web ist es jetzt quasi bisher noch nicht so unheimlich weit verbreitet.
Nur, dass jeder das macht, ja.
Nee, jeder macht das nicht. Also eigentlich hat es Apple gemacht mit Mafari, Google hat es gemacht mit Chrome und darüber hinaus nur noch Adobe mit Flash. Ansonsten eigentlich bisher noch so richtig keiner. Also Microsoft will es machen, klar. Die kommen dann irgendwann mal mit einem Internet Explorer raus, der das kann, aber so im Augenblick ist.
Opera?
Opera ist da auch kein H264.
Opera ist aber nicht die Videos im Web. Die Videos im Web sind die Webseiten, die diese Videos haben. Und sagen wir mal, irgendeinen, der nicht auf H264 geht. Naja, aber...
Nur mit Flash.
Das ist doch egal.
Wie ist es egal?
Also du kannst es auch ohne Flash haben.
H264 ist das einzige, was du derzeit überall abgespielt bekommst.
Dank Flash.
So wird es weiterhin sein.
Trotz Flash.
Nee, dank Flash.
Weil ansonsten ist ja... Also ich meine... Google hat... Was passiert, wenn ich das nächste Mal Flash sage?
Worauf willst du jetzt hinaus?
Ich will einfach nur darauf hinaus, dass bisher ist das Rennen noch lange nicht entschieden. Weil H264 hat sich im Web noch nicht halb so gut verbreitet, wie man vielleicht glauben könnte.
Das kann sich schnell wieder ändern.
Das machen eben nicht alle. Sag mir mal, irgendein Video-Anbieter, der nicht auf H264 setzt.
Einen.
Die können alle re-entcodieren. Die machen das nur, weil Flash das kann.
Ja, sie können das auch alles mit A.A.Lib in Aski Art umrechnen. Können sie auch, machen sie aber nicht.
Aski Art wäre aber schick.
Ich finde deine Aussage ist einfach Bogus. Ich meine, alle machen H264. Ja. Guck dir die Statistiken an von den Buden, die Video-Encoding-Services machen. Da geht einfach H264, das ist einfach eine Kurve, die geht irgendwie ganz nach oben.
Aber die einzige Chance, das abzuspielen ist mit einem Flash-Player. Ansonsten gibt es da nichts da draußen, was das kann. Mehr will ich gar nicht sagen. Was denn?
Alle Smartphones auf diesem Planeten, alle iPads auf diesem Planeten, alle Macs auf diesem Planeten, das auch alle ohne...
Safari, sag ich ja.
Einfach Markenanteil 5 Prozent, das ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Also auf meinem Blog hat der Safari deutlich.
Auf wobei wächst die eher wahrscheinlich auch. Keine Ahnung warum.
Ja, ist doch alles jetzt auch nicht so...
Es geht aber trotzdem, es ändert auch nichts an der Tatsache, dass alle das tun.
Max, Tim out.
Max, du redest nicht manchmal wirklich um Kopf und Kran.
Lass uns mal lieber hier über Apple streiten. In-App Purchases. Es gab ja verschiedene neue Ankündigungen von Apple, wo ich am Anfang dachte, das macht ja noch irgendwie alles Sinn. Aber mittlerweile bin ich mir da gerade nicht mehr so sicher, nachdem ich heute mal ein bisschen tiefer gelesen habe. Ich hatte jetzt leider nicht so die Zeit, mich wirklich durch irgendwelche offiziellen Apple-Dokumente außer den Pressreleases durchzuarbeiten. Es gab wohl auch eine Änderung nochmal bei den Developer Guidelines bzw. nicht in den Guidelines, sondern eine Klarstellung, die zu den Developern kam, in der sie aufgefordert werden, bis zum 30. Juni ihre Apps konform zu machen.
Zu uniformisieren.
Genau. Also was dem vielleicht vorausgegangen ist oder was parallel damit kommuniziert wurde, ich weiß auch nicht warum, irgendwie hängt das alles zusammen, ist dieses neue Subscription Modell. Na, was es jetzt nächste Woche gibt.
Nächste Woche?
Naja, dieses The Daily hat das ja im Prinzip schon. Es hat aber sozusagen dieses Exklusivrecht, zwei Wochen gesponsert von Verizon, schon mal da zu sein.
Nach ablauf der zwei Wochen meinst du, kommt iOS 4.3 und da ist es dann.
Das könnte sein, das weiß ich nicht.
Naja, ich denke schon, dass eine neue Software kommt.
Permutlich.
Könnte ja auch passen, ist eigentlich mal reif jetzt.
Sie hätten eigentlich auch für The Daily hätten sie es auch mal direkt in die App integrieren können. Wenn das das als Einziges bisher kann.
Nein, nein, nein, The Daily kann es nicht. The Daily wurde für dich bezahlt von Verizon. Das ist eine zwei Wochen Sponsoring-Aktion, die wahrscheinlich Verizon deshalb gemacht hat, damit sie diese zwei Wochen bis zum Release von iOS 4.3 dieses Hotspot-Feature anbieten können, was es ja derzeit bei AT&T nicht gibt.
Und jetzt haben sie es nochmal verlängert.
Also sie liefern ja ihre iPhones mit 4, 2, 5 und 6 aus. Da ist dieses Hotspot-Feature schon drin. Also WLAN-Hotspot, also Tethering über WLAN. Und das wird ja voraussichtlich erst mit iOS 4.3 dann auch bei den GSM-Phones möglich sein. Und um diese zwei Wochen zu überbrücken, zahlt quasi, ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so gelaufen ist, macht so den Eindruck, warum sollte ausgerechnet Verizon The Daily sponsern? Und die sind sozusagen da als das neue Subscription-Modell, obwohl es die Subscriptions noch gar nicht gibt. So, das heißt jetzt dürfen alle zwei Wochen lang The Daily schon mal lesen und danach muss The Daily das an tatsächlichen Subscriptions dann auch umsetzen. Und siehe da nach zwei Wochen, kommt die Katze aus dem Sack und Apple kündigt an, ach ja, übrigens, das gibt es jetzt auch für alle. Und wie es funktioniert, finde ich ganz interessant. Sie bieten also, so wie man jetzt kaufen kann, kann man jetzt auch Subscriptions kaufen und das verlängert sich automatisch weiter. Aber man kann halt jederzeit den Schalter ausschalten und sagen, bitte nicht weiter verlängern. Und du kannst eben in eine Woche, einen Monat, zwei Monate, drei Monate, sechs Monate und zwölf Monate Abstände irgendwas abonnieren.
Also das ist eigentlich so, wie man es sich vorstellt.
Genau.
Wie sowas zu sein hat.
Das heißt, ich kann bei zwölf Monaten keine Ahnung, wie viele Hunderte Dollar zahlen und dann kommt alles frisch neu rein, automatisch.
Genau. Und das geht im Prinzip für jedes Programm. Also du kannst das auch in Spiele einbauen, also in alle Apps, die in irgendeiner Form auf Subscription-Basis irgendwas anbieten. Und da wird es natürlich auch ganz interessant. Auch für Sachen, die bisher sowas eben noch nicht bieten konnten. Ich will jetzt nicht Podcast sagen, aber...
Aber noch Wälze.
Naja, es wäre zu überlegen. Ich meine, es gibt ja eine ganze Menge Apps, die schon so ähnlichen Kram haben. Und theoretisch, also periodical Content muss ja nicht immer nur lesen sein. Das kann ja auch hören sein. Eine regelmäßig erscheinende Radio-Show könnte genauso davon profitieren. Aber dann würde das eben auch nur innerhalb von dieser Abwelt eines iPhones funktionieren.
Wird das mir dann auch abgebucht, wenn ich es gar nicht nutze? Oder endet der Vertrag automatisch, wenn ich daily, wenn ich das jetzt abonniere und dann vergesse, wird das dann...
Und du dein iPhone verlierst und nicht abschalten kannst, meinst du?
Ich hab ja noch keinen Screenshot gesehen, aber soweit ich das verstanden habe, hat es eine automatische Verlängerung? Ob die jetzt bei default an oder aus ist, können wir nur darüber ermutmaßen. Vermutlich ist es an. Vielleicht auch nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Ah, da ist so ein Auto-Renewal-Button.
Du kannst es tun. Wo siehst du den?
Auf einem Screenshot, der jetzt hier gerade bei im Chat rumging. Von Unzuversum. Irgend so ein, keine Ahnung, ein gewisser Timo. Da haben wir es dazu geschrieben.
Okay, alles klar. Jetzt sind wir schon wieder einen Schritt weiter.
Wir sind ja auch eine Unterhaltungssendung.
Enttats noch mal eine Runde.
Es gab nämlich auch so einen anderen Artikel, über den ich gestolpert bin. Bei GigaOM. Wo auch von irgendeinem Podcaster die Rede ist, Kevin Pollack. Es gibt ja schon so verschiedene Podcaster, die ihren alten Content quasi als Musik im iTunes Store verkaufen. Aber eben nicht als Podcasts. Und in diesem Artikel heißt es am Ende, keine Ahnung, was da für ein Wahrheitsgehalt drin ist, dass dieser Pollack meint, iTunes sei gerade dabei, kurz zu entwickeln, dass es möglich machen würde, für ihn als auch anderen Podcastern für ihre Podcasts Geld zu nehmen. Ob das mit diesen Subscriptions zusammenhängt? I don't know. Ich bin auch bisher mal davon ausgegangen, dass Apple die Hände lässt von Podcasts. Einfach aus dem Grund des kuratierten Contents. Ich meine, wir sehen ja, was sie bei den Applikationen für ein Hack-Mac machen, um sicherzustellen, dass da kein Inhalt drin ist oder kein Programmverhalten, was in irgendeiner Form ihrem Image, ihrem Laden damit sozusagen schaden könnte.
Und was schadet ihrem Image mehr als unser Podcast?
Unsere würde noch durchgehen, aber es gibt schon so Podcasts, da wird auch immer mal Ficken und Hitler gesagt. Hab ich nicht, du hast das gesagt. Was ist das? Naja, ich will nur sagen, das könnte...
Holgi hat da über Cialis berichtet.
Ja, aber es sind halt so Sachen, wo ich bisher immer dachte, da Apple gar nicht in der Lage ist, diesen Inhalt zu checken. Ich meine, die können sich ja nicht alle Podcasts anhören.
Doch, Steve kann das.
Deswegen bin ich eigentlich noch... Also ich wäre immer noch überrascht, wenn sie diesen Schritt gehen. Naja, aber ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass es total unmöglich ist.
Mir geht auch ein bisschen diese Content-Zensiererei eigentlich gegen den Strich, muss ich mal sagen. Also es ist ja gut und schön, dass sie das auf ihr Image machen. Aber wenn sie schon echt alles durch ihren Scheißladen da durchruten müssen, müssen sie dann auch echt noch den Big Brother raushängen lassen und dann jetzt auch noch den Leuten erzählen, was sie da in ihre Ups publishen und was nicht. Also ich finde das ja... Irgendwie finde ich das schon ein bisschen doof.
Ja, aber die Nippel.
Ja, was mit die Nippel hier?
Die Menschheit muss von Nippeln bewahrt werden. Das scheint auch so eine amerikanische Krankheit zu sein.
Ja, aber Amazon zum Beispiel, die haben sich ja richtig, richtig stark gemacht dafür die Meinungsfreiheit und so. Im Endeffekt haben sie auch klein beigegeben. Aber da gab es doch an diesem Amazon Kindle Store so ein Riesenskandal, weil da irgendwie so jemand eine Anleitung für Pädophile geschrieben hat. Also wirklich nicht mehr grenzwertig, sondern schon deutlich. Also ich glaube in Deutschland wäre so was einfach. Du durftest es per Gesetz nicht verkaufen. Und da ist es halt gedeckt von der Meinungsfreiheit. Und das konntest du halt im Kindle Store kaufen. Und da hat Amazon echt lange gegen angekämpft, bevor sie das rausgenommen haben. Da ist über denen schon ziemlich was zusammengebrochen. Die haben immer die Meinungsfreiheit hochgehalten. Und wenn Apple sich wenigstens halb so weit aus dem Fenster hängen würde, würde ich das schon mal gar nicht so schlecht finden.
Ja, irgendwie hier bei art.com war auch irgendwie so eine Bude, die so einen schwulen Reiseführer gemacht hat. Der ist ja ein schöne Berg da im EP-Zentrum quasi und dann haben die so erzählt, also der Kollege meinte, dass dann auch jemand von Apple sogar vorbeigekommen sei, um mit denen da irgendwie mal zu gucken, was wir da jetzt nur noch drin lassen können und was nicht.
Für so eine Ab.
Wie, einem schwulen Reiseführer?
Der Darkroom ist auch ein Besuch wert, das ging dann gar nicht.
Und weißt du auch, was dabei rausgekommen ist?
Na ja, sie haben halt irgendwie Sachen rausgenommen und dann ist die ab, glaube ich, dann auch in Insta noch gekommen. Aber war halt mit Abstrichen.
Mit Abstrichen.
Ich weiß nicht, was jetzt so für Inhalte da rausmuss, aber...
Ich war nicht hier von Pixar, was ja auch eine Steve-Bude ist, dieses Video, wo die Schwulen und die...
Wo alle Schwule von Pixar sich zu Wort geäußert haben. Zu Wort geäußert.
Das war ja auch nicht schwulenfeindlich in dem Sinne, aber wahrscheinlich gab es da den einen. Ein Insider-Tipp. Ja, das ist mal alle. It gets better, heißt das. Ja, na auf jeden Fall. Das tue ich mal nicht schon, das ist cool. Das ist echt schön. Kennt ihr das? Er hat ja letztens auch so ein kleines Plädoyer für den App Store Review Prozess geschrieben und so. Aber irgendwie macht es mir halt trotzdem auch so gleichzeitig Bauchschmerzen, dass sie da alles jetzt so immer durch ihre Finger gleiten lassen und mal checken und das ist da überhaupt kein kreatives Chaos so oder kreativer Umgang mit dem Medium sozusagen erlaubt ist. Also im Sinne von...
Tja, am Ende muss man doch mal wieder Web-Applikationen machen. Da gibt es keinerlei Restriktionen. Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass es jetzt alles total dicht wäre. Ist nur so, dass derzeit, obwohl viel darüber geredet wird, wie toll doch Web-Applikationen eigentlich sein könnten und Chromo ist und was nicht alles für Verheißungen und Versprechungen schon seit Jahrzehnten gemacht werden. Auch Netscape hat im Prinzip das hohe Lied schon damals immer gesungen. Nur so richtig die überzeugenden Anwendungen sind noch nicht gekommen, weil offensichtlich diese Plattform noch nicht so ausgereift ist, wie sie es eigentlich sein müsste, damit es auch mit nativen Applikationen mithalten.
Das liegt am JavaScript, ich sag's euch.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Ist die falsche Sprache dafür.
Daran wird es am Ende nicht liegen. Sondern es ist eher Deployment, Laden. Aber es geht ja dahin, Local Storage, du kannst dich da quasi offline runterladen, vor Ort sein und so.
Es ist halt alles noch so ein bisschen, also man kann auf dem iPhone schon hervorragende Web-Applikation schreiben, du bist halt nicht in diesem App Store vertreten und ich meine, egal mit wem man redet, wenn irgendjemand auf dem iPhone sein will, dann will ja auch eine iPhone-App und will ja auch unbedingt im App Store und das ist immer ganz wichtig, dass man da drin vertreten ist.
Klar, aber dann kann man Geld verdienen.
Nee, auch wenn man es verschenkt hat, also ich glaube, das ist irgendwie so ein, ansonsten wenn man sie nicht vor, steht man irgendwie im Golf Club, steht man doof da, wenn man als Eins hier nicht im App Store vertreten ist oder keine Ahnung was. Also das ist auch selbst bei zu schenkt, zu schenkt eine Korte. Ja und dann natürlich tatsächlich so dieses Geldverdienen, das ist, da hat Apple tatsächlich, ich bin ja mal gespannt, was dieser Chrome App Store da bringt, Web App Store.
Ja da gab es doch heute auch irgendwie schon wieder so ein Video mit irgendwie mach deinen eigenen Android oder wie war das?
Ja da hätte ich mir sogar einen machen lassen, da hätte mir jemand einen gebastelt.
Aber kommen wir noch mal jetzt zurück zu diesem Ding mit dem Content. Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, hat Apple jetzt auch folgendes bekannt, also einerseits haben sie diese Nebelkerze des Subscriptions gestartet und in demselben Move quasi auch in diesem Pressrelease steht halt drin, es geht gar nicht nur um die Subscriptions, sondern es geht auch um alles, was gekauft wird und du darfst jetzt keinen Link mehr ins Web haben, um irgendwas zu kaufen und es ist auch so, und hier kommt auch noch ein bisschen, was ich bisher immer dachte, was sie tun und was ich jetzt glaube, nachdem ich das gelesen habe, was sie tun. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es jetzt so, wenn du nachladbaren Content hast, den du irgendwie verkaufst und dabei ist unerheblich, wo du ihn verkaufst, dann bist du gezwungen, diese Kaufmöglichkeit auch im In-App Store zu bieten und zwar mindestens zum selben Preis oder billiger. Was ich bisher immer verstanden hatte, was mich nicht weiter aufgeregt hat, ist, dass wenn du deine Kaufmöglichkeit hast in deiner App, dass du dann das auch mit In-App-Purchase machen musst, also wenn du sozusagen auf deine Webseite verweist, dass du es dann auch als In-App machst, aber sie gehen ja noch einen anderen Weg. Sie schmeißen Link auf Webseite komplett raus, darfst du nicht, aber du darfst jetzt auch nicht, also wenn wir das mal ein bisschen konkreter machen, Kindle, dieser Kindle-Rider müsste, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, vielleicht verstehe ich das ja auch falsch, so wie ich das jetzt zuletzt wahrgenommen habe, allein die Tatsache, dass man woanders dafür Content kaufen kann, nämlich diese Bücher, würde diese Applikation, da sie ja diesen Content visualisiert und sind, quasi über den Server, zwingen, dass man diese Bücher auch darüber kaufen muss, zum selben Preis, aber mit 30 Prozent für Apple.
Exakt, also exakt so habe ich auch verstanden.
Das ist ein starkes Stück. Weil, wenn sie jetzt nur gesagt hätten, ja nur, wenn du überhaupt es aus dem Programm heraus zum Einkauf anbieten willst, dann musst du in ab benutzen. Damit hätte ich ja noch leben können. Weil das ist irgendwie auch klar. Und bei diesem Subscription Modell wiederum ist es ja auch so. Also wenn du zu deinem Zeitschriftenverleger gehst und sagst, hier Abo. Und dann gilt das Abo auch in der Ab. Ja und dann will Apple davon nichts. Aber wenn das Abo über Apple abgeschlossen wird, dann wollen sie ihren 30 Prozent cut. Da war ich okay meinetwegen. Das ist dann ihre Infrastruktur, das ist quasi auch ihr Werbegewinn. Da sind sie das Portal und der Zuführer. Und auf der anderen Seite sind sie es nicht. Aber ich meine, bei dieser Kindle-Ab ist es ja nicht so. Ich meine, wenn die Leute über den Amazon Store da irgendwas kaufen und dann benutzt du deine Ab und züngst da dein Content rein.
Ja, hat Apple damit eigentlich nichts zu tun.
Ja, und vor allem würde Apple Amazon zwingen, quasi ihren kompletten Katalog, also ihren kompletten Buchkatalog als In-App-Purchases dabei Apple zu hinterlegen.
Wofür es nicht mal eine Möglichkeit gibt.
Das geht ja gar nicht, weil man darf nur, war jedenfalls mal so 1000 In-App-Produkte haben bei Apple pro App und man muss die alle einzeln anmelden. Du kannst nicht sagen, du willst mal fünf Dollar kassieren und du musst genau sagen, du willst fünf Dollar für folgende Sache kassieren. Dann muss Apple sagen, okay, finden wir gut, darfst du machen. Das geht halt mit tausenden von Büchern nicht. Das war auch schon das Problem bei Texter.
Ich meine, wenn sie die nicht haben wollen, sollen sie einfach verbannen.
Das große Problem daran ist, dass jeder Content, für den es eine App gibt, muss durch den App Store bezahlt auch kaufbar sein. Das heißt, bei jedem Produkt, was man verkauft, muss die Gewinnmarge so hoch angesetzt werden, dass man es verkraften kann, 30 Prozent vom Umsatz an Apple abzugeben und dann immer noch Gewinn zu machen. Also wenn man zum Beispiel Musik verkloppt, unabhängig vom App Store, auch wenn man diese Größe nicht hätte, wenn man das nicht über iTunes macht.
Und die dürfen die 30 Prozent ja nicht mehr aufschlagen, weil sie das dafür nur gleich oder weniger kosten. Das heißt, sie müssten den anderen Preis eigentlich dementsprechend erhöhen, wenn sie Gewinn machen wollen. Dadurch werden aber eindeutig andere Einkaufsquellen für die gleiche Sache, also sagen wir mal so ein Buch, werden geringer. Also eventuell schießt sich Apple auch ins eigene.
Also ich hoffe mal ganz klar, dass sie sich damit ins Bein schießen, weil wenn sie damit durchkommen, dann wäre das quasi die Apple-Steuer, die man auf alles zahlt.
Ich freu mich, wer da jetzt noch betroffen sein könnte, außer Bücher.
Also was wir gesagt haben ist, wie heißt dieser, so ein MP3-Streamdienst hat sich schon mal ganz weit aus und von und hat gesagt, wir sprechen da auch noch mal mit unseren Anwälten drüber und wir werden den Spaß nicht mitmachen. Hier Netflix, dieser Online-Videoverleih wird garantiert davon betroffen sein. Weil die halt auch, es gibt Netflix-Apps, mit denen du streamen kannst und dann musst du die halt auch darüber kaufen können. Mit dem 30%-Anteil.
Da gibt es doch die Frage mit der Buchpreisbindung, wie die denn jetzt bei digitalen Büchern gilt.
Ja, aber das ist nicht Apples Problem.
Schon klar, aber vielleicht lohnt es sich für die Verlage dann einfach gar nicht mehr und es rechnet sich nicht für die, die können den Preis nicht höher machen und die können nicht gehen, weil sie dann Verluste machen.
Ja, aber Buchpreisbindung heißt auch im Prinzip, dass das elektronische Buch genau das gleiche kosten muss, wie das gedruckte, oder?
Das heißt, dass sie den Preis nicht beliebig anheben können.
Keine Ahnung, wie sich darauf auswirkt. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die E-Bücher in Deutschland eh keine Chance haben deswegen. Aber da habe ich keinen Überblick.
Ja, du hast recht, das ist wegen der Buchpreisbindung, haben die überhaupt gar keine Chance. Beziehungsweise, nee, das hängt gar nicht an der Buchpreisbindung. Du könntest die Bücher billiger verkaufen. Aber was ich mir... es macht einfach keinen Verlag, weil die Buchvertriebslobby, also die Buchgeschäfte, so eine große Macht haben, dass so... und die sagen, wenn du das E-Book günstiger machst, dann stellen wir dein Buch nicht da vorne in den Schaufelster hinein, sondern dann stellen wir es irgendwo ganz hinten, wo es keines auf findet, rein. Und dann wirst du kein Buch verkaufen. Und da jeder Hugendubel mehr verkauft, als man mit E-Book-Verkauf erwarten kann, sagen die Händler dann, sagen die Verlage dann, okay, dann verlangen wir für das E-Book den gleichen Preis wie für die Ladenversion.
Also im Chat kommt hier nochmal so der Kommentar, dass so, wenn der Kunde von der App schon eine ID bei dem Anbieter, der App hat, bekommt Apple nichts. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, woraus diese Aussage sich ableitet.
Naja, das leitet sich aus einer Stellungnahme von Steve Jobs, die da noch mit beigelegt habt. So dieses, wir haben ein einfaches Modell. Wenn der Verkauf über uns eintritt, dann zahlen wir, dann kriegen wir 30% ab. Und wenn du sozusagen, Apple will nichts davon abhaben, wenn du über die Webseite gehst, dir da dein Netflix-Abo klickst und dann das auf deinem entsprechenden App nutzt, dann will Apple dafür nichts haben. Aber das wäre nun auch wirklich bizarr.
Das bezieht sich doch nur auf die... Das steht hier in diesem Pressrelease.
Das ist so ein bisschen...
Naja, aber du musst diese Möglichkeit halt anbieten. Das ist irgendwie ein bisschen unklar. Naja, ich denke, die Problematik existiert. Das wird sich in den nächsten zwei Wochen auf jeden Fall noch mal ein bisschen deutlicher herausschälen, glaube ich, wie das eigentlich nur wirklich gemeint ist und was es wirklich für Konsequenzen hat. Das ist noch ein bisschen zu neu für mich.
Also ich glaube, es gibt einige Apps, die sich keine Chance hätten zu existieren weiterhin, wenn das... Also das Kindle-App ist, glaube ich, so ein Fall. Dieses Sony e-Reader-App ist ja von vornherein offensichtlich wegen so einer Gemengelage abgelehnt worden.
Wahrscheinlich genau, weil sie jetzt gegen diese neuen Bestimmungen quasi...
Als lustig ist ja, das war ja noch bevor die offiziell eingetreten sind.
Ja, aber jetzt fangen sie schon an abzulehnen, weil sie es danach sowieso ablehnen müssten. Tja, was soll man dazu noch so groß sagen? Was ich noch interessant fand, ist hier dieser Feind, ich glaube, das war irgendwie auf dem FSC-Klog, dass da mal wieder so in den Metadaten von iBooks, der aktuellen Version, ein bisschen geprokt wurde und da gab es dann auch neben Books und PDFs, was ja derzeit die beiden Arten von Content sind, die du hast, auch noch ein Verweis auf Periodicals. Das könnte ja vielleicht bedeuten, dass das, was ich hier letztes Mal schon haben wollte, nämlich so eine Art Magazin-Format, durchaus auch auf dem Weg ist. Und das würde mit dem Timing jetzt ganz gut zusammenpassen mit diesen Subscriptions, weil wenn sie jetzt in iBooks auch noch die Subscriptions einbauen, und damit Magaziner deliveren.
Das würde mit den 30% auch ein bisschen mehr Sinn machen, weil dann Apple sagt, hört mal zu hier, ihr braucht doch gar nicht jetzt irgendwie dick Apps zu programmieren, sondern ihr macht den Content und wir haben den ordentlichen View dafür. Dann würde es sich zumindest schon ein bisschen besser vom Geschäft her anhören.
Auf jeden Fall.
Aber natürlich für die Verlage 30% ist schon immer noch eine ganz schöne ordentliche Summe.
Na ja gut, aber ist ja auch nicht so, dass du jetzt nichts bekommst für diese 30%. Also erstmal, du hast den ganzen Payment-Kram. Ja gut, kann man sagen, das kann man auch billiger haben als 30%, das stimmt. Aber du gewinnst dadurch halt auch mal Kunden, la, la, la. Du musst keine Software mehr programmieren, warten, pflegen, finanzieren. Ist ja auch nicht ganz billig, wenn du es ordentlich machen willst. Am Ende passt da einfach deine Preise entsprechend an.
Ich denke, wir werden einfach mal abwarten. Der Markt regelt sich schon.
Dann verstehe ich aber nicht, warum sie sich hinter so was wie dieses The Daily so sehr dahinter stellen. Das ist ja auch wieder so ein News, ein Da-Face, ein Trainwreck. Das will man doch nicht benutzen, so ein Kack.
Das ist ja die erste Version, vielleicht wird die ja noch mal ein bisschen schicker.
Aber mich lässt irgendwie tatsächlich auch dieser ganze Content.
Ich will nicht jedes Magazin anders lesen. Ich meine, das ist ja wirklich so, als ob du das eine von links nach rechts durchblätterst und bei dem anderen musst du die Seiten mit der Nase um und her schieben und das andere musst du dir aus einem Puzzle zusammenfalten.
Nee, das macht irgendwie alles noch nicht so richtig Sinn. Ich beziehe auch keinen Content aus diesem iTunes Store außer TV-Serien und Filme ab und zu. Diese Books und was nicht, das ist irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, tangiert mich überhaupt nicht. Also Buch lade ich nur PDFs selber da in dieses iBooks rein.
Also ich bin jetzt verschärft auf der Suche nach nach EPUB-Content und bin immer schon ganz enttäuscht, wenn es irgendwelche Manuals nur noch als PDF gibt, weil einfach EPUB viel besser ist als PDF.
Ja, von mir aus auch EPUB, aber... Also ich hol's mir nicht aus dem iTunes Store, weil...
Nee, ich auch nicht.
Ich würde mir was aus dem iTunes Store holen, ein Buch-Content, wenn es da was vernünftiges gibt. Ich hab mehrfach schon nach gesucht, nach irgendwas, das würde ich jetzt gerne haben und hätte es gerne aus dem iBooks Store und es gibt es dann halt immer nicht.
Zum Beispiel O'Reilly Bücher. Ja, das ist gerade ganz oben so.
Das kann man sicher fast kaufen.
Naja, ein Graschen Roman.
Und danach Katze suchen.
Anyway, wie gesagt, dieser Content da, der ansonsten außer TV-Szenen und Filmen rumfliegt, das ist irgendwie noch nichts.
Für dich ist es nichts. Ja gut, aber das findet schon so seine Freunde, der ganze Kram.
Ich glaube, dass mit diesen Zeitschriften im iTunes-Store, das hat so seinen Grund auch darin, dass da zurzeit so ein bisschen diese Verlegerrolle auch in Frage gestellt wird. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, wie ist dieser Dienst, der Kommentare sammelt, hier so Commentarist, oder was das war, der jetzt von der SZ und von der FAZ so massiv angegangen wird, dass die gleich erstmal ihre Anwälte... Ja, ja, total peinlich. Also Hintergrund ist der, es gab einen neuen Webdienst, der Kommentare von einzelnen Autoren sammelt, dann immer so die Überschrift und eine kurze Zusammenfassung liefert und dann Link auf den Content, wo man jetzt als Verlag sagen könnte, wow, die verlinken kostenlos auf unseren Content, wie geil. Endlich mehr Klicks, für die wir kein Geld zahlen brauchen. So, jetzt haben da aber die FAZ und die Süddeutsche ihre Anwälte erstmal von alleine gelassen und haben die erstmal auf irgendwie 5000 pro Link verklagt oder abgemeint oder weiß der Teufel, was ist so eine Vertragsstrafsumme, die da irgendwie in Frage kommt. Auf jeden Fall sind sie damit gar nicht, darüber gar nicht begeistert. Und ich hab nämlich das Gefühl, dass bei diesem ganzen Zeug, bei diesem RSS Feed-Readern und bei diesem Instapaper und Read it later, so dieses Problem der Verlage ganz hart zutage tritt, dass die, die bisher haben die halt ihre Zeitschrift und das war ihre einzige Aufgabe, die sie hatten. Sie haben von verschiedenen Autoren was genommen und haben es gebündelt zu einer Zeitschrift. Und in dem Moment, in dem du jetzt anfängst, dir das zu entbündeln und neu wieder zusammenzusetzen, so wie man es persönlich mag, und wenn das andere plötzlich tun, dann ist diese Rolle der Verleger fast weggefallen. Also sie müssen sich um die Bezahlung kümmern und sie müssen sich um die Bündelung kümmern. Das ist im Augenblick ihre Aufgabe. Und ich glaube darum klammern die sich alle so an diese virtuellen Zeitschriften und wollen um Himmels willen nicht ein Lesegerät für alles haben, weil dann wären sie überflüssig. Weil dann könnte man, dann könnte da jeder Autor aus seinem Inhalt rein kippen, wie er mag. Und wenn man sich das sowieso zusammenstellt, ist mir doch wurscht, ob die Quelle ursprünglich mal Spiegel Online hieß oder ein kleines Blog von dem Autor, den ich mag.
Ja, die haben irgendwie ein totales Rad ab. Jetzt habe ich irgendwie gelesen, jetzt wollen sie irgendwie, dass Google sie rettet vor Apple. Apple-Puppern, denen sie jetzt seit zwei Jahren durch die Straße getrieben haben, jetzt ist auf einmal irgendwie ihr Retter. Also sie wissen auch echt nicht, was sie wollen. Ein kleiner Nachteil, ich habe mir hier dieses The Daily gestartet und tatsächlich ist die Abo-Funktion hier sozusagen schon drin. Also irgendwie...
Gibt es das jetzt über einen deutschen Store mittlerweile oder?
Also glaube ich nicht, nee. Ich habe mir das aus dem US-Store geladen.
Du hast das aus dem US-Store, weil das da oft deutsch ist und...
Ja, aber ich kriege ja einen deutschen Dialog. Also offensichtlich schlummerte diese Funktion in dem iOS, welche wir sind, auch immer, schon irgendwie drin.
Ja.
Und The Daily durfte die ganz gnädig benutzen, dieses undokumentierte Stück API.
Und sind trotzdem durch den App-Store hier durchgekommen. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht? Also so scheint es auf jeden Fall zu sein. Also ich frage mich natürlich, wenn sie wirklich jetzt mit diesen Periodicals kommen im iBooks, was für ein Format ist das? Also worin ist das? Also ich glaube nicht, dass es PDF ist und ich könnte mir eigentlich nur vorstellen, dass sie sowas machen wie EpapX.
Ich würde sagen auch HTML.
So wie bei den iTunes Cover-Geschichten. Kannst du die Lampe so ein bisschen wegdrehen, dass sie nicht so super sind?
Epap ist HTML.
Kriegst du da auch so richtige Multimedia-Feature rein in Epap? Oder ist das einfach nur so Videos?
Kommt auf den Generator an.
Naja, ich meine jetzt so kriegt man da einen SVG rein, kriegt man da ein Canvas rein, kriegt man JavaScript rein. So dieses ganze Zeug.
Ich denke, wenn man das einfach mal deklariert, dass das da jetzt auch alles mit drin ist, dann kriegt man das da auch alles mit rein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das noch Epap nennen sollte.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, sondern Epap nennt ich.
Epap 5.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich haben sie irgendwie so einen fancy, whizzy Name dafür. Aber ich könnte die mir heißen.
Epap 264.
Na, so was könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass sie sagen, wir machen jetzt Magazins. Und übrigens, wir verwenden hier Epap, aber in The Apple Way. Und übrigens hier ist unsere Spezifikation, wie wir das machen. Das ist so, wie wir das machen. Und wenn du das gemacht hast, dann ist das einfach HTML5, das volle Programm mit Canvas, mit CSS-Transitionen und diesen ganzen Climbim, was sie jetzt auch auf ihrer eigenen Webseite gemacht haben. Das gibt es jetzt auch für Magazins. Und du musst quasi dein Magazin als Web-Magazin machen in einem ePub-Container, der eine Versionsnummer Tralala hat oder das Apple-Flag gesetzt hat oder das Multimedia-HTML5-Flag, was auch immer, wie es auch immer heißen mag. Und dann kannst du das in diesen iBook Store reintun und. Und dann kannst du dir da eben deine Periodicals kaufen.
Achso, DRM fehlt natürlich noch, ne? Ach nee, gibt's ja bei EPUB DRM.
Gibt's ja.
Und dann wär doch alles super, weil dann hättest du auch ein Format. Erstens deine ganze Arbeit in das interaktive Design deines Magazins, wenn du überhaupt eins haben willst, wäre dieselbe Technologie, die du auch in eine HTML5-Seite reinstecken kannst. Musst du halt irgendwie deinen Flash vielleicht mal rauslassen, weil da wird's bestimmt keinen Flash drin geben. Macht aber total Sinn. Anstatt, dass du halt so Flash-interaktive Grafik nahe Osten, wo brennt's, hast, machst du halt SVG mit JavaScript nahe Osten, wo brennt's. Und das hast du dann halt auch in deiner Offline-Variante deines Magazins in so einem EPUB-Container, den du über den iBookstore verkaufst und den du aber auch dann genauso gut in den Android-Bookstore verkaufen kannst. Wie heißt dieser Google Bookstore? Oder, weiß nicht, wie viel verkauft der noch?
Bücher?
Naja, Kindle ist leider raus, ne?
Warum? Wieso?
Kindle, Farbe, CSS-Transitionen, Videos, also mit so einem Teil kriegen sie es doch nicht ab.
Also zumindest theoretisch laufen sie ja noch auf Android und auf iOS und überall.
Ja gut, aber der Kindle selber, denke ich mal, ist als Target für Magazine komplett raus, ne?
Zumindest für tolle animierte Infografiken.
Jaja, und das wollen die Leute eigentlich haben. Und das finde ich dann wieder cool. Ich meine, so einen Spiegel würde ich mir abonnieren.
Also ich finde so Infografiken, wenn die...
Hat der Spiegel nicht bis heute noch Schwarz-Weiß-Bilder?
Nein. Seit Anfang der 90er nicht mehr.
Ich spiele nicht die...
Nein, aber die haben noch ein Zeitwort. Die haben aber da noch ganz viel Flashprobe im Jahr.
Ja, also Spiegel hat das mit dem Web noch nicht so verstanden.
Doch, die haben das... Ich glaube, wenn man eins sagen kann, dann hat Spiegel das mit dem Web verstanden.
Guck dir mal die Coverage von Guardian und so oder New York Times zu den WikiLeaks-Dingern an. Was die da für einen Aufwand betrieben haben, das alles zu visualisieren und bla, und dass man Spiegel da irgendwie einen Artikel mit fünf Auszügen aus den Depeche und so.
Nein, so schlimm war es nicht.
Doch!
Also, das mit dem Web, also, eins kann man jetzt dem Spiegel nicht vorwerfen, dass sie da irgendwie spät gestartet werden.
Nee, aber das, was sie gut können, ist, sie haben verstanden, dass Leute Spiegel die eher als Time-Waste auch benutzen. Also sowas wie andere Sub-Io-Klicken oder sonst was sitzen halt tausende Millionen von Leuten auf Arbeit und klicken. Die Fresh, irgendwie Fotostrecke, Kader Loth jetzt hier irgendwie oder Lady Diana oder Hitler war Vegetarier und wissen schon, was da alles nicht so kommt. Die haben das halt verstanden und die Seite funktioniert dafür auch super. Und die Leute checken halt alle fünf Sekunden ein und wollen News. Und die haben verstanden, dass Leute oft neue News haben wollen und so. Bei der Zeit zum Beispiel auf der online Seite, da hast du ja das Gefühl, dass sie das Wochenmagazin-Konzept auch auf ihrer Webseite fahren. Da kannst du dreimal am Tag irgendwie vorbeigehen, bis du da mal einen neuen Artikel irgendwo findest. Und bei anderen ist das halt auch. Sie sind viel langsamer.
Aber Spiegel haben sie immer noch nicht verstanden, dass nicht nur das Datum hinschreiben, sondern vielleicht auch mal die Uhrzeit werden, die ihre Artikel so oft updaten oder refreshen, damit man weiß, wie alt der Shit jetzt ungefähr ist.
Naja, nichtsdestotrotz funktioniert es halt bei denen einfach am besten. Aber ich finde nicht, dass sie jetzt sozusagen die Web-Technologien und die Möglichkeiten, die sich da in multimedial bieten würden, wirklich voll ausreizen. Und die sind da schon an sich noch relativ konservativ unterwegs.
Na, die könnten aber schon mal den Redakteur entlassen, der für die Überschriften zuständig ist. Der wird einfach erschossen. Muss ich jetzt mal ganz klar sagen. Wieso?
Diese Wortspielkassen, Karlauer, die sie mal reißen. Das ist wirklich unter aller Sau.
Also, Gutenberg in der Schummel verlockiert, geht noch.
Aber es sind halt alles so, weißt du, das geht halt alles über diese...
Kernkraftwerk im Kofferraum, da geht es nur über irgendwie Technik in Autos. Also der haut immer Dinge raus.
Ich glaub, das ist eine ganze Redaktion.
Ja, das ist aber horrible.
Also in der letzten Zeit waren da wirklich... Also die sind alle irgendwie so mit so einer eigenen Poetik verpasst.
Worüber reden wir jetzt? Reden wir jetzt darüber, ob jemand das Web verstanden hat oder ob er die falsche Überschriften...
Nein, Steve Jobs hätte besser Überschriften gemacht.
Wir gleiten halt auch mal ab.
Naja, ich meine, ist ja schön, jetzt hier mal die ganzen Tech-Companies zu bashen. Aber ich finde, wir können jetzt auch mal das ehemalige Nach...
Spiegelüberschriften ist das Web M der Huckel und Dennis Thiel.
Ja, wir können jetzt mal das ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin aus Hamburg ein bisschen bashen.
Ey, die beiden Spiegel haben das abgeschafft, dass man hier diese noch mehr Themen dazu aufklappen konnte. Das ist nicht mehr da.
Kann ich das Thema nochmal auf... Weiterführen?
Versuch's mal.
Also ich hab jetzt zumindest zu diesen Periodicals meine Thesen bekannt gegeben. Wir werden ja sehen, ob ich recht hab oder nicht. Richtig. Was sagt uns dann das Licht? Wo wir noch nicht so richtig viel drüber gesprochen haben, wo mir was, wo jetzt rausgekommen ist, dieses CDMA-iPhone.
Wo jetzt rausgekommen ist?
Sein Tun?
Machst du schon eins?
Warum nicht?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich hab hier mal CDMA ausprobiert, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen wenig Empfang.
Ja, aber U2 doch auch und trotzdem hast du ein U2-iPhone.
Naja, auf jeden Fall sieht es so aus, als ob dieser Qualcomm-Stein, den sie da drin haben für Spaceband, schon eine Variante ist, die auch GSM könnte. Das heißt...
Schon im Sommer könnte ein triebandfähiges iPhone rauskommen?
Naja, zunächst einmal, ich hab irgendwann mal gesagt, dass ich nicht daran glaube, dass Apple ein CDMA-Only-Phone bauen wird.
Jetzt kommst du aber mit einem Netpacking. Ich hab das auch gesagt, ich hab ein bisschen abgelost, da kann man jetzt hin und her korrigieren, wie man will. Ich hab's ehrlich nicht geglaubt.
Ich versteh mich nicht falsch, ich will mich jetzt hier nicht reinwaschen, dass meine Vorhersage nicht zu 100 Prozent eingetroffen ist. Aber wenn ich's richtig sehe, haben sie jetzt bereits schon das Design gemacht, was wohl im iPhone 5 so mehr oder weniger dann auch so zum Einsatz kommen könnte. Ja, ich denke, dass das kommt.
Du meinst, im Sommer kommt schon für die W-Revision Leute gleich ein neues Phone wieder?
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall, na klar.
Glam Chowder, Tim, Max, auf jeden Fall.
Also das nächste iPhone.
Schreiben Sie mit.
Kiste Mate. Kein Problem, die krieg ich. Haltet ihr nicht gegen.
Schulzt du mich noch an Kiste Mate? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, weswegen.
Wüsste ich auch nicht, Max.
Die Hörer werden's rausfinden.
Haben wir hier nicht mal großartig eine Kiste Mate gemacht?
Das Problem ist, wenn man im Mobile-Max-Block nach Wette sucht, dann findet man wahrscheinlich alle Episoden.
Also ihr meint, dass schon im, wann wird es sein, Juni oder Juli, kommt schon sozusagen für die Verizon-Kunden ein Update?
Wir werden ein iPhone sehen, was einfach auf beiden Netzen funktioniert, eben genau mit diesem Stein, den sie da jetzt schon drin haben. Wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal nennenswert irgendeinem Nachfolger. Ich glaube, das ist auch so das mehr oder weniger aktuelle Modell. Und der einzige Unterschied zu dem CDMA-iPhone ist halt das, was auch immer in dem neuen iPhone dann neu ist. Also neuer Prozessor, mehr RAM, keine Ahnung. Plus eben natürlich die Möglichkeit, da noch eine SIM-Karte rein zu machen, es sei denn, sie gehen halt schon auf dieses Downloadable.
Bei Apple ist es natürlich, als gerade einer schlägt die Hand von Kopf und sagt, man, dieser Idiot Prittler, jetzt kauft niemand mehr unser CDMA-Phone gerade, weil die warten jetzt alle auf das Neue, was macht der Typ nur?
Die zahlen halt nicht gut genug, offensichtlich.
Ich bin ja noch nicht so überzeugt, wobei die dann bis nächstes Jahr warten lassen, glaube ich ja auch nicht so richtig. Und dass aber ihre iPhone-Ausgabetermine verschieben, glaube ich auch nicht so richtig. Also ich bin gespannt. Ich bin mir da nicht sicher, weil bei Apple ist man sicher heutzutage weiß man ja nichts mehr, deswegen, ich weiß auch nichts.
Ich weiß auch nichts. Ich lese hier auch nur den, wie sagt man so schön, was liest man?
Den iPhone-Wette mal vor Ewigkeiten.
Und?
Womit? Ich habe jetzt mit Max eine Wette laufen, dass das iPhone es bis einschließlich Mai 2008 auch in Deutschland schafft, das meistverkaufte Telefon zu werden. Eins als eine Kiste Club Mate.
Ja, und? Was war das meistverkaufte Telefon?
Irgend ein anderes. Keine Ahnung.
Nokia.
Aber es steht...
Ah, aber es hat nicht viel gefehlt wohl.
Was, woher nimmst du jetzt diese Information?
Nokia ist tatsächlich der erste gewiesene. Also es steht im Blog geschrieben, dass du die Wette verloren hast. Von daher wird es bestimmen. Echt?
Und hast du die Kisten-Mate schon bekommen?
Nee.
Nee?
Also ich hab sie wahrscheinlich im Laufe der Zeit abgesoffen, genauso wie alle anderen, aber...
Niemals.
Wir haben mehrere Kisten-Mate hier durchgebracht. Ich fahre hier regelmäßig zum Getränkemarkt.
Warum fährt der Getränkemarkt denn nicht zu dir?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Leisten die noch nicht? Da gibt es schon Dienstleister.
Die am Mate vorbeifahren? Ich fahre gern zu meinem Getränkemarkt. Ich mag meinen Getränkemarkt. Da kann ich immer Browsing machen.
Was es noch für Getränke gibt?
Was man sonst noch mal kaufen könnte.
Kannst du online machen?
Scheiß Internet.
Ich fahre da hin, hole den Scheiß fertig. Fertig. Lieferender muss man immer rechtzeitig da sein. Das passt mir immer nicht. Wir haben schon so andere Liefersachen. Das ist immer total der Terror, da auch zu Hause zu sein. Das ist noch viel anstrengender.
Lasst sie ja noch in die Packstation schicken.
Können sie in ihrer Postfiliale abholen. Na super. Gut, dann habe ich noch was anderes. Und zwar habe ich hier noch ein bisschen weiter mit meiner Fritzbox vor mich hin experimentiert.
Also ich habe ja gestern die neuesten Neuigkeiten gehört über Fritzboxen. Und zwar, dass wenn man sein Kabel rauszieht von der Fritzbox, dass man dann weiter telefonieren kann.
Wie spät ist es? Jungs, wir müssen in 40 Minuten fertig sein, dann startet die Ariane 5.
Die geht ab, habe ich gehört.
Was war denn der Kontext nochmal von diesem Scherz?
Hab ich ja überhaupt nicht verstanden.
Ja, kam gestern einer im Club und meinte, er zieht seinen Kabel raus und kann trotzdem telefonieren.
Das war so ein Paranoider, der sind hinter mir her und so. Und ich habe das Kabel aus der Fritzbox gezogen. Und es ging aber immer noch.
Oh, ich hörte davon.
Das ist aber so ein guter Witz, den man so vor 500 Leuten mal bringen kann. So ein totaler Insider.
Weil man jetzt auch zuhört, man nimmt es nicht so schwer, Junge. Wie hieß der Bixxer-Film?
Jetzt wird er aber richtig paranoid, wenn wieder eine Podcast über ihn erzählt.
Es wird besser.
Ja, aber aus einem anderen Zusammenhang, ne?
Ist egal.
Ja, mit meiner Fritzbox, ich weiß nicht, was ich von dem Ding halten soll.
Hast du immer noch nicht Schluss gemacht?
Nee.
Ist immer noch so ein langer...
Ich hatte aber noch nicht so richtig viel Zeit, die Fähigkeiten hier voll auszutesten, weil ich mich noch nicht habe entscheiden können für irgendwelche Decktelefone. Ich hab einfach derzeit hier noch zu viele offene Baustellen. Aber ich hab so Probleme mit weggrollerndem WLAN. Also, das WLAN diffundiert auf einmal so. Das Ding hing auch mal, musste mal wieder rebooted werden. Alles nicht so geil irgendwie. Na ja, wie auch immer. Dann hab ich noch mal so ein bisschen rumgeguckt, aus anderen Gründen und bin dann noch mal so einer anderen Sache auf die Spur gekommen. Eines der Features, die ja diese Fritzbox hat, ist ja, dass man da so gleich so ein dünn DNS-Klein drin hat. Das heißt, wenn du so über dünn DNS oder andere Dienste dir so ein IP, Quatsch, so ein Domänen-Namen bedienen lassen willst, wo dann deine aktuelle IP-Adresse, die dir der Provider zugewiesen hat, beim letzten PPP einwählen, wenn du die quasi dann von außen immer ansprechen willst über einen festen Namen, jetzt habe ich es langsam, dann ist eben der notwendige Client in der Fritzbox schon integriert und das ist ja an sich ganz toll. Nur, dass es natürlich immer so eine Sache ist mit so anbieterspezifischen Clients, will man ja eigentlich nicht, man will das ja eigentlich mal standardisiert haben. Da dachte ich mir so, gibt es da eigentlich keinen Standard? Da habe ich mal so ein bisschen gegraben und festgestellt, dass es den sehr wohl gibt. Und zwar, wer nämlich denselben Effekt auch mit seiner Time Capsule oder seiner AirPod Express haben will, die ja keinen dünnen DNS Client eingebaut hat, aber wohl die Fähigkeit besitzt, White Area Bonjour zu machen. Das ist so dieses, was immer so auftaucht, wo man nicht weiß, was man eintragen soll. Und dann habe ich mal so ein bisschen vor mich hingeguggelt und festgestellt, dass die Standards, auf denen das Ganze basiert, welche sind. Also White Area Bonjour ist jetzt nicht wieder ein Apple Server oder so. Das handelt sich hierbei einfach um DNS-Standards. Ganz konkret um DNS-Update, also die Möglichkeit, ein Rekord zu aktualisieren von außen, indem man da so Login-Credentials hat. Und jetzt habe ich schon wieder vergessen, was es heißt. DNS-SD.
Manu, ey.
Man sich nicht alles aufschreibt. Wofür steht noch mal das SD? Das steht für Service Discovery. Also quasi was wir als Bonjour kennen. Also dass du darüber eben auch Dienste ablegen kannst.
Verstehe. Und am 17. März 2010 ging das DünnDNS Wide Area Bonjour Support Beta los.
Genau. Und DünnDNS selbst unterstützt das nämlich auch. Das heißt, wenn der Haken ist, das geht nicht mit diesen Standard- kostenlos angeboten, sondern du musst dir da für 30 Dollar im Jahr so eine Custom DNS Kunden-Account klicken. Gut, kann man sagen, eigene Domäne, du kannst dann deine eigene Domänen da von denen verwalten lassen, kannst darüber deine Records machen und kannst auch automatisch aktualisieren. Also du hast quasi einen DNS-Server, den sie für dich fahren, der eben auch diese ganzen Update-Prozeduren hat und dann kannst du eben auch Wide Area Bonjour damit machen. Das Vorteil hat, dass du eben nicht nur A-Records dort machen kannst, sondern im Prinzip auch alle so ganzen Service-Records, also auch so mein Webserver steht hier, mein... ist gerade oben. Das heißt, wenn irgendwie in deiner lokalen Zone irgendwelche Dienste verfügbar werden, dann können die eben auch unter deiner Domänen im Internet eingetragen werden. Na ja, habe ich jetzt selber nicht ausprobiert, also ich habe mir jetzt deswegen nicht ein Custom DNS geklickt, aber ich habe zumindest mal zur Kenntnis genommen, dass das jetzt auch nicht etwas ist, was es nicht gibt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ganz cool eigentlich.
Finde ich auch.
Aber sag mal, hier so auf der WLAN-Front, so an Geräten von Apple ist auch schon lange nichts mehr erschienen, oder? Also weder Time Capsule noch AirPod Extreme und Express, da ist schon ziemlich lange Funkstille.
Ja, gefühlt ist das richtig, ja.
Zwei Jahre, oder wann?
Gute Frage.
Zuhause funktioniert es bei mir.
Langsam dürften sie an der Kaputt sein, oder?
Ich hab nur eine Express, deswegen...
AirPod Express musst du irgendwie alle zwei Wochen rausstöpseln.
Ich bin beide nicht, aber noch nie eigentlich.
Immer. Also bei mir in der Wohnung, ich hab da mehrere Stecken. Ich muss jede irgendwie mal... Also wenn da irgendwie viel Traffic drauf ist... Keine Ahnung wovon es wirklich abhängt, aber stabil ist anders. Also stabil ist so, dass ich mich nicht erinnern könnte, die jemals rebooted zu haben. Das ist stabil. Aber die sind permanent nicht sichtbar, und dann muss ich sie wieder rebooten, dann hab ich mal irgendwie diejenigen, die benutzt die sozusagen auch, um noch so ein B-Netz zu posten, und da boot man sich dann ein, und dann kriegt man auch kein Internet. Also die sind irgendwie auf merkwürdige Arten und Weisen, die freezen die irgendwie und sind nicht so richtig geil. Aber das stimmt, mit dem Rautern hat sich irgendwie wenig getan.
Bei den Extrem, die funktionieren mittlerweile ganz okay. Also die Extrem, die ich zu Hause hab, die muckt auch nie. Und in der Uni hab ich ja auch mal die alten Airpod-Eier durch Extrems ersetzt. Und die laufen auch vergleichsweise gut dafür, dass sie eigentlich nicht für so einen Betrieb fahren, mit mehreren hundert Studenten und so ausgelegt sind.
Ja, aber ich finde, sie können jetzt auch mal in die Telefonie einsteigen und irgendwie SIP-Services da einbauen. Ich weiß ja nicht, was sie vorhaben. Vielleicht wollen sie ja die Dinge auf iOS umstellen.
Tja.
So Economy of Scale und so. Aber derzeit verwenden sie wohl immer noch nicht BSD. Ich weiß nicht, was sie da vorhaben.
Vielleicht investieren sie ja WebOS drauf.
Oh ja, bestimmt.
Windows Airport 7.
Auf jeden Fall Stromspart.
Ein Vögelchen hat mir übrigens gesagt, dass es nicht mehr lange dauert, bis Micro S10 Line kommt.
Was heißt nicht mehr lange?
So wie angekündigt.
Und dieses Vögelchen hieß Steve Jobs.
Nö, aber so, dass es auch schon hätte sein können, dass es schon eine Beta gibt.
Nee.
Aber es hätte schon eine geben können. Wenn es dann nicht im letzten Moment...
Wenn wir dann doch an der Universum leben würden.
Aha, es hätte schon eine geben sollen, aber es wurde dann gecancelt, meinst du.
Und warum?
Weiß ich nicht.
Der Vögelchen, was dir da Sachen zwitschert, ist immer sehr zaghaft mit dem Zwitscher.
So ist das mit diesen Vögelchen.
Muss man erstmal groß füttern, bis sie dann auch mehr Sätze und Worte an einem Stück sagen.
Oder ein bisschen wirken.
Die Vögelchen halten sich sehr zurück.
Und der Grober hat keine Vögelchen am Start. Der muss doch Schwärme haben.
Naja, total abwegig ist es ja nicht, weil, wie ihr vermutlich alle mitbekommen habt, gab es mal ein Release-Candidate von Xcode4, der kurzzeitig auf der Webseite, auf der entsprechenden Developer-Webseite drauf war.
Davon weiß ich auch nichts.
Und wo in den Systemvoraussetzungen drin stand, braucht Mac OS 10.7 Lion. Und dann war der ganz schnell wieder draußen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob er mittlerweile wieder da ist. Ah ja, Golden Master Seed gibt es auf jeden Fall. Ja, ja, der kam dann. Dann kam der Golden Master Seed.
Also, ich kenne ja wen, der benutzt das gerade und der meint, das würde ja ganz schön oft abstürzen noch.
Und das ist wohl auch extrem langsam nach wie vor. Also jemand, der noch 4 GB nur hat, ja, und nur eine normale Festplatte. Solche Leute soll es ja auch noch geben. Der meinte dauernd Spinning Beachball of Death und Crashers und geht gar nicht. Also kann man überhaupt nicht mitarbeiten, meint er. Und das für den Golden Master.
Ist das hier, dass der John Gruber hier I love Amy Jane in seinem Logo hat? Ist das neu?
Das ist ja wie gesagt ein paar Tagen.
Wer ist denn Amy Jane?
Naja, also wahrscheinlich seine Hippe.
Oder im Baseball Team, man weiß ja nicht.
Aber ich meine, Milliardenfach angeschaut. Ich meine, weißt du, früher haben die Leute noch mit Kreide auf den Boden geschrieben, so. War mal bei einer Firma, wo ich gearbeitet hab, kam ich hin, war auf dem Boden. Also auf der Haustür, wo die Frau dann wohl rauskam morgens, war guten Morgen. Anne oder wie auch immer die hieß. Und dann aber 50 Meter weiter, noch mal irgendwelche anderen wünschen. Das ging bis zur U-Bahn. Also der ganze Weg bis zur U-Bahn war voll gepinselt mit Nachrichten. Und das war schon ganz gut, aber heutzutage macht man einfach bei John Gruber halt I love Amy Jane, so, Milliardenfach runtergeladen. Der Impact ist natürlich dann viel größer. Also heiraten kommt da jetzt nicht mehr drum rum.
Der ist schon verheiratet, der hat Kinder.
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, dann heißt sie Amy Jane Gruber.
Vielleicht hat er ja irgendwas angestellt und versucht...
Vielleicht war einfach hier... Qualentinstag, Menschenskinder.
Stimmt ja. Ja, weil man das einfach mal skippt.
Er ist ein super Analytiker, finde ich.
Robert hat ja gesagt hier, mein Arbeitskollege, dass Mark... wie heißt er? Robert. Der hat mir nur gesagt, dass jemand anders gesagt hat, dass Mark Armend oder so der neue John Gruber ist.
Marco Armend ist der neue John Gruber.
Also Wörther.
Wie heißt der? Marco Armend.
Ja, der hat halt erst... Der hat halt erst Tumblr gemacht, dann ist er bei Tumblr ja raus, bevor es richtig scheiße wurde wohl. Dann hat er Instapaper mal eben gemacht und das war ja gleich auch wieder so ein Knaller Erfolg und der macht ja auch einen Podcast. Bild & Analyze heißt der, glaube ich. Ja, mit noch irgendeinem Typen. Von Xcode wahrscheinlich, oder? Bild & Analyze Podcast. Und der hat ja auch einen Blog und so und auch einen Twitter und der wird jetzt ja auch immer mehr referenziert, deswegen eben einer meiner Kollegen meinte, das wird hier der neue Gruber. Ein bisschen weniger.
Ich finde, der Gruber haut immer ein bisschen sehr doll obendrauf, wenn er...
Ich sag der Gruber, der hat ja oft recht so. Also ist ja nicht so, dass er...
Erstaunlicherweise.
Ja, das ist die ganze Dan Benjamin Podcast-Klicke. Der macht halt mit Gruber und Valkusa und all den coolen Leuten macht er irgendwie.
Der John Zyralkusa von Ars Technica? Okay, aber zurück zu dem Vögelchen.
Ist auch extrem zu empfehlen. Das ist auch wirklich eine wunderbare Alternative zu dem ganzen Leo Laporte-Universum. Der Benjamin ist wirklich ein extrem angenehmer Moderator. Super, also der macht das ganz toll.
Ach, das ist auch so einer wie du. Der macht ganz viele Podcasts.
Genau, der hat auch ganz viele Podcasts. Und Bild und Analyze ist da nur einer davon. Talkshow ist halt der mit Gruber, Back to Work ist der mit dem...
Na, da gibt es auch einen Rubi-Podcast.
Ja, der macht tierisch viel. Das ist wirklich auch unfassbar. Merlin Mann ist Back to Work. Und ich bin selber gerade ganz überrascht.
Gott, ist das viel. Meine Fresse.
Boah, der hat ja da echt die Stars am Start.
Jaja, der hat die Stars am Start. Ich frage mich vor allem, wie er das macht, weil der sitzt selber irgendwie in Florida und die klingen immer alle sehr gut. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Double Ender Aufnahmen macht oder ob die da einfach so gute Skype-Verbindungen haben. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Skype nehmen. Aber ich weiß es gar nicht. Warte mal noch so ein bisschen auf die Auflösung. Ja.
Aber jetzt nochmal zurück zum Vögelchen. Wir waren ja bei deinem Switchervogel und ihr habt irgendwas erzählt von Xcode 4 und schon Golden Master und zurückgezogen.
Das würde ja heißen, dass das Lying schon fertig ist. Nein, das ist eben nicht fertig.
Das Lying meine ich.
Zumindest wissen sie genau, welche Features sie ausliefern wollen. Das kann man glaube ich schon mal sagen.
Das Xcode 4, wenn es das Lying benötigt und ich meine, man soll ja drauf umsteigen. Die releasing ja keinen GM von Xcode 4 für einen Beta-Lying, sondern vielleicht für das Finale. Warum sollen sie den schon vorher fertig machen, den Xcode? Könnte man natürlich.
Also was ich gehört habe ist, wir werden Beta-Versionen sehen und das ist ja auch kein Wunder. Und dieses Xcode wird dann vielleicht diese Beta voraussetzen. Also macht Sinn. Das ist jetzt keine wirkliche News. Das kann man sich auch selber zusammenreimen. Aber die Einschläge kommen näher. Das ist eigentlich die Information, die ich habe.
Also es ist...
und ich bin... Ich bin... ich halte es nicht mehr aus.
Willst du was Neues?
Ich halte es echt nicht mehr aus. Ich platze.
Aber ehrlich, das ganze iPhone-Gelaber der letzten Monate...
Ich habe auch noch ein paar andere Sachen gesagt, die ich nicht sagen kann. Und ich... es muss kommen jetzt langsam.
Also mir geht das jetzt nur noch über iPhones labern auch ganz schön auf dem Keks.
Ich brauche auch wieder richtig Macintosh und richtig OS und Engineering und ordentliche Features und Fallsysteme und...
geht gar nichts.
Du fällst vom Ast.
Ja.
Ja, dann drück doch mal kurz die Rolls-Ball-Taste und sag uns doch noch mal kurz auf die... Chat es uns zu.
Ich hab euch schon gesagt, was ich sagen kann.
Da kann ich nicht sagen.
Na dann Pantomime es halt.
Nee.
Pant ist uns. Genau. Tanzt die Rumors.
Es geht hier um Menschenleben.
Aber ich hab einen Backen.
Ja, wir bringen dich um, wenn du es nicht bald erzählst.
Ich hab einen Backen gefeilt. Kann man ja machen, wenn man einen Developer Account hat. Also wenn man so eine Apple ID hat, die als Developer registriert ist, das kann ja jeder machen, ohne Geld dafür bezahlen zu müssen. Dann kann man bei bugreport.apple.com so einen richtigen Backen feilen, noch mit so einem richtig geilen Oldschool Interface. Und da wollen sie ja so ein bestimmtes Format zu haben. Und das geht dann eben dann so wirklich richtig rein in den Backprozess von Apple. Und ich habe mir mal Mühe gemacht hier, was ich ja schon mal beklagt habe, dieses Audio-Umschaltproblem von meinem iMac zu machen. Ich habe noch ein paar andere Leute gefragt, die halt auch ein 27 Zoll iMac haben. Und ich habe bisher noch niemanden angetroffen, der das Problem nicht nachvollziehen konnte. Also das ist wirklich so richtig 100% immer das Problem. Und um so etwas Unterstützung zu geben, also diese Backreports sind ja nicht öffentlich. Also man stellt die ein und sieht die aber dann nur unter seinem Eingriff. Genau. Und damit man eben solche Ups ein bisschen popularisieren kann, gibt es ja dieses Open Radar Projekt, openradar.upspot.com, wo man Kommentare hinzufügen kann und so weiter. Das ist allerdings quasi nur für die Öffentlichkeit. Das wird von Apple nicht gelesen. Zumindest offiziell nicht gelesen, keine Ahnung.
Also da kann man auch, die ID gibt es pro ID, also Radar ID gibt es ein Forum, aber der eigentliche Bug Report ist bei denen dann nicht, oder wie?
Genau, aber da kann man schon mal sehen, was andere Leute auch gefeilt haben, sodass man sich dann vielleicht bestellt sieht, einfach denselben Bug auch selbst nochmal auch zu feilen, wenn man den auch hat. Und das wäre sozusagen meine Bitte. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob das jeden stört, aber wer so einen 27 Zoll iMac hat und noch einen zweiten Mac und eben auch dieses Problem nachvollziehen kann, was nochmal kurz zusammengefasst jenes ist, wenn man halt ein Mini Display Kabel reinsteckt in den iMac und in den anderen Rechner und dann der iMac umschaltet und sich quasi zu Bildschirm und Lautsprecher macht für diesen externen Mac. Das Lautsprecherteil ist sozusagen der entscheidende Punkt. Dann wird eben dieser Audiostein von dem iMac irgendwie so umprogrammiert, dass eine Recording Session auf dem AudioInn hops geht. Also irgendwas machen sie mit dem Audiostein, dass wenn man da gerade drauf aufnimmt, Zweck ist. Wir hatten das mal hier, ich wollte das hier mal zeigen, wie toll das geht. Und dann lief hier gerade der Stream. Und der Stream läuft halt hier von diesem iMac und holt sich das Audio von dem Build-in Audio. In dem Fall digital, aber es ist egal, ob es digital oder analog ist. Es ist in beiden Fällen Hops. Und dann bleibt der einfach stumm. Also dann kommt da einfach kein Audio mehr an. Manchmal gibt es Fehlermeldungen. Bei manchen Leuten gibt es Fehlermeldungen. Und bei manchen ist es einfach nur stumm. Wie auch immer. Es ist wirklich furchtbar. Ja, der Chat meint, dass man wahrscheinlich der Einzige davon betroffen ist. Klar, das ist jetzt nicht so das, was man jeden Tag macht. Erstmal werden wahrscheinlich die wenigsten, den 27 Zoll iMac wirklich als zweiten Bildschirm benutzen. Und viele Leute werden nicht das Problem haben, dass sie währenddessen irgendwie Audio eben betreiben. Aber das erinnert ja nichts an der Tatsache, dass das ein Fehler ist. Das sind Show-Notes. Sehr viel mehr hab ich jetzt nicht zu berichten, Leute.
Mal hier nochmal gucken, was ich hier nochmal so habe.
Gucken wir nochmal rein in die große Kiste. Achso, du hast ja deine Themenliste übrigens. Wollen wir das nicht mal in so ein Etherpad tun auch?
Aber das ist doch kein Outliner, da kann man doch nicht mit tinkern.
Nein, Outliner hab ich jetzt auch nicht, aber ich stehe total auf eine tiefe Ups. Ich benutze halt derzeit Simplenode und theoretisch kann man mit Simplenode auch irgendwie zwischen Usern scheren, aber ich hab nicht verstanden, wie es geht. Irgendwie muss man einen Tag wählen, der der Name ist von jemandem und dann...
Wie auch immer, ich prangere dieses Themenlistenmonopol an.
Das stimmt.
Ich prangere das auch an, wenn ich es irgendwie, wenn du mir irgendwas Praktikables, was über das Editieren von Webseiten hinausgeht, bieten kannst, dann...
Ja, warte, Moment, ich paste dir gleich was in den Chat.
Also ich folg mich nochmal bei...
Gleichstift und Zettel und dann so rumreichen.
Ach, wir können ja immer mal über den Sparkle Share reden, ne?
Das können wir auch noch tun, ja.
Ich hab das nämlich mal ausprobiert. Ja, das wüsstest du gern, ne?
Guck mal, Tim, geh mal hier.
Hatte der Huckel jetzt auch schon irgendwas getwittert? Ich wusste ja auch nicht, was das sein soll.
Da hat Huckel vor... Ui, wir haben ein Zeitalter erzählt, dass sowas ist so quasi so ein kleines Dropbox zum selberbauen auf Git-Basis. Also gibst einfach dein Git Repository an und dann hast du sowas wie so eine Dropbox. Alles, was du reinpackst, wird automatisch in dein Git committed.
Es hat diesen Dropbox-Appeal, aber es leistet halt schon andere Sachen. Du hast halt einen Ordner auf deinem Rechner und du kannst da Sachen reinschieben und der schiebt diese Sachen dann auf irgendeinen Server. Entweder deinen eigenen, auf GitHub, auf Gitorius oder irgendwo, wo es einen Git Repository gehostet gibt. Und du kannst jetzt halt mit vielen Clients, ähnlich wie bei Dropbox, auch auf dieses gleiche Repository gucken. Das heißt, wenn du auf deinem Notebook jetzt was in diesen Folder tust, dann ist das jetzt auf deinem anderen Rechner, wo du auch dieses Repository mit Sparkle Share beobachtest, auch drin. Deswegen, es hat so ein bisschen die Funktionalität von Dropbox. Nur, dass es eben auf einem Git Repository beruht. Du dieses Git Repository auch so klonen kannst, branchen kannst, die Versionshistorie hast und alles damit tun kannst, was du mit Git halt auch ansonsten tun kannst. Und ja, eben den Vorteil noch zusätzlich bietet, dass du es eben auch selber hosten kannst. Und das ist halt auch insofern auch noch ganz nett, weil zum Beispiel, du kannst halt Webseiten damit auch deployen. Du hast halt irgendwie deine Homepage lokal in irgendeinem Verzeichnis, was eben mit Sparkle Share beobachtet wird. Und in dem Moment, wo du da ein neues HTML reinschiebst, schiebt du das gleich auf den Server, checkt das da aus und ping. Könntest du jetzt sozusagen auch irgendwelche Dokumente auf deinem Web-Server einfach hier so in Sync mit deiner lokalen Platte halten und so weiter? Das ist jetzt nicht...
Das ist nur für kleine Daten.
Na ja, Git funktioniert schon auch mit größeren Daten, aber es ist halt nicht so... Also der Vorteil von Git ist ja auch, dass sie ganz viel komprimieren und so weiter. Und bei Large Binary Blobs performt es noch nicht so gut. Da arbeiten sie zwar dran, aber es ist jetzt nichts um irgendwie voll HD-Movies.
Na gut, Dropbox ja auch nicht. Mit Dropbox könnte man schon irgendwie mal so ein paar Apps oder dicke Daten oder ein paar Bilder da rüber schieben.
Ja, im Prinzip kannst du das damit aber auch machen. Also es ist nicht so, dass es nicht funktioniert. Und es ist auch nicht so, dass es jetzt so extrem doll langsam würde, gleich sofort, aber...
Sparkle Share ist so die App, oder ist das schon der Service auf der anderen Seite?
Sparkle Share ist tatsächlich nur die App, die dann ähnlich wie bei Dropbox sich da oben in dein Menü auch noch ablegt.
Also wo dein Git Repo ist, ist denen egal, stellt es halt ein. Kann also auch über eine sichere Quelle sein, mit einer sicheren Verbindung.
Also ich hab's auf meinem Server via SSH.
Und wo ist da der Share-Anteil? Das heißt, wenn du das so machst, könnte ich auch einen Key haben, wo ich dann auch den gleichen Zeug zugreife, auch mit Sparkle Share. Und dann könnten wir uns ein paar Daten teilen.
Genau, haben wir so einen Sync-Folder, wo wir beide Sachen reinschieben können. Und der andere kriegt die dann halt auch.
Ich meine, wenn man diese Repositories sich dann auf GitHub macht, dann sind die irgendwie alle public.
Na ja, wenn man einen gratis GitHub-Account hat, schon, ja. Es gibt ja auch bezahlt Private Accounts. Also es gibt Private Accounts, aber bezahlt. Aber ich find ja GitHub-Accounts noch zu teuer.
Was empfiehst du dann?
Na, ich hab's halt auf, na ja, meinem Server halt, ne? Also hat natürlich nicht jeder einen Server, aber mittlerweile sind ja so V-Hosts mit SSH-Schilds auch nicht so wahnsinnig teuer.
Aber was nutzt du denn so, um hier so Commits dir anzugucken und diesen Webview dafür zu haben? Oder einfach wirklich nur Git und pure Git und sonst nichts als Git?
Na, Webviews benutze ich, wenn, dann Git-Torius. Das ist halt, also es gibt halt GitHub und es gibt ja Git-Torius, was du sagen, so ein Open Source und Gratis-Clone, in Anführungsstrichen, von GitHub ist. Da sind auch viele Projekte FFmpeg, Qt und so, ist schon eine ganze Menge großer Projektkram auch. Und die haben ihre Software auch released. Das heißt, man kann auf Git-Torius, das Git-Torius-Projekt klonen und sich selber auch auf dem Server installieren. Dann hat man sozusagen für die Firma oder für sich selbst halt so ein komplettes Web-Repository-Management mit History und weiß der Geier was. Das benutze ich zum einen so als Web-Viewer und ansonsten habe ich halt tatsächlich so nur noch ein GUI-Client auf meinem Mac, um so History zu browse und zu suchen und so weiter. Also ansonsten, command line.
Welchen GUI-Client hast du?
Nee, ich finde das auch krass. Der kostet jetzt 49.
Ja, ein bisschen teuer, oder?
Ja, wie gesagt, das hatte ich ja schon mal angesprochen, diese Git-GUI-Client, die geben mir irgendwie alles nichts. Ich brauche eigentlich nur was zum History-Browse, History-Suchen, auf dem Index-Add-Committen und vielleicht noch pushen, aber dieses Git-Tower, das ist schon wieder so viel mehr und so viel GUI-Tralara, so viel GUI-Fushing für, also nicht, das ist mir zu viel. Und die anderen kleinen hab ich auch noch nicht gehört. Ich benutze halt GitX, allerdings ist die Version, die man so im Web runterladen kann, ewig nicht mehr maintained worden, aber es gibt da einen Fork auf GitHub, der immer mal wieder Liebe erfährt und eigentlich genau das tut, was ich brauche. Ich könnte dich dann auch mal hier dir gleich den Link noch zu posten für die Shownotes, wo man diesen Fork findet.
Jetzt postest du es nicht, aber jetzt tust du das in dieses Etherpad rein, das du mir jetzt gerade Aufmerksamkeit hast.
Ja, das meine ich ja. Ich suche ja erstmal das Repo-Kurs.
Ich kann so lange mal hier von dem, bist du annehmend oder wer bist du jetzt?
Warte doch mal, ich hab doch gerade erzählt. Ich habe mal so ein Alternatives Experimentelles Gitterprojekt angelegt und zwar mach ich jetzt gemeinsam mit noch einem anderen Podcast, die Märchenstunde, mit Björn Grau. Und dann erwähne ich auch nochmal, wir müssen reden. Am Freitag live.
Das Hauptfeature im iTunes Podcast Direktory reicht dir wohl nicht?
Ne, das reicht mir nicht. Ich will hier noch zusätzlich beim Obernext mich erwähnt werden. Und da lesen wir immer Märchen vor und haben festgestellt, dass die Unterschiede zwischen den einzelnen grimpischen Ausgaben der grimpischen Hausmärchen doch sehr, sehr groß sind. Und da gibt es ja keinen so, ich wollte mal einen Diff machen, einfach so zwischen den einzelnen Versionen der entsprechenden grimpischen Märchen. Und hab dafür ein Skript geschrieben, was mir ein Git Repository anlegt, was für jede Auflage der grimpischen Hausmärchen eine neue Datei anlegt. Und dann dachte ich so, könnte man per GitHub hier gucken, was sich so geändert hat zwischen den einzelnen Auflagen. Und das Dove ist aber, dass GitHub mit so großen Comments, also mit so großen Diffs nicht klarkommt. Wobei ich auf der einen Seite müsste man dafür nochmal dringend die, toll, Tim wird jetzt so langweilig, achso, er guckt jetzt ein bisschen Arianestaat nebenbei. Echt, du auch?
Dass sie nicht aus dem Konzept bringen, Max. Ja, es hat Probleme mit großen Diffs.
Hat Probleme mit großen Diffs. Ich halte die Idee ansonsten ganz toll, dass man die Unterschiede zwischen einzelnen Versionen einfach mal per Diff sich anguckt.
Da sind dann wahrscheinlich die GUI-Klines halt wieder besser geeignet, weil also ein, zwei davon, die sind ja auch mit Grand Central Dispatch schon befeuert und so, und da flutscht das dann schon alles ein bisschen.
Die Unterschiede sind auch darum so groß, weil da noch relativ viele HTML-Text drin sind aus der Wikipedia-Version, die sich dann doch unterscheiden und die, nach meinem Wissenstand, nicht in der Original-Ausgabe drin waren, diese HTML-Text. Also daran muss ich nochmal ein bisschen arbeiten. Da ich mich irgendwann mal so zwei, drei Stündchen ran gesetzt, vielleicht hat ja jemand Lust, da ein bisschen weiterzumachen. In meinem GitHub-Projekt gibt es auch das Skript dafür zum Runterladen, was einem Automat bestübe.
Aber das hatte ich ja auch schon mal, so ein Fall, da hat jemand Pi-Wiki, wie heißt es? Dieses andere Wiki, was auf Files basiert, es war irgendwas mit P auch.
Achso, dieses Git, dieses Git-Wiki.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, davor Git, vor Git, wie heißt denn das?
Pi-Wiki?
Das ist Pi-Wiki.
Pi-Wiki.
Pi-Wiki. Ja, das basiert ja auf Files, da haben sich da irgendwelche Leute mal so ein Pi-Wiki zerschossen und irgendwie was kaputt überschrieben und keine Ahnung, dann hatte ich aber noch ein Backup und dann habe ich irgendwie auch einfach 8 Gigabyte Text files in das Git reingepumpt, dann die 8 Gigabyte von dem jetzigen Stand in einen anderen Branch und die dann gedifft, damit die sehen können, was sich wo überhaupt geändert hat und dann auch gleich mit Git gemerged und dann haben die ja ihren 8 Gigabyte Pi-Wiki File-Dump irgendwie mit Git wieder zusammengemerged, weil gab halt zwei unterschiedliche Teams und die dachten, sie arbeiten an einer Version, aber sie haben auf Wir haben auf zwei unterschiedlichen Datenständen gearbeitet. Wir mussten das dann wieder zusammenkriegen. Und sie haben es tatsächlich geschafft auch. Also da hat sich irgendeine studentische Hilfskraft wahrscheinlich die Finger rund geklingelt.
Wurde damit ein Sommer lang ein Leben gehalten.
So lange hat es nicht gedauert, glaube ich. Ey, Peeweekee sieht ja jetzt ganz hässlich aus.
Vielleicht haben sie auf verschiedenen Versionen gearbeitet, um zu bemerken.
Ja, nee, das benutzt wahrscheinlich einfach keiner mehr.
Und, was ist denn mit der Rakete?
Die steht da rum und es sind...
Achso, da ist der Countdown.
Da ist der Countdown. Wir sind bei 10 Minuten 30.
Mach doch mal dahin und dreh mal den Show ein bisschen.
Nee, das gefährdet die Aufhörer, aber dann knistert der Stream und dann sind uns die Hörer gleich wieder böse.
Na, auf dem Mac läuft das bestimmt wieder nur im Flash.
Das ist ja noch 10 Minuten.
Ja, jetzt guckt man da nicht so gebannt hin hier. Wir haben hier noch so eine Sendung, ne? Wie heißt die eigentlich?
Wo läuft denn der Ariane-Screen?
Ihr habt das Problem, dass ich jetzt die Show notes da reingetan habe. Jetzt müsst ihr auch mit am Content arbeiten.
Ja, ich hab doch reingepastet hier.
Nicht nur reinpasten, sondern auch lesen und aufgreifen und mögliche Themen nachtragen.
Wir würden das ja mal alles ein bisschen machen mit dem Aufräumen. Ich wollte jetzt mal sagen, ich hab mir ja während der Sendung am Anfang dieses Hands Off mal installiert. Aber ich dachte so ein bisschen Security. Ich bin ja auch so ein Fan von irgendwie mal ein bisschen beobachten, was da so geht und so. Ist ja auch ein cooles Analysetool, was Programme so machen und wo die hinconnecten und so. Und irgendwie seitdem ist mein Adium zum Beispiel schnarchlangsam geworden. Also da kommt ganz oft jetzt die Spinning-Pizza und wenn du Huckel mir was sendest, kommt hier Spinning oder ich brauch nur schon umschalten und das passiert ewig gar nichts.
Habt ihr mal in den Activity-Monitor geguckt?
Nö, da ist auch nichts los. Also ich glaube, es liegt am Hands-Off, das hatte ich vorher noch nie.
Dann machst du mal aus und probier es nochmal.
Das kann man so einfach abstellen?
Ja, da oben kannst du da bei dieser Hand auf Quit gehen.
Disable Rules gar nicht machen.
Ja, oder dann musst du im Activity-Monitor gehen. Ja, das ist die Sache so, wenn man eine SSD hat, dann fallen so eine Sachen alle gar nicht mehr auf.
Das hat jetzt nichts mit der Platte zu tun.
Weißte dich. Quatsch.
Das zählt immer nicht. Der hat irgendwas verkackt, der Typ.
So Leute, wir haben kein Thema mehr, ne?
Wir haben keine Themen mehr?
Ich hab nur noch so Notthemen.
Was denn so? Wo sind denn die Notthemen?
Steht da alles.
Da unten? Mögliche Themen?
Ja, das sind aber jetzt nur noch Notthemen. Das sind Themen, die müssen man nicht unbedingt machen, es sei denn sie kommen vielleicht. Du kannst sagen, wow, darüber möchte ich aber jetzt unbedingt reden, weil das ist ja mal total spannend. Dann können wir das gerne machen. Aber das ist für mich eher so...
Dennis und wir können ja unsere Podcasts jetzt nochmal featuren zum Schluss.
Ach, ihr habt auch noch einen?
Nein, wir haben natürlich keine Podcasts. Mobile Max ist unser Leben. Deswegen haben wir auch so viele Themen. Also für die 60. Folge, wir müssen es ja auch nicht immer so lang übertreiben.
Nein, man kann auch mal eine kompakte, knackige, hochdynamische Sendung machen, die nur 180 Minuten dauert.
Ihr wollt da schon aufhören, oder was?
Ja.
In acht Minuten startet die Ariane.
Ja und?
Na, bis dahin können wir ja auch...
Das ist jetzt nicht so spannend. Die hebt dann ab und dann?
Vielleicht explodiert sie auch.
Das ist aber jetzt hier...
Na dann ist sie völlig losgelöst von der Erde.
Dann hebt sie ab.
Völlig schwerelos.
Don't mess with Major Tom.
Bitte hört auf zu singen.
Ich habe halt jetzt eine Affinität zur Raumfahrt bekommen. Ich kann ja auch noch mal meinen Podcast placken.
Guck mal hier, hast du gesehen, die haben da auch ganz dicke LED-Displays.
Was ist das denn überhaupt, was du so mitguckst?
Das ist der Ariane 5 ES Start in Kuru. Ja, womit guckst du den? Mit der Ariane Space Up.
Es gibt eine Ariane Space Up?
Ja, gibt es. Für iPhone.
Dennis, wir brauchen auch einen Podcast, damit wir gefeatured werden und selber featuren. Dennis hat ja nicht mal einen Blog.
Und da wird halt jetzt die ATV 2 Johannes Kepler.
Hast du noch deine Dennis X Seite?
In den Orbit geworfen auf das Andocker an die ISS. Das ist sozusagen die Versorgungskapsel für die ISS.
Damit die wieder scheißen.
Ja, aber das andere auch. Die nehmen ja wieder was mit.
Ja, die tun auch was rein und dann wird das verbrannt.
Weil die verglüht ja beim Wiedereintritt. Die wollen aber irgendwann mal auch ein ATV bauen, was dann nicht verglüht, richtig?
Dann dampft die Kacke.
Ja, die würden auch gerne mal wieder was zurückbringen. Das ist sozusagen ein Vorschlag, dass sie der ATV so ein bisschen umbauen, da so eine Kapsel machen, wo sie dann auch Leute mit hinbringen können.
Wieder zurückkriegen vor allem, aber das geht nämlich ja bisher noch nicht.
Und wie lange halten sie durch, falls das jetzt schief geht mit der Ariane?
Wie lange wird der ISS durchhalten, meinst du?
Ja, ja, wie lange?
Also die haben es immer scheiß, bis zum Hals steht es nicht.
Die können die immer noch irgendwie in Not retten mit der Sojus-Kapsel, aber das wäre schon ein Rückschlag, wenn das jetzt nicht klappen würde. Aber die erste ATV-Mission war extrem erfolgreich. Das ist ja ein Automated Transfer Vehicle. Das Ding dockt vollautomatisch an, so mit Laserstrahlen und so.
Der guckt aber sehr ernst da.
Ja, die sind auch glaube ich zum ersten gespannt da.
Wahrscheinlich warten die auch auf. Der Kurs 10.7 live.
Genau.
Und wir gucken, ob ihr App endlich durch ein erstes Review durchkommt. Naja, haben wir das doch eigentlich so quasi fast hinter uns gebracht. Achso, Janik, was ich noch mal positiv, ich wollte ja noch mal dem Fuchs danken, weil das wollte ich schon vor zwei Sendungen machen, weil die haben mir die Festplatte ausgewechselt, so ratzfatz und ganz auf die Schnelle und schön noch am Abend und ich bin vorbei und eine Viertelstunde später konnte ich meinen Rechner wieder abholen. Und dann habe ich hier in der Sendung, ne, habe ich hier das Backup wieder eingespielt, ne, habe ich nicht gemacht, aber da saß ich mit einer schönen neuen Festplatte.
Der freundlichste und lustigste Computerladen.
Genau. Und jetzt habe ich dann nach dir benannt, Tim. Die heißt jetzt Timmy, die Festplatte.
Ich hab ja heute noch mal die Folge gesehen, wo alle ins Hauspark metrosexuell werden und dann auch Timmy im Rollstuhl sitzen sah, Timmy.
Welche Folge ist das?
Sucht einfach nach South Park und metrosexuell und ihr werdet diese Folge finden. Das ist auch sehr unterhaltsam eigentlich. Also die ersten zwei Drittel, dann wird es ein bisschen wild. Ja, also bei South Park gibt es auch zu allem schon...
Jetzt hast du den Raketenstart verpasst.
Jetzt sind es aber nur noch vier Minuten, das können wir jetzt aber noch durchhalten.
Wir machen jetzt die Aftershow weiter als gestern.
Wir machen die Aftershow jetzt hier schön.
Was war denn gestern und warum haben sie gecancelt?
Wir machen die Aftershow, das heißt wir machen die Sendung jetzt erst mal zu Ende noch vor dem Start und danach gibt es nur noch Aftershow.
Oh Gott, und die Podcast-Hörer werden hier?
Muss ich da die Hose runterlassen?
Was? Nein, wir sagen jetzt schön Tschüss. Dann ist die Sendung vorbei.
Aber wir quatschen noch weiter auf dem Stream.
Ja, wir bleiben auf dem Stream.
Aber ich will nicht nur schlafen gehen.
Wir können noch weiter aufnehmen.
Dann können sich die Leute auch reinziehen.
Nein, das ist langweilig. Los, wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Die hören sich den Rest ja auch an.
Schluss! Tschüss.
Das war's.
Wir haben es gar nicht.
Das war die Sendung, die immer noch nicht weiß, wie sie heißt.
Und die Mitglieder wissen auch nicht, wie sie heißen.
Der Max, der Tim, der Dennis und der ich. Wir sagen jetzt Tschüss.